WELCOME.
TO RCT INFORMATIONAL HEARING.
.
WELCOME THE SECOND OF OUR
INFORMATIONAL HEARINGS ON THE
FUTURE OF CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION.
IN CALIFORNIA'S K. TWELVE
SCHOOLS.
TODAY'S HEARING IS JOIN WE
HOSTED BY FOR ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEES.
EDUCATION COMMITTEE OF WHICH I
AM A CHAIR BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
ON EDUCATION FINANCE.
CHAIR MCCARTY IS NOT HERE YET IF
HE'S COMING BY. THE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON CAREER. AND
TECHNICAL EDUCATION ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BURKE IS THE CHAIR OF
THAT.
JOBS AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
AND THE ECONOMY COMMITTEE. A
CHAIRED BY.
SHARON QUIRK SILVA.
AND I'VE GOOD THERE SHE IS SHE
IS HERE. SO I'D LIKE TO.
WELCOME ALL OF MY COLLEAGUES
THAT ARE HERE TODAY.
AND TODAY IT MUCH ATTENTION HAS.
LARGE KITCHEN SYSTEM HAS FOCUSED
ON COLLEGE READINESS WERE ALWAYS
TALKING ABOUT COLLEGE READINESS
OR COLLEGE ENTRANCE.
BUT THERE'S ALSO CLEAR NEED TO
FOCUS ON CAREER READINESS AND
CLEAR EXPLORATION BOTH TO MEET
THE NEEDS OF STUDENTS BUT ALSO
TO MEET WORKFORCE DEMANDS.
THIS TOPIC BENEFIT STUDENTS FOR
SURE BUT ALSO THE CALIFORNIA
ECONOMY WHICH HAS SO MANY JOBS
TO GO WANTING.
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE STUDENTS
WITH THAT TECHNICAL SKILL SET
AND IN FACT FOR ABOUT THE LAST
TWENTY FIVE YEARS WE HAVEN'T
TRIED TO DEVELOP IT.
AT THE K. TWELVE LEVEL BUT I'VE
RECENTLY WE AWAKENED AND NOW
THIS EFFORT IS TO KEEP THAT THAT
THAT.
RCT FUNDING ALIVE.
SCHOOLS MUST REPAIR ALL STUDENTS
FOR A WORLD BEYOND HIGH SCHOOL
WHETHER THEY ARE.
WHERE THEY CHOOSE TO GO TO A TWO
OR FOUR YEAR COLLEGE?
OR TRADE SCHOOL IF THEY CHOOSE
TO GO DIRECTLY INTO THE
WORKFORCE.
THE CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION
CENTER GRANTS HAVE NOT BEEN A
KEY SOURCE OF SUPPORT FOR CT
PROGRAMS.
A RECENT YEARS
BUT THESE FUNDS ARE SET TO
EXPIRE THIS YEAR.
CG PROGRAMS MUST CONTINUE TO BE
A PRIORITY FOR OUR EDUCATION
SYSTEM.
AND AS A STATE WE NEED TO
MAINTAIN AND BUILD ON THE
INVESTMENTS HAVE ALREADY BEEN
MADE IN THESE PROGRAMS AND IN
OUR OUR SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITIES.
AND I KNOW THERE MAY BE SOME
OTHER A MEMBERS HERE WISH TO
COMMENT QUICKLY QUICKLY PLEASE
BUT JUST FOR ME OTHERS SAY WHY
I'M HERE.
AND I'M THAT'S NOT WHY I'M HERE
TODAY THAT'S WHY I'M IN THE
ASSEMBLY IT'S MY. MY EXPERIENCES
TEACHERS WHEN I BRING HERE AND.
I SAW MANY KIDS FALL OFF THE
PATH OF HIGH SCHOOL SUCCESS
BECAUSE THERE JUST WASN'T.
SOMETHING OF A HIGH SCHOOL TO
ENGAGE THEM.
THEY WEREN'T GOING TO A FOUR
YEAR UNIVERSITY THEY KNEW THAT
THAT WAS NOT IN THEIR PLAN.
YET WE DIDN'T ACCOMMODATE BARREL
THERE I'M.
THEIR GOALS
AND I SEE THIS WE NEED TO OFFER
MULTIPLE PATHS TO SUCCESS THE
STATE FOR ALL OF OUR STUDENTS.
AND THAT'S WHAT THIS EFFORT IS
ABOUT.
I WE HAD CD FUNDING FOR WHAT THE
LAST THREE YEARS THIS IS ABOUT
KEEPING IT GOING FORWARD. US
WITH THAT OF THEIR ANY MEMBERS
WISH TO COMIC QUICKLY WILL GO
AROUND.
TO GIPSON DOESN'T MISTER CARLY
DOESN'T. I'M I LIKE THIS.
I WAS YOUR CHáVEZ.
TO FRAZIER.
CUNNINGHAM.
GOD.
I WOULD JUST LIKE.
YOU KNOW.
PEOPLE BACK HOME ASK ME.
WITH ABOUT EXAMPLES OF
BIPARTISANSHIP AND PEOPLE
WORKING ACROSS THE AISLE. FOR
THE BETTERMENT OF CALIFORNIA FOR
KIDS I ALWAYS POINT OUR EFFORTS.
ON CAREER ATTACK AD.
I THINK IT IS ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT ISSUES.
FOR OUR KIDS FOR OUR ECONOMY.
FOR FUTURE SKILLED LABOR FORCE
I'D LIKE TO.
THANK THE CHAIR ASSEMBLYMAN
O'DONNELL FOR HIS PERSISTENT
LEADERSHIP IN THIS ISSUE.
AND UNITED CONSTITUENT YOU MAIL
ME WHEN I FIRST START TALKING
ABOUT CT .
THEY WROTE TO ME SAID YOU KNOW
IF IT WASN'T FOR WHAT YOU SPEAK
CALLED BOQUETE.
PROGRAMS I WOULD'VE FINISHED
HIGH SCHOOL.
YOU KNOW BUT I FOUND OUT THROUGH
THOSE CLASSES IN HIGH SCHOOL.
THAT I LOVE MACHINERY. ABOUT
FIXING THINGS ALL WORK WITH MY
HANDS.
STATE HIGH SCHOOL I FINISH I
GRADUATE I JOIN THE MILITARY.
I LEARNED HOW TO SERVICE AND
REPAIR HELICOPTERS.
AND WHEN I GOT OUT OF THE
MILITARY WHEN I FINISHED SERVING
THE COUNTRY. I START A
HELICOPTER REPAIR BUSINESS.
HE IS NOW A MULTI MILLIONAIRE.
AND HE WAS WRITING ME SAY AND
KEEP UP THE FIGHT ON CAREER TECH
ED. IT CHANGES LIVES.
SO THANK YOU FOR INDULGING ME ON
THAT STATEMENT.
GREAT THANK YOU KNOW I LIKE THE
LAST PART OF THAT IS JUST CHANGE
LIVES.
AND IT HELPS MAKE STUDENTS
SUCCESSFUL NOT ONLY IN HIGH
SCHOOL.
BUT OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL WAS A
DUAL EFFORT FROM MY PERSPECTIVE
UP.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK SILVA.
THANK YOU CHAIR O'DONNELL I AS
THE CHAIR OF THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON JOBS I WANT TO.
WELCOME EVERYBODY FOR BEING
HERE AND JUST REMIND PEOPLE THAT
DOES THIS HAS BEEN A SERIES OF
HEARINGS ON C. T. E. AND WE WERE
A VERY EXCITED TO HOST MANY OF
YOU IN OUR DISTRICT AND WHAT A
PARK. WHERE WE HAVE A SAW FIRST
HAND SOME OF THE? ACTUAL C. T.
E. PROGRAMS THAT DOES THAT VICE
SCHOOL WAS SHOWCASING THOSE
INCLUDING ON AUTOMOTIVE PROGRAM
AG PROGRAM CULINARY. AYE EVEN
AYE MORE EXCITING ARTISTS THAT
SEVERAL OF THOSE PROGRAMS FINAL
RIGHT IN TWO OTHER COMMUNITY
COLLEGE CYPRESS COMMUNITY
COLLEGE WHERE THOSE AUTOMOTIVE
STUDENTS THEN MOVE INTO THE
CYPRESS COMMUNITY COLLEGE
PROGRAM. AND ARE ACTUALLY
RECRUITED RIGHT OUT OF THAT
PROGRAM.
WITH TOYOTA BEING ONE OF THEIR
PARTNERS AND ARE DOING EXTREMELY
WELL AS FAR AS NOT ONLY A SALARY
BUT HAVING THE TRAINING WITH THE
TECHNOLOGY. SO WE KNOW AS FAR
AS.
THE WORK FORCE ONE OF OUR MAIN
FUNCTIONS.
THAT WE ARE FOCUSING ON IS TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE DOING WHAT
WE ARE DOING IN THE CT  IS
IN DIRECT RELATION. UP TO THE
JOB MARKET AND WHAT WE KNOW THAT
OUR EMPLOYERS ARE ASKING FOR
WHETHER IT'S FUTURE IN
TECHNOLOGY WHETHER IT'S A WORK
FORCE US SET OF SKILLS. AND US
SO WE'LL CONTINUE FOCUSING ON
WITHOUT LANDS BUT. I'M EXCITED
BE HERE THANK YOU SO MUCH GEAT
THANK YOU.
AND I SIERRA CELLULAR TOWERS
HERE AND DOCTOR WEBER.
AND MISS BURKE HAS JOINED US TOO
DID YOU WANT TO SAY ANYTHING
QUICKLY AND ANY OF YOU.
DOESN'T LOOK LIKE IT OF A GREAT
WITH US MOVE OUR FIRST PANEL
BECAUSE THAT'S WHO WE'RE REALLY
HERE TO HEAR FROM. ALL FIRST
BRING UP ARE.
NATASHA COLLINS FROM
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
DONNA Y. AT FROM THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
AND AMBER ALEXANDER AND LISA
BRZEZINSKI FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE.
AND THERE IS AN ALLEY ó HAND
OUT I BELIEVE IT'S IN YOUR
PACKET.
AND YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN READY
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON NATASHA COLLINS
FROM THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE
I WE'VE BEEN ASKED TO PROVIDE A
BROAD OVERVIEW OF HIGH SCHOOL
CAREER TECHNICAL ON IT EDUCATION
THAT'S GOING TO BUILD UPON THE
OCTOBER SECOND HEARING.
THAT YOU ALL PARTICIPATED IN.
WE'RE GOING TO BE PROVIDING THAT
OVERVIEW THEN WILL BE.
PROVIDING AN OVERVIEW OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL.
AND OTHER CT PROPOSALS AS WELL
SOME COMMENTS.
AS THE CHAIR MENTIONED YOU'LL
BE.
MEETINGS WITH A HANDOUT THAT WE
PROVIDED BEFOREHAND. ENTITLED
OVERVIEW OF CREEK TECHNICAL
EDUCATION. WILL START ON THE
FIRST PAGE WHICH SHOWS THE
FIFTEEN INDUSTRY SECTORS.
BUT THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION HAS DESIGNATED FOR
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION.
HIGH SCHOOL'S REALLY ORGANIZE
THEIR CT  AROUND THESE
INDUSTRY AREAS WHICH RANGE FROM
MANUFACTURING TO INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY IN ARTS AND MEDIA.
WITHIN EACH INDUSTRY AREA THE CD
THAT IS THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION HAS DEVELOPED MODEL
CURRICULUM STANDARDS THAT HIGH
SCHOOL PROGRAMS FOLLOW. AYE INS
IN ORDER TO QUALIFY AS A HIGH
QUALITY CTE PROGRAM.
TURNING TO PAGE TWO.
WE KNOW THAT IN OFFERING CT AT
HIGH SCHOOLS THERE ARE.
SEVERAL OBJECTIVES AND HERE ARE
THE FOUR PRIMARY OBJECTIVES THAT
WE'VE IDENTIFIED.
FIRST TO PROMOTE STUDENT
ENGAGEMENT AND OFTENTIMES TO
TEACH ACADEMIC SUBJECTS IN A
HANDS ON WAY.
SECOND TO TEACH TECHNICAL SKILLS
TO STUDENTS.
THIRD TO TEACH SOFT SKILLS SUCH
AS COMMUNICATION AND TEAM
BUILDING.
AND FOURTH TO HELP MEET STATE
WORK FORCE NEEDS
THAT'S ONE OF THE STATE.
WORKFORCE PLANS GOALS TO PROVIDE
MORE MIDDLE SKILLED WORKERS IN
CT AND HIGH SCHOOLS OFTENTIMES
HAS AN OBJECTIVE TO DO THAT.
MOVING TO PAGE THREE WE PROVIDE
INFORMATION ABOUT THE STATE'S
APPROACH TO FUNDING CT  AT
HIGH SCHOOLS OVER TIME.
PRIOR TO THE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA THE STATE
SUPPORTED CTE THROUGH VARIOUS
CATEGORICAL PROGRAMS THOSE ARE
EARMARKED PROGRAMS FOR SPECIFIC
PURPOSES IN THIS CASE CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION.
THE LARGEST OF THESE AIR MARK
PROGRAMS WAS THE SAHARA CP ALSO
KNOWN AS THE REGIONAL
OCCUPATIONAL CENTERS AND
PROGRAMS AT ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY.
WHEN THE STATE TRANSITION TO THE
LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA
AND TWENTY THIRTEEN FOURTEEN.
CATEGORICAL PROGRAM FUNDING
INCLUDING OUR OCP THAT FUNDING
WAS LARGELY ELIMINATED AND
ROLLED INTO THE NEW FORMULA.
WHICH PROVIDED A NOTABLY HIGHER
BASE RATE FOR HIGH SCHOOL
PROGRAMS AND RECOGNITION OF THE
HIGHER COSTS OF PROGRAMS LIKE
CREW TECHNICAL EDUCATION AND.
OTHER COLLEGE PREPAREDNESS
PROGRAMS.
WHILE THE ROC PEEPER GRIMACE
ROLL THEN SEVERAL SMALLER
CATEGORICAL CTT PROGRAMS FOR NOT
THEY STAYED OUTSIDE OF THE LC A
FIVE.
THE STATE ORIGINALLY INTENDED TO
PHASE EN EL CFF FUNDING OVER
SEVERAL YEARS PIE AS STATE
REVENUES INCREASED.
WITH THE ORIGINAL PROJECTION OF
MEETING FULL FUNDING AND TWENTY
TWENTY. ONE TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE.
THE STATE FUNDED SEVERAL
TRANSITIONAL PROGRAMS DURING
THIS TIME AS IT MOVED TOWARDS
THAT FULL FUNDING.
FIRST IN ADDITION TO ROLLING THE
RCP FUNDS INTO THE NEW FORMULA.
OF THOSE THAT WERE RECEIVING
THOSE FUNDS WERE REQUIRED FOR
TWO YEARS TO KEEP SPENDING THAT
MONEY ON CT PROGRAMS IN THEIR
DISTRICTS.
AFTER THAT.
THE STATE ADOPTED THE UMPS CCP
TEETH THE CAREER PATHWAYS TRUST
WHICH WAS FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS OVER TWO YEARS AND THEN
THE CT INCENTIVE GRANT WHICH I'M
YOU HEARD ABOUT A BIT EARLIER.
WHICH WAS A THREE YEAR NINE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR PROGRAM
WHICH PROVIDED FUNDING THROUGH
TWENTY SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN SO
THIS CURRENT YEAR.
THE SEATING INCENTIVE GRANTS AND
DECREASE STATE FUNDING AS IT
INCREASED A LOCAL MATCH
REQUIREMENT AT THE SAME TIME.
MOVING TO PAGE
FOR YOU'LL SEE THE STATE'S
APPROACH TO ACCOUNTABILITY UNDER
THE LC FF FOUR CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION.
CURRENTLY SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE
REQUIRED TO DISCUSS WITH THEIR
COMMUNITIES HOW THEY'LL ENGAGE
STUDENTS IN A VARIETY OF AREAS.
I INCLUDING A CAREER AND
TECHNICAL EDUCATION THEY DO THIS
THROUGH THEIR LOCAL CONTROL AND
ACCOUNTABILITY PANT PLAN WHICH
IS A STATE REQUIRED STRATEGIC
PLAN DISTRICTS ARE REQUIRED TO
SUBMIT.
TO INCENTIVIZE SCHOOLS TO SERVE
STUDENTS IN THE BEST WAY
POSSIBLE.
AND ALSO TO SIGNAL TO THE STATE
IF SCHOOLS NEED HELP.
IMPROVING THE STATE REQUIRES
DISTRICTS TO REPORT ON STUDENT
OUTCOMES ON A NUMBER OF AREAS
INCLUDING COLLEGE AND CAREER
READINESS.
THIS DATA IS DISPLAYED ON A
PUBLIC WEDS WEBSITE KNOWN AS THE
SCHOOL DASHBOARD.
IF SCHOOLS DO NOT DO WELL ON
DASHBOARD INDICATORS THEY WILL
NEED TO ASSESS THE ROOT CAUSES
OF THEIR PERFORMANCE ISSUES AND
ACCESS SUPPORT TO IMPROVE.
OUT COME DATA DISPLAYED ON
SCHOOL DASHBOARD AND TWENTY
SEVENTEEN I WAS THE FIRST YEAR
THAT WE SAW THE COLLEGE AND
CAREER READINESS INDICATOR.
WHAT INDICATED WAS THAT FIFTY
PERCENT?
OF CALIFORNIA STUDENTS WERE
DEEMED.
I'M COLLEGE
CAREER PREPARED.
TWENTY FIVE WERE DEEMED NOT
PREPARED AND TWENTY FIVE PERCENT
ARE AND TWENTY FIVE PERCENT WERE
DEEMED APPROACHING PREPARED.
IF YOU LOOK ON PAGE FIVE OF YOUR
HANDOUT YOU'LL SEE A FIGURE IN
WHICH WE WALK THROUGH THE
INDICATOR AND. THE DIFFERENT
METRICS THAT ARE INVOLVED IN
CALCULATING AT.
YOU'LL SEE THE A PREPARED
APPROACHING PREPARED ND NOT
PREPARED ARE ON THIS GRAPHIC I
WOULD NOTE THAT THE STATE BOARD
OF EDUCATION HAS INDICATED THAT
THEY INTEND TO ADD A WELL
PREPARED.
VINDICATOR.
THAT WOULD INCLUDE MORE METRICS
OF CT E. INCLUDING THE NUMBER OF
STUDENTS THAT PARTICIPATED IN
WORK BASED LEARNING. AND
ACQUIRED CERTIFICATES.
ON PAGE SIX.
WE PROVIDE A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF
THE GOVERNOR'S TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN CT  PROPOSAL.
ALTHOUGH THE ADMINISTRATION
WILL PROVIDE GREATER DETAIL ON
THIS PROPOSAL LEADER IN THIS
PANEL.
THE GOVERNOR PROPOSES TO ALLOW
THE CT INCENTIVE GRANT TO SUNSET
IN THE CURRENT YEAR. AND INSTEAD
TO PROVIDE THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE WITH TWO
HUNDRED AND TWELVE MILLION
DOLLARS AN ONGOING FUNDING FOR
HIGH SCHOOL CT . THROUGH
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES STRONG
WORK FORCE PROGRAM.
STRONG WORK FORCE IS A PROGRAM
THAT FUNDS EIGHT REGIONAL
CONSORTIA WHICH DEVELOP AND
IMPLEMENT PLANS.
DESIGNED TO MEET THE REGIONAL
WORKFORCE NEEDS.
OF THE TWO HUNDRED TWELVE
MILLION PROPOSED FOR THE HEIST
FOR HIGH SCHOOL TO BECOME A PART
OF THIS REGIONAL APPROACH TO CT
TWO HUNDRED MILLION WOULD BE FOR
DIRECT SERVICE SAYS. FOR CT AT
HIGH SCHOOLS.
REGION'S WOULD RECEIVE THE FUNDS
BASED ON THEIR SHARE OF
STATEWIDE ADA I KNOW I'M.
INACCURACY IN OUR HAND OUT IT'S
NOT JUST HIGH SCHOOL ABA IT'S
SEVEN THROUGH TWELVE EIGHTY A.
THAT WOULD BE ONE COMPONENT
COMPONENT OF DETERMINING HOW
MUCH REGION'S RECEIVE.
ALSO BE DETERMINED BASED ON THE
NUMBER OF JOB OPENINGS AND THE
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE. IN THAT
SCHOOL DISTRICTS REGION.
FROM THERE AFTER WE DETERMINE
THE THE FUNDING AMOUNT OF.
FOR EACH OF THE REGIONS.
OF THE CONSORTIA WOULD DETERMINE
THROUGH A COMPETITIVE BASIS
WHICH SCHOOL DISTRICTS WOULD
RECEIVE THE MONEY IN ORDER TO
OFFER.
WORKFORCE ALIGNS CT.
SCHOOL DISTRICTS WOULD ALSO BE
REQUIRED TO PROVIDE A ONE TO TWO
MATCH FOR THE FUNDING.
I WOULD JUST EMPHASIZE THAT
DISTRICTS COULD ONLY USE THEIR
FUNDING FROM THIS PROGRAM TO
OFFER CTE COURSES THAT ARE IN
THE INDUSTRY AREAS THAT ARE
ALIGNED WITH THEIR STRONG WORK
FORCE REGIONAL PLANTS.
THE REMAINING TWELVE MILLION
DOLLARS WOULD BE FOR SEVENTY TWO
PATHWAY COORDINATORS THAT WOULD
WORK WITH SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
HELP THEM COURTNEY PROGRAMS WITH
THEIR STRONG WORK FORCE PLANS.
AS WELL AS PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO THOSE PROGRAMS.
WHAT ALSO NOTE THAT THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSES TO FULLY FUND THE LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA TWO
YEARS AHEAD OF SCHEDULE? IN THE
BUDGET YEAR THIS WOULD EQUATE TO
A NINE THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED
DOLLARS AS A HIGH SCHOOL BAY
STREET. WHICH IS ABOUT THREE
THOUSAND DOLLARS MORE THAN THE
PER PUPIL HIGH SCHOOL BASE ATE
WHEN WE BEGAN ALL CFF AND
TWENTY.
ARE THIRTEEN FOURTEEN.
ON PAGE SEVEN WE PROVIDE OUR
ASSESSMENT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL.
WE RAISE CONCERNS WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO CREATE A
CASE THROUGH TWELVE CT
CATEGORICAL PROGRAM. DESPITE LC
FF BEING FULLY FUNDED AND THE
USE OF THE COLLEGE AND CAREER
READINESS INDICATOR BEGINNING.
I'M TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
UNDER LC FF EVERY HIGH SCHOOL IS
EXPECTED TO PROVIDE COLLEGE AND
CAREER READINESS TO STUDENTS
WE HAVE CONCERNS THAT MOVING
BACK TO A CATEGORICAL APPROACH
COULD BE A SIGNAL THAT CT IS
VIEWED IN AT AS AN ADD ON TO THE
HIGHEST COURT HIGH SCHOOL
EXPERIENCE. RATHER THAN A PART
OF IT.
IN ADDITION WE HAVE CONCERNS OF
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL DEFINE
CCT  TOO NARROWLY. HIGH
SCHOOL CT HAS VARIOUS SCHOOLS IN
ADDITION TO MEETING REGIONAL
WORKFORCE NEEDS.
LASTLY WE HAVE CONCERNS THAT THE
PROPOSAL DOES NOT INCLUDE
SEVERAL OF THE OTHER CATEGORICAL
PROGRAMS THAT STILL EXIST
OUTSIDE OF THE LC A FAST.
WHEN COMPARED TO THE CT
INCENTIVE GRANT WE THINK THE
INCENTIVE GRANT APPROACH HAS A
FEW ADVANTAGES OVER THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL.
FIRST IT PROVIDES HIGH SCHOOLS
WITH MORE FLEXIBILITY TO OFFER
SITU  AN INDUSTRY AREAS NOT
ONLY THOSE THAT ARE ALIGNED WITH
THE REGIONAL WORKFORCE NEEDS.
SECOND THE PROGRAM IS OVERSEEN
BY THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION WHICH HAS GREATER
EXPERTISE IN CT CURRICULUM
STANDARDS. AND HIGH SCHOOL CT
OVERALL.
PAGE EIGHT OF YOUR HANDOUT
DESCRIBES AB SEVENTEEN FORTY
THREE. WHICH PROPOSES TO EXTEND
THE CT INCENTIVE GRANT FOR THREE
ADDITIONAL YEARS AN INCREASE
FUNDING.
SPECIFICALLY IT WOULDN'T IT
WOULD PROVIDE FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY TO
SCHOOLS TO PREFER TO PROVIDE
HIGH QUALITY CT  AND
REQUIRE A ONE TO ONE MATCH.
THE FUNDING WOULD BE INTENDED AS
TRANSITIONAL FUNDING TO FULL
IMPLEMENTATION OF ALL CFF AND
THE FINAL DEVELOPMENT AT THE
COLLEGE AND CAREER READINESS
INDICATOR.
THE BILL ALSO ALSO ESTABLISHES
PERFORMANCE REQUIREMENTS THAT
WOULD REQUIRE PROGRAMS TO BE
DEEMED SUCCESSFUL BY THE CD
IN ORDER TO CONTINUE TO
RECEIVE FUNDING.
AT SEVERAL OTHER REQUIREMENTS
SUCH AS PROVIDING OPPORTUNITIES
TO STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES
AND TO STUDENT CT ORGANIZATIONS.
PAGE NINE OUTLINES OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
LEGISLATURE WITH REGARD TO
MOVING FORWARD TO CT.
WE BELIEVE THERE ARE MANY
BENEFITS TO THE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA APPROACH.
THE FORMULA IS FULLY FUNDED IN
THE BUDGET YEAR WE'VE HAD FIVE
YEARS OF TRANSITIONAL FUNDING.
AND WE HAVE OF ITS
COLLEGE AND CAREER READINESS
INDICATOR.
FOR THIS REASON WE RECOMMEND
THAT THE LEGISLATURE TAKE THE
LCF APPROACH WE BELIEVE THAT IF
IF THE LEGISLATURE HAS CONCERNS
INSTEAD OF CREATING A
CATEGORICAL PROGRAM. IT CAN A
ADDRESS THOSE CONCERNS IN OTHER
WAYS FOR EXAMPLE IF THE CONCERN
IS THAT NOT ENOUGH FUNDING IS
PROVIDED TO HIGH SCHOOLS OFFER
CT THE LEGISLATURE CAN REVISIT
THE HIGH SCHOOL FUNDING AMOUNT.
IF THE CONCERN IS THAT THERE'S
NOT STRONG ENOUGH INCENTIVES
THROUGH THE ACCOUNTABILITY.
THAT WE CURRENTLY HAVE WE THINK
THE LEGISLATURE COULD REVISIT
ACCOUNTABILITY AND WE HAVE SOME
IDEAS TO SHERIFF IF THAT ISN'T
INTEREST. OF ON THE COMMITTEES.
HOWEVER IF THE LEGISLATURE DOES
WISH TO TAKE THE CATEGORICAL
APPROACH TO CUT TO CT . WE
RECOMMEND TAKING THE CT
INCENTIVE GRANT APPROACH WITH
SOME MODIFICATIONS THAT BRING
IN.
SOME OF THE COORDINATION THAT
THE GOVERNOR SUGGESTS.
SPECIFICALLY. A WE BELIEVE THAT
A LINING A PORTION OF THE CT
FUNDING TO WORKFORCE NEEDS BUT
NOT ALL OF IT COULD HELP WITH
ALIGNMENT BETWEEN COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. AND K. TWELVE CT
PROGRAMS.
WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT REQUIRING
THE CD  AND THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES TO SHARE DATA
ACCOUNTABILITY. COULD STRENGTHEN
COORDINATION FOR EXAMPLE BY
REQUIRING QUE TWELVE AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO LINK DATA
SUCH THAT WE COULD SEE ONE A
STUDENT LEAVES HIGH SCHOOL IF
THEY ENTER CT PROGRAM IF THEY'RE
REMEDIATED AND HOW WELL THEY
PERFORM AFTER THAT STAGE.
TO FURTHER COORDINATE WE
RECOMMEND ROLLING IN THE
OUTSTANDING CATEGORICAL PROGRAMS
THAT ARE STILL OUTSIDE OF THE LC
FF IN TO ANY NEW CATEGORICAL
PROGRAM TO REDUCE ADMINISTRATIVE
BURDEN AND PROVIDE MORE
STREAMLINED APPROACH.
SO THAT THE LEGISLATURE CAN
REVISIT IN FUTURE YEARS TO SEE
IF THIS PROGRAM IS MEETING ITS
GOALS WE RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE CONSIDER MAKING THE
PROGRAM LIMITED TERM AND SETTING
VERY CLEAR DATA. EXPECTATIONS AS
WELL AS TARGETS FOR SCHOOLS.
IN THAT WAY THE LEGISLATURE
COULD COME BACK IN SEVERAL YEARS
AND EVALUATE WHETHER IT'S
MEETING THE GOALS THAT WERE PUT
FORTH.
FOR FUNDING THE PROGRAM WE THINK
THE LEGISLATURE NEEDS TO
CONSIDER THE TRADEOFFS OF HOW
MUCH FUNDING TO PROVIDE.
FUNDING THAT GOES TOWARDS A
CATEGORICAL PROGRAM IS FUNDING
THAT MAY NOT BE AVAILABLE FOR
OTHER PRIORITIES OR FOR THE
LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA.
WE THINK THE LEGISLATURE COULD
CONSIDER SETTING THE AMOUNT AT A
RATE THAT SIGNALS.
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT THIS
PROGRAM IS SUPPLEMENTAL TO THE
LCF AFTER THEIR SPENDING ON CT
. AND NOT THE CORE FUNDING
SOURCE FOR CT.
I WITH THAT I'M OF CONCLUDE MY
COMMENTS I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU. GREAT THANK
YOU LET'S HEAR FROM OUR MYSTARA
Y. IT FROM THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT EDUCATION WILL FINISH
THE PANEL. THAT WILL HAVE
QUESTIONS.
GOOD AFTERNOON DONNA Y. IT
DIRECTOR OF THE CAREER IN
COLLEGE TRANSITION DIVISION AT
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION.
YOU CAN SPEAK TO YOU TODAY ABOUT
SOME OF THE OUTCOMES THAT WE'RE
SEEING UNDER THE SEA TAG
INCENTIVE GRANT. AND THEN ALSO
THE DIRECTION OF K. THROUGH
TWELVE CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION. MUCH OF THE
INFORMATION THAT I'M GONNA
PRESENT TODAY WAS ACTUALLY PUT
TOGETHER BY THE SEVEN SEAT TAKE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE CENTERS AND
MANY OF THE LEADERS ARE BEHIND
ME TODAY.
THE LIST OF AWARDEES OF THE
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION
INCENTIVE GRANT WERE SEATED WILL
BE PUBLISHED DURING THE MARCH
STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION
MEETING.
THE THIRD AND FINAL ROUND OF C.
TAKES ON A TOTAL OF THREE
HUNDRED NINETY THREE GRANT
APPLICATIONS WITH THIRTEEN OF
THOSE BEING NEW APPLICANTS.
AND THREE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
BEING GRANT RENEWALS.
DURING THE GRANT PERIOD OF
TWENTY FIFTEEN TO TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THE REQUEST FOR FUNDS
TOTALED JUST UNDER NINE HUNDRED
AND SIXTY FIVE MILLION.
ENROLLMENT NUMBERS FOR CT
PROGRAMS UNDER THE THREE YEARS
OF SEE TAKE HAS INCREASED TWELVE
PERCENT.
CT ENROLLMENT HAS INCREASED OVER
TWENTY TWO PERCENT SINCE TWENTY
ELEVEN TWELVE.
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN
FIFTY FIVE PERCENT OF HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS WERE ENROLLED IN
CT PROGRAMS WITH INFORMATION AND
COMMUNICATIONS TECHNOLOGY
BENEFACTIONRING. ENGINEERING
HOSPITALITY TOURISM AND PUBLIC
SERVICES SHOWING THE LARGEST
GROWTH DURING SEATED.
UNDERSEA TAKE SCHOOLS HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO CREATE AN EXPANSIVE TV
PROGRAMS DRIVEN BY STUDENT
INTEREST
CURRENT REGIONAL AND STATEWIDE
LABOR MARKET DATA. INDUSTRY
ADVOCACY AND IN ALIGNMENT WITH
PROGRAMS OFFERED AT THEIR LOCAL
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS.
K. THROUGH TWELVE CT  IS
UNIQUE FROM C. T. PROGRAMS
OFFERED IN COMMUNITY COLLEGE IN
FOUR KEY WAYS.
FIRST THE EMPHASIZE THE
INTEGRATION OF GENERAL EDUCATION
CONTENT AND CURRICULUM WITH CTE
CONTENT AND CURRICULUM.
COURSES ARE BASED ON THE CT
MODEL CURRICULUM STANDARDS WHICH
WERE ADOPTED BY THE STATE BOARD
OF EDUCATION AND TWENTY
THIRTEEN.
STUDENT LEADERSHIP THROUGH
CAREER TECHNICAL STUDENT
ORGANIZATIONS ARE INTEGRAL TO
STUDENT SEATS TWO CT STUDENT
OUTCOMES. AND STUDENTS ARE
PROVIDED WITH THE CONTINUUM OF
WORK BASED LEARNING EXPERIENCES
THROUGH THEIR CT COURSE
SEQUENCES.
OUR EARLY DATA SHOWS US THAT THE
MAJORITY OF SEATED FUNDS WERE
USED FOR THESE VERY PURPOSES.
SEE TAKE FUNDS WERE USED TO
BRING K. THROUGH TWELVE CT
PROGRAMS UP TO CURRENT INDUSTRY
STANDARDS AND EQUIPMENT WITH
CAPITAL OUTLAY DOLLARS BEING
USED FOR STATE OF THE ART
EQUIPMENT LIKE ULTRASOUND
MACHINES. FOR VETERINARIAN
ANIMAL HUSBANDRY ATTIC AG ED
PROGRAMS.
AMBULANCE SIMULATORS FOR
EMERGENCY MEDICINE AND HEALTH
SCIENCE PROGRAMS. AND LASER
CUTTERS FOR MEDI FACTORING
PROGRAMS TO NAME JUST A FEW.
FOR MOST PROGRAMS THIS WAS THE
FIRST SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT IN
INDUSTRY STANDARD EQUIPMENT
SINCE THE RECESSION IN
CATEGORICAL FLECKS OF A WAIT
THROUGH TEN.
DISTRICTS ALSO REPORTED THAT
SEATED FUNDS WERE SPENT ON CT
SPECIFIC PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT AS WELL AS WELL AS
COLLEGE INCORRECT COUNSELORS.
PERHAPS THE MOST EXCITING
ACHIEVEMENT OF SEE TAKE IS THAT
THE MAJORITY OF DISTRICTS
REPORTED TO US THAT CT UNIT IS
NOW EMBEDDED IN THEIR EL CAP.
AND THEIR DISTRICTS HAVE A
RENEWED INTEREST AND COMMITMENT
TO CT.
THE REPORT THAT THE CALIFORNIA
CAREER PATHWAYS TRUST SEE TEGAN
AND NOW THE COLLEGE CAREER
INDICATOR HAVE BEEN INSTRUMENTAL
IN THIS CHANGE.
WELL GRANT RECIPIENTS
PARTICIPATED IN SEATED REPORTED
THAT THEIR DISTRICTS WERE
COMMITTED TO HIGH QUALITY CT.
THEY DID EXPRESS CONCERN ABOUT
THEIR ABILITY TO MAINTAIN
INDUSTRY STANDARD EQUIPMENT. AND
CONTINUING DEDICATED CT
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT WITHOUT
SEATED DOLLARS.
WE SEE TAKE THE CD
ESTABLISH SEVEN COUNTY OFFICES
OF EDUCATION AS REGIONAL
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE PROVIDERS.
THE SEVEN CENTERS WERE CHOSEN
FOR THEIR LEADERSHIP AND
EXPERTISE IN THE DELIVERY OF K.
THROUGH TWELVE CT.
THE SEVEN CENTERS PROVIDED
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT BASED
ON THE UNIQUE REGIONAL AND STATE
WHITE NEEDS OF K. THROUGH TWELVE
CT.
INCLUDING THE MODEL CURRICULUM
STANDARDS. INTEGRATION OF
GENERAL ED COURSES AND CT
CONTENT.
PROJECT BASED LEARNING FUND
COLLEGE AND CAREER PATHWAY
DEVELOPMENT AS DEFINED IN THE
STATE PLANS FOR BOTH PERKINS AND
ESTA.
IN ADDITION TO THE PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT PROVIDED BY THESE
COUNTY TEE A CENTERS THE CAREER
IN COLLEGE TRANSITION DIVISION
AT THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. HAS PROVIDED
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT BY DEDICATING
FOUR DIVISION STAFF AS REGIONAL
SUPPORT TO OUR CITY LEADERS IN
THE FIELD. WHO HAVE THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF PERKINS GRANT
MANAGEMENT?
THE DIVISION ALSO PROVIDES
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT AND
MENTORING. FOR UP TO UP AND
COMING CTE LEADERS THROUGH OUR
CT LEADERSHIP INSTITUTE.
DIVISION STAFF HAS COLLABORATED
WITH OUR CD COLLEAGUES IN THE
EDUCATIONAL DIVERT DATA AND
MANAGEMENT DIVISION TO PROVIDE
STATEWIDE PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT ON UPGRADES TO CAL
PADS THE CALIFORNIA LONGITUDINAL
PEOPLE DATA SYSTEM.
WE ARE ALSO WORKING VERY CLOSELY
WITH STAFF FROM THE ANALYSIS
MEASUREMENT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
DIVISION. ON THE EXPANSION OF
CAREER INDICATORS FOR THE
STATEWIDE COLLEGE CAREER
INDICATOR.
AND MOST FREQUENTLY WE'VE BEEN
COLLABORATING WITH CD COLLEAGUES
IN FACILITIES AND TRANSPORTATION
TO SUPPORT SCHOOL DISTRICTS
THROUGH THE NEW CTE FACILITIES
PROGRAM APPLICATION.
LISTENING TO BEING RESPONSIVE TO
AND PRIORITIZING THE NEEDS OF
THE WEEK THOSE WE SERVE IS THE
NUMBER ONE PRIORITY.
A CAREER IN COLLEGE TRANSITION
DIVISION AT THE CD.
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND BEYOND
WERE PRIORITIZING CT
MIDDLE SCHOOL EXPANSION THROUGH
A PILOT GRANT PROGRAM FOR TEN
MIDDLE SCHOOL CTE PROGRAMS. THAT
ALIGN TO OUR CALIFORNIA
PARTNERSHIP ACADEMIES WERE
CURRENTLY WORKING ON A THREE TO
FIVE YEAR PLAN FOR EXPANSION OF
MIDDLE SCHOOL CT. AND WE EXPECT
TO PUBLISH THE ANNOUNCEMENT FOR
THOSE GRANTS IN MID MARCH.
AN EARLY RESPONSE FROM THE FIELD
IS VERY VERY ENCOURAGING.
AS OF TWENTY THIRTEEN THERE WERE
OVER FOUR HUNDRED CALIFORNIA
PARTNERSHIP ACADEMIES IN THE
STATE.
CPA MODEL HAS OVER THIRTY YEARS
OF PROVEN SUCCESS WITH CPA
STUDENTS OUTPERFORMING NON CPA
STUDENTS. IN GRADUATION RATES
YOU SEE A THROUGH G. RATES
HIGHER GPA HIGHER INTEREST LEVEL
WAGES AND HIGHER COLLEGE GOING
RATES.
CPA'S FOCUS ON THE INTEGRATION
OF GENERAL EDUCATION IN CT
CONTENT WITH WITHIN SPECIFIC
INDUSTRY SECTORS. AND THEY
PROVIDE A SERIES OF WORK BASED
LEARNING EXPERIENCES THAT ALLOW
STUDENTS TO TRY ON CAREERS
THROUGH THEIR INTERACTION WITH
INDUSTRY PROFESSIONALS.
CPA STUDENTS ARE ALSO SUPPORTED
BY A COHORT.
OF TEACHERS AND COUNSELORS
DEDICATED TO THEIR SUCCESS.
PRE APPRENTICESHIP
IS ANOTHER HIGH PRIORITY AND
UNDER THE DIRECTION OF STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TOM TWELVE X. AND.
DIVISION STAFF HAS MET WITH
LEADING LABOR UNION OFFICIALS IN
THE STATE AS WELL AS STATE
LEADERS IN THE CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY. TO DEVELOP A PLAN FOR
THE EXPANSION OF PRE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS TO
ADDRESS THE DEMAND FOR SKILLED
LABOR IN OUR STATE.
CURRENTLY THERE ARE EIGHT PRE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS
OPERATING UNDER THE CPA MODEL.
AND WE PLAN TO EXPAND THOSE WITH
THE SUPPORT OF OUR LABOR AND
INDUSTRY PROFESSIONALS.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE PATHWAYS
ADVISORY COMMITTEE.
WAS CONVENE TWO BIG BEGIN
ADDRESSING THE REQUIREMENT FOR A
NEW STATE CT  PLAN PENDING
THE AUTHORIZATION OF PERKINS.
THIS ADVISORY COMMITTEE IS
COMPOSED OF MEMBERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE DEPARTMENT
STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION AND THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
BOARD OF GOVERNORS.
IN ADDITION TO THIS ADVISORY
COMMITTEE STAFF FROM THE CURRENT
COLLEGE TRANSITION DIVISION AT
THE CD . AND STAFF FROM THE
WORK FORCE IN ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT OFFICE AT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE.
CONTINUE TO WORK.
SORRY.
ONE PAGE.
IN DEFINING THE ELEMENTS OF HIGH
QUALITY COLLEGE AND CAREER
PATHWAYS INCLUDING WORK BASED
LEARNING CAREER READINESS
APTITUDES. EARLY COLLEGE
OPORTUNIDADES AND STUDENT
SUPPORT.
ON A REGIONAL LEVEL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CONTINUE THE GOOD WORK THAT
STARTED UNDER THE CALIFORNIA
CAREER PATH WE STRESSED.
THEY CONTINUED TO CREATE BRIDGES
ACROSS THE TWO SYSTEMS.
TO CREATE DUAL ENROLLMENT AND
ARTICULATION AGREEMENTS AND THE
ALIGNMENT OF COLLEGE AND CAREER
PATHWAYS ACROSS K. THROUGH
TWELVE AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
IN CONCLUSION WITH THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE STATEWIDE
COLLEGE CAREER INDICATOR THERE
IS AN PRESIDENTE DEMAND FOR K.
THROUGH TWELVE CT PROGRAMS.
WHILE THIS IS EXCITING IT'S ALSO
DAUNTING AND OUR CHALLENGE IS TO
ENSURE THAT CTT PROGRAMS MEET
THE STANDARDS OF HIGH QUALITY
CT.
AND ENSURE THAT ALL K. THROUGH
TWELVE CT PROGRAMS ALLOW OUR
STUDENTS TO EXPLORE THEIR CAREER
INTERESTS. AND TO PREPARE FOR
BOTH ENTRY LEVEL EMPLOYMENT AS
WELL AS POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION
AND TRAINING.
CHOICE SHOULD BE UP TO OUR
STUDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES.
OUR JOB IS TO ENSURE THAT
STUDENTS LEAVE OUR SCHOOLS
PREPARE TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE
FULL RANGE OF CAREER IN POST
SECONDARY OPTIONS AVAILABLE TO
THEM.
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND ATTENTION AND FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF K. THROUGH TWELVE
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION.
THANK YOU MISS WHITE. OF I JUST
DO WANNA GO THE PRESIDENT'S
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CERVANTES MORE
SUCI. BAKER HAS JOINED SPEAKERS
JOIN US MR MCCARTY.
AND MISTER BERMAN'S JOIN US AS
WELL I DON'T THINK I'VE BEEN
DOING ANY FROM INFORMATIONAL
HEARING IN THIS CAPITAL EVER.
WHERE THERE'S BEEN THIS?
MANY MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY SO
I THINK THAT SHOWS THE INTEREST
IN THIS EFFORT SO. I THINK WE'RE
IN A GOOD SPOT.
.
WITH THAT WITH THAT WE'RE GONNA
HEAR FROM.
MISS AMBER ALEXANDER AND LISA
BUCZYNSKI FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND I APOLOGIZE IF I DID
NOT SAY THAT LAST NAME CORRECTLY
YOU CAN CORRECT ME.
WHEN YOU ARE UP.
THAT AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS AMBER ALEXANDER WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
BUILDING OFF THE LA OWES HIGH
LEVEL SUMMARY OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL I'M GONNA TAKE MY TIME
TO DOUBLE WILL BUT DEEPER INTO
SOME OF THE SPECIFIC. ELEMENTS
OF THE PROPOSAL TO ESTABLISH A
K. TWELVE SPECIFIC COMPONENT
WITHIN THE STRONG WORKFORCE
PROGRAM.
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL IS
BUILT TO ENSURE THE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR STUDENTS TO
EXPLORE AND SELECT PATHWAYS INTO
MIDDLE SCHOOL CAREERS CONTINUE
AFTER THE END OF THE CT
INCENTIVE GRANT.
AS A REMINDER THE CT INCENTIVE
GRANT WAS DESIGNED AS A SHORT
TERM TRANSITION PROGRAM TO HELP
DISTRICTS COVER THE COSTS OF CT
WHAT THE LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA OR ELSE YET THAT WAS
BEING FACED AND.
THE LC FF BASED GRANT AMOUNT
INCLUDES A TWO POINT SIX PERCENT
ADJUSTMENT FOR GRADES NINE
THROUGH TWELVE. WHICH IS
INTENDED TO ACCOUNT FOR THE
HIGHER COST OF PROVIDING CTE
PROGRAMS AT THE HIGH SCHOOL
LEVEL.
ASSUMING FULL IMPLEMENTATION AND
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN THIS
SPACECRAFT ADJUSTMENT WILL
AMOUNT TO APPROXIMATELY FOUR
HUNDRED AND THIRTY MILLION AN
ONGOING FUNDING. THAT HAS BEEN
BUILT INTO THE LC FF FACE THE
CAN BE USED TO SUPPORT ROBUST CT
PROGRAMS TO THE EXTENT THAT
THOSE PROGRAMS ARE LOCAL
PRIORITY.
WELL THE ADMINISTRATION STILL
CONTENDS THAT FUNDING ALLOCATED
THROUGH THE LC FF SHOULD PAY FOR
A FULL RANGE OF EDUCATIONAL
COSTS INCLUDING CT.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES
TWO HUNDRED MILLION ONGOING
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
FUNDING.
TO PROVIDE AN EXTRA INCENTIVE
FOR LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES
TO OFFER HIGH QUALITY CD
PROGRAMS THAT ARE ALIGNED WITH
NEEDED INDUSTRY SKILLS AND
REGIONAL WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
EFFORTS OCCURRING THROUGH THE
EXISTING STRONG WORKFORCE
PROGRAM.
UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE THAT THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
WILL ALLOCATE FUNDING TO BE
EIGHT EXISTING STRONG REGIONAL
STRONG WORKFORCE REGIONAL
CONSORTIA. BASED ON A FORMULA
THAT TAKES INTO ACCOUNT THE
REGION'S UNEMPLOYMENT RATE
PROJECTED JOB OPENINGS AND SEVEN
THROUGH TWELVE AVERAGE DAILY
ATTENDANCE.
EACH REGIONAL CONSORTIA WILL
THEN ADMINISTER A COMPETITIVE
GRANT PROCESS TO DISTRIBUTE
THEIR PORTION OF THE FUNDING TO
ELIGIBLE LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES AND THEIR REGION.
GRANT DETERMINATIONS WILL BE
MADE BY SUBCOMMITTEE FORM BY THE
CONSORTIUM MADE OF OF MADE UP OF
INDIVIDUALS WITH EXPERTISE
INCAPABLE OF EDUCATION AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT.
THIS SUBCOMMITTEE WILL WORK IN
CONSULTATION WITH THE CONSORTIUM
TO DECIDE THE SPECIFIC FUNDING
AMOUNTS FOR EACH GRANT AWARD.
SIMILAR TO THE C. T. INCENTIVE
GRANT PROGRAM THE FUNDING
ALLOCATED TO EACH CONSORTIUM
WILL BE SEPARATED INTO THREE
POTS FOR SMALL MEDIUM AND LARGE
APPLICANTS. BASED ON THE AVERAGE
DAILY ATTENDANCE.
IN ORDER TO BE ELIGIBLE FOR
FUNDING APPLICANTS MUST BE A
MEMBER OF THE CONSORTIUM AND BE
PARTICIPATING IN THE REGIONAL
WORKFORCE EFFORTS TO ALIGN
WORKFORCE EMPLOYMENT AND
EDUCATION SERVICES.
BE UTILIZING THEIR REGION'S PLAN
TO INFORM THEIR EFFORTS TO
IMPLEMENT OR EXPAND UPON CTE
PROGRAMS.
PROVIDE A LOCAL MATCH FOR ANY
FUNDING RECEIVED.
FROM THE PROGRAM.
AND MEET CERTAIN MINIMUM
ELIGIBILITY STANDARDS THE
MAJORITY OF WHICH WERE LIFTED
FROM THE EXISTING CITY INCENTIVE
GRANT PROGRAM APARTMENTS.
SO WHY HAS THE ADMINISTRATION
STRUCTURE THE PROPOSAL THIS WAY
RATHER THAN CONTINUING TO
PROVIDE FUNDING TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION TO
ADMINISTER QUE TWELVE SPECIFIC
CD PROGRAM.
LIKE YOU WE'VE BEEN LISTENING TO
FEEDBACK AND COMMENTS MADE AT
THE VARIOUS HEARINGS OVER THE
PAST FEW YEARS. AND WE'VE HEARD
SEVERAL COMMENTS BEING
CONSISTENTLY MADE.
FIRST WE HEARD THAT THE APPROACH
I'VE PROVIDING ONE TIME OR
LIMITED TERM GRANTS TO SUPPORT
CITY IT'S NOT SUSTAINABLE.
ADMINISTRATOR SAID THAT THEY'VE
STRUGGLE TO PLANS ET PROGRAMMES
FOR SHORT TERM GRANT
OPPORTUNITIES LIKE THAT CT
INCENTIVE GRANT AND THE CAREER
PATHWAYS TRUST PROGRAM.
IN RESPONSE THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL ESTABLISHES AN ONGOING
AND SUSTAINABLE FUNDING STREAM
FOR REGIONALLY A LINE TO SEE T.
PROGRAMS.
SECONDLY WE AGREE WITH THOSE WHO
HAVE STAYED AT THAT WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT IS A REGIONAL ISSUE.
COMMENTS HAVE BEEN MADE ABOUT
INVESTING AS A STATE IN A
REGIONAL MODEL TO SUPPORT CT.
A MODEL THAT WILL BRING INDUSTRY
AND THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY TO
THE TABLE TO CONFORM EDUCATION.
WE HEARD CONCERNS THAT DESPITE
PAST EFFORTS TO INTEGRATE QUE
TWELVE CT PROGRAMS WITH INDUSTRY
AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE COURSE
OFFERINGS.
PROGRAMS ARE ALWAYS FEEDING
SEAMLESSLY TO GET TOGETHER.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL
SEEKS TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE BY
UTILIZING A REGIONAL
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT RT EXISTS
UNDER THE STRONG WORK FIRST
PROGRAM.
THIS STRUCTURE IS PREDICATED ON
THE NOTION THAT CALIFORNIA'S
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES
COMMUNITY COLLEGES UNIVERSITIES
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD'S
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND
INDUSTRY LEADERS SHOULD
COLLABORATE TO INFORM. VETS
OFFERINGS OF CTE COURSES AND
PROGRAMS IN THEIR REGION.
THE STRONG WORK FORCE PROGRAM
HAS EXPANDED THE AVAILABILITY OF
REGIONALLY ALIGNED CT PROGRAMS
AT THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE LEVEL.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT THESE
BENEFITS WILL ONLY BE FURTHER
ENHANCED BY EXTENDING THE
PIPELINE OF THIS PROGRAM INTO
THE K. TWELVE COMMUNITY.
INDUSTRY HAS CONSISTENTLY BEEN
BRINGING UP THE NEED TO OFFER
RELEVANT CT PROGRAM THAT WILL
ACTUALLY PREPARE STUDENTS FOR
CAREER POINT GRADUATION.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL
IS INTENTIONALLY FOCUSED ON
PROVIDING INCENTIVES FOR THOSE
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES. THAT
ARE OFFERING C. T. PROGRAMS THAT
ARE ALIGNED TO INDUSTRY NEEDS IN
OUR REGION.
AS A RESULT WE BELIEVE THAT
THESE PROGRAMS WILL BETTER
PREPARE STUDENTS TO MEET
INDUSTRY WORKFORCE NEEDS.
FINALLY WE'VE HEARD CALLS FOR
THE STATE TO PUT IN PLACE
ORIGINAL LEADERSHIP STRUCTURE TO
ASSIST TEACHERS IN INDUSTRY
PARTNERS IN IMPLEMENTING HIGH
QUALITY CTE PROGRAMS.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL
DOES THIS BY PROVIDING TWELVE
MILLION AND ONGOING PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT FUNDING. TO PUT IN
PLACE SEVENTY TWO K. TWELVE
WORKFORCE PATHWAY COORDINATORS.
WHOSE DUTIES WOULD INCLUDE
PROVIDING TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
AND SUPPORT TO LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES IN IMPLEMENTING OR
EXPANDING UPON THEIR LINE C. T.
PROGRAMS.
THIS WOULD ALSO INCLUDE
CULTIVATING COLLABORATION
BETWEEN LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES AND INDUSTRY TO FURTHER
STRENGTHEN INDUSTRY INVOLVEMENT
AT THE K. TWELVE LEVEL.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL
HAS BEEN CAREFULLY CRAFTED TO
PRESERVE KEY ELEMENTS OF THE SI
TIENES INFOPRINT PROGRAM.
CONTINUING TO FOCUS ON HIGH
QUALITY CT PROGRAMS AND
RETAINING THE LOCAL MATCH
REQUIREMENT. TO ENSURE THAT
FUNDING PROVIDED FOR THE PROGRAM
IS BEING GRANTED TO ELEAZAR ARE
ALSO COMMITTED TO INVESTING
THEIR OWN VOCAL RESOURCES INTO
THEIR PROGRAMS.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL
INCLUDES THE SAME OUTCOME
REPORTING METRICS THAT WERE PART
OF THE CITY INCENTIVE GRANT
PROGRAM. PERVERT DATA WILL BE
RECORDED FOR THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES LAUNCH FOR
DATA SYSTEM.
WHICH HAVE THE CAPABILITIES TO
SHOW HOW STUDENTS PROGRESS FOR
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS AND
INTO THE WORKFORCE.
BY FOCUSING ON INDUSTRY DRIVEN
WORKFORCE ALIGNED CTE PROGRAM.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL
PUTS IN PLACE A STRONG CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION FRAMEWORK.
THAT ENSURES THAT REGIONAL
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT PLANNING
EFFORTS TRANSCEND ACROSS K.
TWELVE AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES
ULTIMATELY GUIDING STUDENTS DOWN
A PATHWAY THAT CAN ACTUALLY LEAD
THEM INTO A LIVABLE WAGE JOB.
I HAVE WITH ME LISA RISEN SKI
FROM ALSO FROM DEPARTMENT
FINANCE AND WE'RE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
GREAT THANK YOU THANK YOU TO OUR
FIRST PANEL HAVE QUESTIONS NOW
FOR OUR FIRST PANEL I HAVE A FEW
ALL KIND OF A QUICK SCAN BECAUSE
IT DOES OTHER QUESTIONS. AND
THERE ARE OTHER PANELS AFTER
THIS.
OFFER THE LA SHOW IF YOU WILL.
.
YOU YOU HAD YOU MADE THE POINT
THAT.
.
HIGH SCHOOL CT OR EVEN MIDDLE
SCHOOL HIGH SCHOOL CT HAS GOALS
BEYOND WORKFORCE PREPARATION
COULD YOU EXPAND ON THAT A BIT.
SURE.
SO ABA I BELIEVE THE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION MENTIONS.
THE FACT THAT MANY HIGH SCHOOLS
UCT  AS A WAY TO TEACH
ACADEMIC SUBJECTS SO WE'VE SEEN
MORE AND MORE CTE COURSES
QUALIFYING FOR. A MEETING A
THREE G. REQUIREMENTS FOR
EXAMPLE.
CTE COURSES CAN BE USED TO
TEACH ACADEMIC CONTENT IN A
HANDS ON WAY.
I'M.
IN ADDITION TO TO THE TECHNICAL
SKILLS THAT YOU MENTIONED CT IS
OFTEN ARE USED AS A STUDENT
ENGAGEMENT STRATEGY AS WELL ON
TO KEEP STUDENTS ENGAGED IN HIGH
SCHOOL.
IN OF PROVIDING THEM OF COURSE
WORK IN AN AREA THAT THEY HAVE
INTEREST IN PROVIDING THEM WITH.
A AN OPPORTUNITY TO EXPLORE
DIFFERENT FROM TYPES OF CAREER.
PADS THAT THEY MIGHT TAKE IN
THE FUTURE. BUT WE'VE ALSO HEARD
THAT CT  AND AND OUR
RESEARCH REALLY INDICATES THAT
SEAT YOU CAN TEACH STUDENTS SOFT
SKILLS.
SUCH AS.
TEAM WORK.
COMMUNICATION.
SHOWING SHOWING UP ON TIME.
BUILDING RESUMES.
THAT PROVIDING SOME OF THOSE
SOFT SKILLS THAT WE KNOW THAT
EMPLOYERS AND AND. EVEN IF
STUDENTS ARE GOING TO FOR
UNIVERSITIES.
REALLY BENEFITS THEM.
GREAT THANK YOU. DUMB AND I
AGREED THAT THESE PROGRAMS
ENGAGE STUDENTS AGREE THEY HAVE
ACADEMIC CROSSOVER.
S. KNIGHTED REALLY
UNDERSTATEMENT FRACTIONS LED TO
OUR CONSTRUCTION AND USE A
MEASURING TAPE RIGHT HAD A
REALLY LEARN WHAT. THE
DIFFERENCE THREE IN FIVE MASON
SEVENTY SECOND PLAN THE
CLASSROOM.
BUT TO PLAN THE REAL WORLD IS
MUCH DIFFERENT THAT'S WHAT I
THINK CT. OF PROGRAMS DAVID YOU
SHE YOU KNOW ME OFF YOUR CONCERN
MIND YOU YOU CAN YOU CAN RESPOND
TO. MY CONCERN IS THAT WE MIGHT
START TRACKING STUDENTS IN
SEVENTH GRADE.
RIGHT THIS SOME OF THE GERMAN
MODEL RIGHT WE STARTED SEVENTH
GRADE YOU PICK YOUR LANE.
ARE YOU CAN YOU SEE T..
ARE YOU GONNA GO TO UNIVERSITY
AND I I I WANT STUDENTS TO
PREPARE FOR BOTH FOR SURE.
BUT I ALSO WANT THEM TO HAVE
OPTIONS FOR BOTH AND NOT TO LOCK
THEMSELVES AND FOR THE REST OF
LIFE IN SEVENTH GRADE HIS IRA MY
WORLD IS A SEVENTH GRADER.
WASN'T TOO BROAD RIGHT I'M COULD
YOU COMMENT ON THAT.
I THINK THAT THE STATE AND THE
LEGISLATURE HAVE HAD CONCERNS
WITH TRACKING STUDENTS AND
THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS THAT
THE STATE HAS MOVED TOWARDS MORE
OF.
THE MODEL I I THINK WE ARE WE
CALL IT MANY TIMES CAREER
PATHWAYS ARE LINKED LEARNING
MODEL WHERE STUDENTS ARE ABLE
TO.
WHAT THE GOAL IS REALLY BEEN
FOR STUDENTS TO BE COLLEGE AND
CAREER READY WHERE THEY WOULD
HAVE AN OPTION TO ATTEND A FOUR
UNIVERSITY OR?
JOIN THE WORKFORCE OR ENROLL IN
A TRAINING PROGRAM AFTER HIGH
SCHOOL.
FOR THAT VERY REASON WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT CERTAIN TYPES OF
STUDENTS AREN'T.
.
NUDGED AND INTO CERTAIN.
CERTAIN PATHWAYS TRACKING
ESSENTIALLY AS HAS BEEN AT
BENNETT CONCERN AND I THINK
THAT.
THE THE STEPS THROUGH THE LC FF
AND THE COLLEGE IN CORRECTING A
SYNDICATE WAS AN ATTEMPT TO.
ADDRESS THAT GREAT THANK YOU
NEXT QUESTIONS FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THAT THE
GOVERNOR SEEN THE NEED. FOR MORE
CT FUNDING WITH TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS ON AN ONGOING
BASIS.
NOT JUST SAYING A FOR THREE
YEARS WERE GONNA DO THIS AND
THEN WE'RE GOING TO GIVE UP ON
IT SO I THINK THAT'S VERY
IMPORTANT.
THOUGH ONE MAJOR CHALLENGE I
HAVE WITH THIS PROPOSAL YOU
PROBABLY KNOWS THE CONSORTIUM.
THAT TO ME IS LIKE THE SOVIET
BLOCK I DON'T KNOW HOW PEOPLE
ARE GONNA GET THEIR MONEY. ON
HOW THEY'RE GONNA GET IT FAIRLY.
IT'S HANDED OVER TO THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
WHICH IS VERY POOR PRECEDENT MY
MIND THAT WE WOULD GIVE THEM THE
AND I DON'T HAVE THE CAPACITY.
TO DO THIS.
Y. WOULDN'T WOULDN'T KEEP THIS
IN THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
I'M STILL CURIOUS.
AND THERE ARE CHALLENGES THE
DEPARTMENT EDUCATIONAL LET'S
ADDRESS THOSE LET'S ADDRESS
THOSE.
BUT AGAIN WE HANDED OVER THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND THEN THEY
HAND IT DOWN THE LOCAL
CONSORTIUM. MY CONCERN IS ALSO
THE LOCAL CONSORTIUM LEVEL IT'S
HANDED DOWN OF THE CONSORTIA
THINK ON AN EIGHTY A BASIS BUT
IT'S NOT HANDED OUT BY THE
CONSORTIUM ON AN EIGHTY BASIS IF
I'M CORRECT. SO CAN YOU EXPLAIN
HOW THAT IS SUPPOSED TO WORK AND
HOW IT'S GOING TO BE FAIR THAT.
DISTRICTS WON'T GET OUT VOTED AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL ETCETERA.
I'M.
THERE WAS A LOT IN YOUR IN YOUR
QUESTION FALL TRYING IF IF I
MISSED ANYTHING GO FREE BECAUSE
SHE WAS A GUY I GUESS YOU.
SO THE APPROACH TO PROVIDE
FUNDING TO ADD THAT THECOMMUNITY
COLLEGE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE THERE REALLY ALLOCATING
THE FUNDING DOWN TO THE
CONSORTIUM BASED ON A CALCULATED
FORMULA. SO IT WOULDN'T
NECESSARILY MATTER IF THE
DEPARTMENT EDUCATION WITH
CALCULATING THAT FORMULA OR
WHETHER THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
WITH CALCULATING THAT FORMULA.
THE FORMULA WILL BE WHAT IT IS
AND BASED ON THE UNEMPLOYMENT
RATE RATE IN THE REGION THE
PROJECTED JOB OPENINGS AND SEVEN
FOR TWELVE EIGHTY A. UP AT THE
CONSORTIUM LEVEL IS REALLY WHERE
THE DECISIONS ON HOW WITHOUT
FUNDING IT'S GETTING DISPERSED
TO THE ALLEY AIDS THAT THAT'S
REALLY WHERE IT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN IS DOWN AT THE CONSORTIUM
LEVEL.
AND CURRENTLY I AM IN IT
CONSORTIUM ARE ARE WORKING VERY
CLOSELY WITH OUR INDUSTRY
PARTNERS IN THEIR REGION TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
OFFERINGS IN THEIR AREA ARE
LYING TO INDUSTRY NEEDS. AND WE
ANTICIPATE THAT THAT AT
COOPERATION WILL CONTINUE AS THE
FUNDING FOR THIS PROGRAM GETS
ALLOCATED. REALLY WITH THE
INTENTION OF MAKING SURE THAT
THE K. TWELVE PROGRAMS THAT ARE
BEING FUNDED THROUGH THAT'S HAVE
FOR THROUGH THAT'S PROPOSAL. ARE
FINE OUR MEETING INDUSTRY NEEDS
AND THAT AREA AND ARE DRIVEN BY
WORKFORCE DEMAND IN THAT AREA.
SO.
IT AT THAT SUBCOMMITTEE IS IS
ONE OF THE COMPONENTS THAT WE'VE
ESTABLISHED TO REALLY TRY AND
HELP MITIGATE SOME OF THE
CONCERNS THAT COMMUNITY COLLEGES
WOULD BE MAKING THESE DECISIONS.
ON BEHALF OF THE K. TWELVE IN
THEIR AREA. THIS SUB COMMITTEE
IS MADE UP OF A HAM IT UP OF
EXPERTS WITH THE K. TWELVE
EXPERTISE AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT IN THEIR IN THEIR
AREAS SO. WE ARE WORKING WITH
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE NOW I'M
IN IN GETTING SOME CALL SET UP
WITH SOME OF THE REGIONAL
CONSORTIA TO FIGURE OUT. HOW
BEST TO INTEGRATE QUE TWELVE
INTO THAT PROCESS WITHOUT
DISRUPTING THE CURRENT
STRUCTURE?
BUT REALLY OUR GOAL IS THAT
THESE PROGRAMS WILL BE MADE DOWN
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL LEVEL WHERE
I'M REGIONAL WORKFORCE DEMANDS
ARE MOST KNOWN TO INDUSTRY IN
THAT AREA. AND REALLY GETTING
THEM TO INFORM THE K. TWELVE OCT
OFFERINGS GREAT SO FROM A
DISTRICT AND I'VE GOT NINE OTHER
DISTRICTS MY CONSORTIA.
AND ONE OF THEM VERY LARGE IT
MIGHT IT BE THAT I WOULD GET OUT
VOTED I WOULDN'T GET ANY THAT
MONEY THAT WE DO HAVE THE
LANGUAGE AND IN THE TRAILER BILL
THAT.
IT ESTABLISHES.
THEY BASICALLY POP FIGHTERS SO
THERE'S SOME SATISFIED WITH EACH
WITHIN EACH CONSORTIA ALLOCATION
FOR SMALL TO MEDIUM AND LARGER.
AND SPECIFICALLY TO ADDRESS THAT
CONCERN THAT THE SMOKE WOULD
MAYBE BE SQUEEZED OUT BY SOME OF
THE LARGE LAW SCHOOL DISTRICT A
SMALL SCHOOL A IT'S BASED ON
EIGHTY EIGHT SO IF YOUR PLANE
OUTSIDE A AS A JPA. IT'S YOU
KNOW YOU'RE COMBINED ABA IF
YOU'RE PLAYING AS A SINGLE
SCHOOL DISTRICT FURNITURE YOUR
DISTRICT'S ADA.
IT'S HOT IT'S BY EIGHTY OF THE
DISTRICT NOT YET SCHOOL SITE
NOW.
BECAUSE YOU'RE PLAYING OUT THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT OR COUNTY OFFICE
OR WORK CHARTER SCHOOL ORDERED.
JPA OKAY I STILL HAVE REAL I
HAVE SIGNIFICANT I DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHY WE DESIGNED A
SYSTEM BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT TO
GO TO THE PARTNER DUCATION
THAT'S WHAT'S IT STRIKES ME AS
BECAUSE YOU'RE SAYING WHAT. WE
WANT TO GIVE IT TO THE VICTIM
NICOLE GE'S.
BECAUSE THEY'RE ALIGNED WITH THE
WITH THE LOCAL OF I'M JUST A
LITTLE CONFUSED ON WHY YOU JUST
WOULDN'T KEEP IT.
IN THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
CAN ELABORATE ON THE CHURCH SO.
.
I THINK WE GET TO GET AWAY FROM
THE MINDSET BUT IT'S ACTUALLY
THE THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
MAKING DECISIONS BECAUSE REALLY
THEY'RE PASSING THE FUNDING DOWN
TO THE REGIONAL CONSORTIUM
LEVEL.
THEY'RE THEY'RE NOT INVOLVED IN
THE DECISION MAKING PROCESS ONCE
IT GETS DOWN TO THAT CONSORTIUM
LEVEL.
IT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH YOU
KNOW WHETHER OR NOT THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION IS
CAPABLE OF MAKING THAT
CALCULATION. IT'S REALLY BASED
ON THE FACT THAT THIS IS AN
EXISTING STRUCTURE THAT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE HAS IN PLACE.
TWO OF THE THREE FACTORS THE
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE AND BE I AM.
THE PROTECTIVE JOB OPENINGS IN
THE REGION OUR CALCULATIONS THAT
ARE ALREADY IN THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE FORMULA SO THAT THE
DEPARTMENT EDUCATIONAL JUST BE
PROVIDING THE EIGHTY A. AND
ULTIMATELY OUR GOAL WAS TO GET
THE FUNDING DOWN TO THE
CONSORTIUM AND THE MOST
EFFICIENT MANNER. AND WE FELT
LIKE PROVIDING IT DIRECTLY TO
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE WHO ARE
A HOUSE THAT STRUCTURE IN PLACE
AS MOST EFFICIENT.
OKAY AND I JUST AGAIN I THINK WE
NEED TO THINK BROADER THAN JUST
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT WE NEED
THINK ABOUT HUMAN DEVELOPMENT
HERE TOO. AND IT MIGHT BE.
THAT A STUDENT IS AN A MIDDLE
SCHOOL HIGH SCHOOL AND THEY HAVE
A PATHWAY PROGRAM THAT MIGHT NOT
BE AT THE LOCAL COMMUNITY
COLLEGE MIGHT BE SOMEWHERE ELSE
THEY WANT TO GO. AND IT STILL
MIGHT BE A FIT FOR THAT LOCAL
SCHOOL BUT THEY MIGHT NOT GO TO
THEIR VERY LOCAL COMMUNITY
COLLEGES I HOPE YOU THINK ABOUT
THAT TOO BUT I DON'T GET TOO FAR
INTO THAT. TODAY BECAUSE I KNOW
OTHERS HAVE QUESTIONS HERE BUT
I'M REAL CONCERNED ABOUT.
HOW THIS MONEY GETS DOWN ON THE
GROUND IN THE ACCOUNTABILITY THE
GROUND I'D VERY SOMETHING LIKE A
NAVIGATOR MODEL IN THE
GOVERNOR'S TWELVE MILLION AND
THERE?
THAT THEN.
MY HOPE WILL BE THE NAVIGATORS
OF THE AROUND THE STATE NOT
LOCATED IN SACRAMENTO SO THAT
THEY WOULD ACT YOU KNOW WE CUT
INTO REGIONS AND THEY WOULD ACT
AS THE LOCAL EXPERTS. ON HOW
BEST TO CONNECT DISTRICTS
TO TO TELL TO LOCAL JOB NEEDS
REGIONAL JOB NEEDS.
AGAIN NOT RELYING ON ON ON TO
PEOPLE SITTING IN AN OFFICE IN
SACRAMENTO BUT TAKE THAT TWELVE
MILLION SPREAD ACROSS THE STATE
REGION'S.
AND AND THEY WOULD DO THE SAME
THING THAT THIS WHOLE CONSORTIA
THING WITH TO SOME A LITTLE
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT. SEEMS A
LONG WAY LEAD TO MAKE.
.
OKAY AND I KNOW MR MCCARTY HAD A
COUPLE QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU FIRST OF ALL IT'S
GREAT TO SEE THE AT THE BROAD
INTEREST FOR COMMITTEES. ROUGHLY
MAYBE
TWENTY. FIVE PERCENT OF THE
ASSEMBLY I THINK IS
PARTICIPATING IN THIS SHOWS HOW
BIG OF AN INTEREST THAT WE HAVE
IN THIS.
AND I KNOW WE'RE GONNA GET IN
GREAT DETAIL ON THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE SO I WANT.
I WANT TO BORE YOU BUT HERE ARE
THE DETAILS BUT JUST KIND THE
BIG PICTURE. BUT CERTAINLY WE'RE
BOUND THE BUBBLE LAST FEW YEARS
AS FAR AS FUNDING FOR THIS
THROUGHOUT THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
THE ONE TIME MONEY FOUR HUNDRED
THE THREE INCH THAN TWO HUNDRED
SO. IT'S A RELIEF THAT WE HAVE
AN ONGOING AMOUNT NOW GRANTED
THAT THE DOLLAR AMOUNT THAT
COULD BE DEBATED. I DO HAVE A
GREAT CONCERNS WITH THE LA O.
PROPOSAL AS FAR AS HAVING THE
DISTRICTS WITH THEIR INCREASED
ELSE IF THAT MONEY PICK AND
CHOOSE THIS BECAUSE THEY HAVE SO
MANY OTHER PRIORITIES.
THEY HAVE THEIR PENSION COSTS
ARE STIRS COST.
TEACHER SALARIES YOU KNOW
BASICALLY GET GETTING OR FROM
THE GREAT RECESSION SELF.
I DON'T THINK THIS WILL
NECESSARILY BE A PRIORITY WHAT
YOU WANTED TO BE LESS WE SAY
THIS IS GOING TO BE A PRIORITY
WHICH IS WHY I THINK.
IT'S IPORTANT EVERITT WE'RE
DOING HERE TODAY SO I THINK THAT
THERE'S THERE'S TWO QUESTIONS AS
FAR IT'S REALLY IT'S HOW MUCH
MONEY ARE GOING TO PUT IN THE
POT AND THEN HOW WILL IT BE.
DOLED OUT ACROSS
LEON ACROSS THE TO CALIFORNIA SO
THE DOLLAR AMOUNT IT'S A GOOD
START AT TWO HUNDRED TWELVE ON
GOING. I THINK HIS DESIRE TO GO
NORTH OF THERE AND CERTAINLY
WILL POP WILL PROBABLY PUSH THAT
IN IN OUR. BUDGET PROCESS IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
AYE I AM I'M IN LINE WITH THAT
MISTER O'DONNELL AS FAR AS THE.
MEANT IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS
I'M NOT QUITE CERTAIN AS FAR AS
WHY WE'RE PICKING THIS MODEL
VERSUS THE PAST THREE YEARS. BUT
ANOTHER ISSUE THAT I WANT TO
RAISE WHICH HASN'T BEEN BROUGHT
UP YET.
IS THE FACT THAT WE HAVE A
THOUSAND TYPE HIGH SCHOOLS IN
CALIFORNIA RIGHT. AND SOME KIDS
AND PARENTS THERE THEY CAN VOTE
WITH THEIR FEET THEY CAN GO
ACROSS THE DISTRICT ACROSS THE
TOWN. BUT SOMETIMES MAYBE THAT'S
YOUR SCHOOL YOU YOU HAVE NO
OTHER CHOICE MAYBE YOUR HONOR.
THAT A RURAL AREA MAYBE URBAN
AREA AND YOU'RE GONNA GO THAT
SCHOOL BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE YOUR
PARENTS OR WHOEVER WANT WANT YOU
TO FOCUS AND. YOU CAN BE ON A
LOT BECAUSE THE CONSORTIA AT MAY
NOT HAVE YOUR HIGH SCHOOL
PARTICIPATING SO. IN THE OLD
MODEL WHERE IS A CATEGORICAL YOU
KNOW EVERY STUDENT HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY AND TO PARTICIPATE.
IN OUR AYE RIGHT DIDN'T BUY
METAL SUBCLASS ROWS OF HIGH
SCHOOL.
AND SO IT'S DIFFERENT NOW WE
WANT TO PICK THE THE THE PROGRAM
WHICH THINK MAKES THE MOST SENSE
BUT HOW CAN WE ENSURE THAT BASED
UPON WHAT. MISTER O'DONNELL SAID
THEY DID NOT JUST THE ECONOMIC
NEEDS FOR THE INDUSTRY BUT THAT.
HUMAN NEEDS FOR IT A KID WHO
WANTS TO. BE ABLE TO TO TO MAKE
A GO OF THIS HOW DO WE ENSURE
THAT VARIABLE TO.
PARTICIPATE IN THEY WON'T GET
LEFT BEHIND.
I'VE SURVEYED EXISTING STRONG
WORKFORCE REGIONAL CONSORTIA
BOTH COVER THE ENTIRE STATE SO
EVERY LA A WILL FALL WITHIN ONE
CONSORTIA SNOW LA A WILL BE LEFT
OUT. THE EXTENT TO WHICH THAT
ALLEVIATE USES TO ENGAGE IN THAT
CONSORTIUM THAT IS THAT IF
ULTIMATELY UP TO THEM.
YOU'D NEED AT THIS PROVIDES AN
INCENTIVE FOR HOPE WE'RE HOPING
TO GET THEM FURTHER INVOLVED WE
KNOW CURRENTLY ELOISE ARE
INVOLVED IN THESE CONSORTIUM FOR
NOT JUST COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CONSORTIUM. RIGHT NOW.
SOME ELEAZAR ARE ARE
PARTICIPATING IN SOME ARE I'M
EVEN RECEIVING FUNDING THROUGH
THE EXISTING STRONG WORK FIRST
PROGRAM UP THROUGH THE POT
THAT'S RESERVE FOR REGIONALLY
PRIORITIZE PROJECTS.
WE ACTUALLY THINK THAT THIS
APPROACH WILL LATIN BEAT.
FURTHER COOPERATION AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL SO IF THERE IS A PROGRAM
THAT'S NOT NECESSARILY OFFERED
AT YOUR PARTICULAR SCHOOL. WE
THINK THAT THESE WILL LEAD TO
CONVERSATIONS FOR DISTRICTS AND.
OTHER ELEAZER IN THE REGION ARE
TALKING AND AREN'T COLLABORATING
ON MAKING SURE THAT COURSES ARE
OFFERED TO STUDENTS IN THEIR
AREA WE THINK IT WILL LEAD TO
FURTHER COOPERATION BETWEEN
ELOISE AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES
FOR THINGS THAT. YOU POSSIBLY
FOR AND USE THE FACILITIES TO
THE EXTENT THAT IT DISTRICT
DOESN'T HAVE FACILITIES
AVAILABLE TO OFFER CERTAIN
CLASS.
SO WE DO THINK. THAT THIS
PROPOSAL ACTUALLY EXPAND ACCESS
RATHER THAN RESTRICTING.
SO I'M NOT QUITE SURE HOW THAT
WOULD WORK IF YOU'RE INDIVIDUAL
STUDENTS.
IN THE INTERIM DO YOU DO YOU
HAVE TO TRANSFER TO A DIFFERENT
SCHOOL HARD YOU HAVE TO WAIT
UNTIL. YOUR AREA GETS TOGETHER
AND COMES TO YOU AS. IT WILL BE
FOR YEARS AND YOU'RE LEFT OUT.
AT GENERATIONS LOST.
SO IF YOU'RE AN INDIVIDUAL
STUDENT NOW AND AND THERE'S A
COURSE THAT YOU'RE INTERESTED IN
THAT'S NOT BEING OFFERED.
YOU KNOW WE DO HAVE THE THOUGH
SO I'LL CAP PROCESS WHERE YOU
CAN KIND OF BRING THOSE CONCERNS
THROUGH THAT PROCESS AND IF YOU
GET ENOUGH SUPPORT LOCALLY MAYBE
THAT IS THE CLASS THAT WILL
ULTIMATELY BE OFFERED ON YOUR
CAMPUS.
IN TERMS OF MAKING SURE THAT
THAT STUDENT IS AWARE OF OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES IN THEIR AREA
THAT'S ONE OF THE DUTIES OF
THAT.
QUE TWELVE FOR FOURTH PATHWAY
COORDINATORS THAT WE'RE CREATING
IN THE REGION THAT WE THE REASON
THAT WE'VE CREATED SEVENTY TWO
IS TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY ARE
ACCESSIBLE TO ELEAZAR AND TO
INDIVIDUAL SCHOOLS AND TO
STUDENTS WITHIN THOSE SCHOOLS.
AND MAKING SURE THAT THAT
SCHOOLS AND STUDENTS KNOW OF
AVAILABLE PROGRAMS IN THEIR
REGION AND REALLY MAKING SURE
THAT THEY'RE FULLY AWARE OF
OTHER OPPORTUNITIES OUT.
OUR GREATNESS WILL GO TO.
.
MISTER GIPSON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN.
THE CHAIRMAN'S ALREADY ASKED ME
TO BE NICE I WOULD IT BE NICE
WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THAT. JOB.
LET ME SIMPLY STRONGLY SUGGESTS
THAT.
.
I REPRESENT A SIX PORTS DIGICAMS
THAT CALIFORNIA.
THE PEOPLE I REPRESENT CAN'T
WAIT.
CAN'T WAIT WE HAVE TO GET IT
RIGHT THE FIRST TIME.
AND SO I'M VERY CONCERNED AS AN
ALLY MY COMMENTS WITH MY
COLLEAGUES.
AHMED ALREADY ARTICULATED.
WE HAVE TO GET IT RIGHT THE
FIRST TIME LIKE RIGHT NOW AND
PUTTING MONEY INTO.
THIS PROGRAM.
FOR DISTRICTS
TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF IT OR NOT.
IS TROUBLING TO ME.
I WAS TROUBLING TO ME IN TERMS
OF YOU KNOW THIS IS A GREAT
PROGRAM AND.
AGAIN PEOPLE.
CHOOSE NOT TO GO TO HIGH SCHOOL
I MEAN NOT GO TO OF A FOUR YEAR
COLLEGE OR A JUNIOR COLLEGE.
THEY WANT A JOB AFTER I FINISH
HIGH SCHOOL AND THEY HAVE TO
HAVE TECHNICAL SKILLS IN ORDER
TO. SUSTAIN THEMSELVES.
AS IN ADULTS.
FATHER BOYLE OF HOMEBOY BAKER
SAID GIVE A MAN A JOB STOP A
BULLET.
THAT'S REAL IN MY COMMUNITY
WHICH I REPRESENT.
I CAN SEE THE DECREASE BY GIVING
INDIVIDUAL A JOB TECHNICAL
SKILLS THAT THEY CAN GET A JOB.
TO THIS THAT CAN SUSTAIN
THEMSELVES THROUGH LIFE.
AND SO YOU KNOW I THINK THERE'S
A GREAT.
INTEREST BY MY COLLEAGUES BEING
HERE IN THE ROOM BEING FULL. ON
TO SHOW THAT WE NEED TO HAVE
SOMETHING WHERE IS NOT BEING
APPROPRIATE EVERY SO OFTEN.
AND WHY NOT HAVE SOMETHING
THAT'S.
ACROSS THE ENTIRE STATE A
CALIFORNIAN EDUCATION.
KATE THROUGH TWELVE WHERE
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION YEAR
OVER THE TIME WHEN YOU MAY BE
TOO YOUNG BUT I REMEMBER THE
TIME WHEN I WAS GOING TO SCHOOL.
I HAD OFFERED IN JUNIOR HIGH
SCHOOL THE WITH THE SHOPS.
AND THEN IT CARRIED ON TO HIGH
SCHOOL.
AND A NUMBER OF MY CLASSMATES
OPEN UP THEIR OWN AUTUMN ACCOUNT
SHOPS.
THEY WANTED TO PLUMBING.
THEY WENT TO JOBS RIGHT NOW
THAT'S PROVIDING A WAY OF LIFE
FOR THEM AND THEIR FAMILIES.
AND THOSE ARE THE THINGS THAT
THOSE THAT THINK THAT WE NEED TO
TRY TO CONTINUE TO DO RIGHT NOW
WITH EMERGING TECHNOLOGY.
HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
AND SO MY QUESTION IS WE TALK
ABOUT YOU KNOW FOLLOWING THE
MONEY HOW DO WE FOLLOW THE
FUNDS.
DOES.
TO ENSURE EQUITABLE DISTRIBUTION
INCLUDING DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES WOULD YOU DESCRIBE
TO US
MCCARTY IS QUESTION I HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT.
SO THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
REALLY DOES TAKE A A REGIONAL
APPROACH SO ULTIMATELY THAT
COUNT ABILITY IS GOING TO BE
COMING FROM THE REGIONAL
CONSORTIUM. AND MAKING SURE THAT
THAT REGIONAL CONSORTIUM IS
GETTING THE OUTCOMES THAT THAT
THEY WERE HOPING TO ACHIEVE AND
MAKING THE INVESTMENT SIMPLY
BASED ON OPPORTUNITY SYSTEM AS
YOU DESCRIBED. AS IT IS HERE
THAT SYSTEM YOU DESCRIBE.
SOME CAN AND SOME WON'T BASED ON
YOU KNOW SCHOOL DISTRICT NEEDS
AND THINGS OF THAT NATURE. THAT
WE CAN'T COMPILE DISTRICTS TO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS PROGRAM JUST
LIKE WE DID NOT REQUIRE THEM TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE CT INCENTIVE
GRANT PROGRAM. WE WE MAKE
OPPORTUNITY AVAILABLE AND
ULTIMATELY THAT DISTRICT IS THE
ONE MAKING THE DECISION ON
WHETHER OR NOT TO APPLY. TO TO
UNDER OUR PROGRAMMER INTERCITY
INCENTIVE GRANT PROGRAMS OF A
SCHOOL I'M SORRY IF A SCHOOL
DISTRICT SIGH I WANT EVERYBODY
TO GO TO COLLEGE AND I'M NOT
GOING TO OFFER. THE CT PROGRAM
BUT YOU KNOW YOU HAVE KIDS THERE
WHO ARE NOT GOING TO GO TO
COLLEGE.
WHETHER IT'S A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
OR A FOUR YEAR COLLEGE SORT
HAVES THOSE KIDS.
ARE THEY IMPORTANT AS WELL.
WE CERTAINLY ARE IN OUR
ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM DOES HAVE%
THE COLLEGE CAREER INDICATOR IN
PLACE AND I THINK REALLY BAD.
THAT IS OUR WAY OF COMPELLING
DISTRICTS TO YOU KNOW BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR OFFERING THESE
TYPES OF COURSES.
BUT BUT I CAN'T ULTIMATELY FOR
NOT REQUIRING THEM TO
PARTICIPATE IN ANY ONE
PARTICULAR CT PROGRAM THAT WERE
OFFERING WE DO HOPE THAT THEY
SEE THE VALUE IN DOING THAT IN
DIDN'T. WE EXPECT THAT IN
INVESTING THESE PROGRAMS THEY
WILL SEEK YOU KNOW INCREASE
STUDENT OUTCOMES IN THE AREA
PUPIL ACHIEVEMENT AND SCHOOL
CLIMATE. BUT BUT AGAIN THAT'S
NOT SOMETHING THAT WERE
COMPELLING THEM TO DEAL.
I'LL STOP THERE. THANK YOU ARE
MISTER FRAZIER WHOM SELF COMES
FROM THE CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY
AND KNOWS THIS ISSUE WELL. SO
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND I
WANT TO JUST KIND OF. CAPITALIZE
ON WHAT YOU WOULD TALK ABOUT
FRACTIONS IN IN REAL LIFE.
I HAD HUNDREDS OF THE PREMISES
COME OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL WHO ARE
NOT QUALIFIED. TO EVEN START.
WORKING FOR ME BASED ON.
OF NOT HAVING THE ABILITY TO GO
THROUGH THE THE SEEDIER
OCCASIONALLY THAT I HAD.
OF I DID HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
THE COLLEGE
I WENT INTO AN APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAM RIGHT AFTER BECAUSE I
KNEW I HAD AN APTITUDE.
TO GO AND BE A SOMEWHAT
COMPETENT. GOING FORWARD LOT OF
KIDS COMMIT HIGH SCHOOL TO GO
INTO THE WORKFORCE THEY DON'T
HAVE THIS TRAINING.
AND THEY'RE EMBARRASSED
BECAUSE.
THEY DON'T THEY CAN'T BE HELPFUL
AND THERE ARE A BURDEN TO THE
EMPLOYER AND TO GIVE UP.
THEY ABSOLUTELY DO GIVE UP.
AND SO THEN THEY KIND OF
FLOUNDERED AROUND LOOKING FOR A
PLACE.
AND I THINK THAT THE CHAIRS IS
DEMONSTRATED THAT.
WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO GIVE THEM
THE OPPORTUNITY THIS TO THESE IN
YOUNG INDIVIDUALS.
AND THEY BECOME.
INFATUATED OR. IMPRESSED OF WHAT
THEY CAN ACCOMPLISH EARLY IN
LIFE AND KNOW THAT THEY CAN BE
SUCCESSFUL AT SOMETHING.
ARM.
WE ALL WE KNOW IT WILL IDENTIFY
WITH LIFE SKILLS FOR THE SPECIAL
NEEDS POPULATION EIGHTEEN TO
TWENTY TWO YEAR OLDS WE GIVE
THEM EVERYTHING THAT WE CAN.
WE HAVE HELL GRANTS WE HAVE CASH
FOR COLLEGE WE HAVE ALL OF THESE
THINGS. FOR THE PATHWAY TO
COLLEGE.
BUT YOU TELL US THAT YOU.
AND YOU KNOW MAYBE THREE MORE
YEARS IT WE'RE GONNA LOOK AT
THIS WHAT WAS FLAT FUNDED PER
CD.
IT'S IMPERATIVE.
THAT WE LOOK AT.
HA THIS AS A.
OPPORTUNITY FOR YOUNG PEOPLE.
ON I AM I WILL TELL YOU THAT.
AS AN EMPLOYER.
I THINK THAT WHEN THE
INDIVIDUALS CAME TO ME AND THEY
WERE PREPARED.
THAT.
I FAILED THEM IN SOME WAY.
PAYING TAXES THAT THEY WEREN'T
GETTING.
THE EDUCATION THAT THEY NEEDED
TO BE SUCCESSFUL.
AND SO I IMPLORE ALL OF YOU.
TO MAKE A CONSCIOUS EFFORT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THESE CHILDREN
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY.
AND DID JUST LIKE I SAID I CAN'T
THANK THE CHAIR FOR BRINGING
THIS UP AND AND BEING A.
CO AUTHOR WITH HIM ON HIS BILL
BECAUSE I IF WE DON'T STEP UP
AND WE LET THE DISTRICTS
DETERMINE OUTCOMES.
THEY'RE GONNA CIRCUMVENT THE
PROCESS BECAUSE THEY HAVE A
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE.
AND I THINK THAT IT NEEDS TO BE
A MANDATE. IN THE STATE I THINK
YOU SAID YOU CAN'T.
MAKE AT DISTRICT OF. COMPLY TO
ANY KIND OF CT WE CAN.
AND WE SHOULD.
AND SO I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE CHAIR GOING
FORWARD.
PHONE THAT PROCESS BECAUSE.
I BECAME AN APPRENTICE BECAUSE
OF CT OR VOCATIONAL ED. AND THEN
I BECAME A MASTER CARPENTER ANY
CONTRACTOR AND NOW I'M A STATE
LEGISLATOR.
AND I AM GOING TO CONTINUE
CHECKING THE CT UNTIL THE DAY
THAT I'M NOT A.
SO LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
ALL OF YOU AND I THINK WE SHOULD
START TRACKING PERFORMANCE
METRICS
ON WHAT IS ACCOMPLISHED THROUGH
CD HAND JOB RETENTION BECAUSE OF
IT.
THANK YOU LANCASTER FRAZIER HER
PASSION.
NEXT WE'LL HEAR FROM ON THIS
QUIRK SILVA AND THEN DOCTOR
WEBER AFTER.
WELL I I APPRECIATE GETTING BOTH
PROPOSALS AS AS YOU MIGHT SAY
AND I KNOW THAT THERE'S A LOT OF
WORK PUT INTO THESE BY A.
THE MAJOR CONCERN IS AS WE LOOK
AT THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES ON THE
ONE MODEL OF THE OF THE MOVING
THE MONEY DOWN TO A CONSORTIUM.
AND THEN THE CONSORTIUM A IN
MANY CASES MAKING THE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND THEN THE
FORMULA BEING A EIGHTY A STRONG
WORKFORCE PROGRAM.
PROJECTED JOBS AND JOB GROWTH I
FEEL LIKE.
IT NO MATTER WHICH DISTRICT YOU
REPRESENT AND AGAIN I REPRESENT
ORANGE COUNTY SO MUCH DIFFERENT
THAN THE INLAND. EMPIRE THAT WE
DON'T WANT HAVE WINNERS AND
LOSERS IN THIS WHICH MEANS THAT
YOU KNOW IF WE DO. AS MR GIPSON
SAYS THEY SAY IT WOULD REALLY
FOCUS ON DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND THAT WOULD MEAN
IN MANY WAYS MY DISTRICT
WOULDN'T HAVE ANY OPPORTUNITY TO
GET FUNDING. I ALSO THINK THAT A
IF YOU LEAVE IT UP TO INDIVIDUAL
US SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO EITHER
SEEK OUT THE FUNDING APPLY FOR
THE GRANTS.
OR OF BE INTERESTED IN THE SOME
WILL AND SOME WON'T SO YOU'RE
GONNA ALSO HAVE THAT. THAT
OPPORTUNITY UP MAY BE TAKEN
BECAUSE THE DISTRICT SAYS THIS
IS NOT IMPORTANT TO US OR WE
DON'T HAVE THE FUNDS FOR IT OR
WE CAN'T COMPETE WITH THE GRANT
SO THAT AGAIN SOME DISTRICTS
HAVE MANY MORE TOOLS. THAN
OTHERS WHETHER THEY HAVE A HIRED
A GRANT WRITER WHETHER THEY YEAH
YEAH AND THESE ARE ALL LITTLE
NUANCES BUT WHEN IT COMES DOWN
TO FUNDING SOMEBODY HAS MORE AN
ADVANTAGE BECAUSE THEY HAVE A
FULL TIME GRANT WRITER ON THEIR
STAFF. OR IF YOU HAVE PARENTS
WHO ARE VERY VERY VOCAL ABOUT
WHETHER IT BE THEATER ARTS AWARD
DANCE OR.
SPORTS AND THEY'RE PUSHING FOR
THAT KIND OF.
I EMPHASIS ON FUNDING THEY MAY
NOT SPEAK UP ABOUT C. T. E. AND
AGAIN IF IT SEEMS AS IF THEY'RE
NOT INTERESTED IN THEY DON'T
MOVE FORWARD WITH. APPLYING
AGAIN WE MAY OR MAY HAVE IT MAY
NOT BE THE MAJORITY OF STUDENTS
BUT IT MAY BE IF YOU HAVE YOU
KNOW A THOUSAND STUDENTS MAYBE
TWO HUNDRED STUDENTS. THAT DON'T
GET SERVE BECAUSE THEY EITHER
DON'T KNOW ABOUT PROGRAMS THAT
PARENTS AREN'T ADVOCATING FOR
THEM THERE COULD BE NO INTEREST
BY THE SCHOOL BOARD SO I REALLY
WHATEVER MODEL IS CHOSEN I THINK
AS A BODY. WE NEED TO UNDERSTAND
THAT THERE IS A GROUP OF
STUDENTS OUT THERE THAT THRIVE
IN THIS TYPE OF SETTING THERE IS
A GROUP OF STUDENTS THAT.
LEAVE HIGH SCHOOL AND
IMMEDIATELY.
WANT TO GO INTO SOME TYPE OF
PROFESSION WHETHER IT'S A PRE
NURSING WHERE THEY'RE LIKE YOU
SAY CONSTRUCTION. AND THE WE
HAVE TO HAVE AN ALTERNATIVE FOR
THEM THAT IS NOT THE SECONDARY
ALTERNATIVE IT'S KIND OF LIKE
WELL IF WE HAVE MONEY WILL FUND
IT.
THIS HAS TO BE PART OF WHAT WE
DO BECAUSE NOT EVERYBODY IS
GOING TO GO TO A TWO YEAR. OR
FOUR YEAR AND BOTTOM LINE IS WE
HAVE VERY VERY TALENTED PEOPLE.
THAT GO INTO TRADES THAT GO
INTO A BUSINESS MODELS AND THEY
SUCCEED THERE AND WE HAVE MANY
MANY YOUNG STUDENTS TRYING OUT
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES SOMETIMES
FOR FIVE AND SIX YEARS. KIND OF
FLOUNDERING LOOKING FOR WHERE
THERE'S MOST DO IN IT AND MANY
CASES THAT THEY ACTUALLY WANT TO
DO ELECTRICAL WORK WHATEVER THAT
IS THAT'S KILLER TRADE BUT
THEY'VE KIND OF BEEN. PUSHED
INTO A DIFFERENT SETTING SO.
IT'S MAKING SURE THAT WE REALLY
PUSH THAT WE KEEP THAT THERE'S
SOME KIND OF FAIR ADVANTAGE.
THAT DOES NOT ELIMINATE A WHOLE
GROUP OF.
STUDENTS FROM DISTRICT TO
DISTRICT.
THANK YOU AYE NEXT DOCTOR WEBER.
YEAH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I
APPRECIATE ALL OF YOUR COMMENTS
IN THEM.
AND AND ALL MY COLLEAGUES COME
IT'S IN SOME WAS LIKE THIS IS
THE HOME RELIVING OF FIVE YEARS
AGO WHAT LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA. THOSE WHO REMEMBER THAT
AND.
AND SOME OF THE QUESTIONS I
THINK WE HAVE A REST IN THE FACT
THAT.
.
THAT TOLD CONCEPT OF L. CFF WAS
NEVER FULLY COMPLETED BECAUSE IT
NEVER HAD A STRONG
ACCOUNTABILITY DOCUMENT ATTACHED
TO IT. NOW THE THE DASHBOARD IS
AN EFFORT TO MOVE IN THAT
DIRECTION AND AND PROBABLY CITY
MAY HAVE MORE DATA AND MORE
INFORMATION IN TERMS OF
ACCOUNTABILITY THAT SOME OF THE
OTHER. INDICATORS THAT WE HAVE
TO DO WITH ACADEMIC SINCE WHAT
HAVE BEEN TERMS OF WHAT DOES
THAT REALLY MEAN.
SO I THINK IT'S IT'S A IT'S
THEM YOU KNOW THIS IS.
A PROCESS IT SEEMS LIKE WE KEEP
GOING THROUGH OVER AND OVER
BECAUSE I IMMEDIATELY AFTER WE
DID ALL CFF PEOPLE WANTED TO DO
CATEGORICAL TO GIVE.
AND THAT'S HOW CTE CAME INTO
BEING WHERE PEOPLE HATE THE
CATEGORICAL AS ALONG AS IT WAS
TAKING UP THINGS THEY DIDN'T
LIKE BUT THAT PEOPLE IN THE
THINK THAT THEY DID LIKE SO. YOU
ALSO THEY'RE IN A LIKE A CRISIS
OF IDENTITY WITH REGARDS TO LC
FF YOU KNOW YOU THE WONDERS OF
LCF F.. THEN PEOPLE START SAY
BUT WE GO MAKE YOU DO THIS AND
SO THAT'S THE ONGOING CHALLENGE
WE DON'T SPECIFICALLY IDENTIFY
WHAT WE HOPE IS AN OUTCOME FOR
ALL STUDENTS WITH REGARDS TO IT
AND HOW DO WE MEASURE THAT IN
THE VERY SCHOOLS THAT ARE THERE
BECAUSE OTHERWISE. YOU'RE GONNA
FIND YOURSELF WITH THAT NUMBER
OF ISSUES THAT ARE COMING
FORWARD REAL SOON. WITH A
SPECIAL ED OR SOMETHING OF THAT
WE'RE GOING TO FIND OURSELVES
ONCE AGAIN FACTOR THAT
CATEGORICAL MODEL WHERE WE SAY
OKAY. YOU KNOW WE NEED THIS AND
SINCE YOU DIDN'T DO IT WILL MAKE
YOU DO IT AND SO THAT WE COULD
DEVELOP A CATEGORICAL. AT
ANOTHER CATEGORICAL AND THEN
WILL FIND US ALSO THIRTY
CATEGORICAL LIKE WE DID BEFORE
ON EVERY ISSUE YOU COULD
POSSIBLY IMAGINE AND IN SCHOOLS
COMPLAINING WHATEVER WE WANT TO
CALL IT IT
HAS LIMITATIONS.
OF FOR A PERSON'S LIFE NOW WE
LOOK AT IT IS HAVING GREAT
OPPORTUNITY BUT OFTENTIMES
UNLESS IT IS SOMETHING LIKE LINK
LEARNING AND IDYLLWILD WE HAVE
MOVED TO LINK LEARNING READ THAN
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION.
BECAUSE.
IN THOSE CASES YOU GET STRONG
ACADEMIC FOUNDATION.
AND ONE OF THINGS YOU LEARN IN
EDUCATION IS THAT THE ONLY REAL
SKILLS WE HAVE THAT WILL LAST
FOR TIMES READING AND MATH AND
COMPUTATION.
BECAUSE IF YOU AND IF YOU DON'T
HAVE GOOD SKILLS AT THAT LEVEL.
IF ANYTHING WHAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO DO IS GONNA BE SHORT LIVED
BECAUSE GOING TO CHANGE TOMORROW
WITH TECHNOLOGY THAT'S COME WITH
SOMETHING NEW COMING ALONG AS TO
HOW YOU MEASURE SOMETHING OF
WHAT YOU PUT IN PLACE A HOW YOU
DEVELOP SOMETHING. AND SO WOULD
NOT EQUIPPING OUR STUDENTS WITH
REALLY STRONG.
ACADEMIC FOUNDATIONS THAT ARE
MEASURED AND SOMETIMES
MANIFESTED IN THESE VARIOUS
CAREER OPTIONS AND CHOICES. UP
IT WILL BE SHORT LIVED IT'S
GONNA BE IT'S GONNA BE LIKE OLD
TO OF. THE BOOK IT PROGRAM THAT
MOST OF YOU TALK ABOUT HOW
WONDERFUL IT WAS A CHIU DRILLED
HOLES MADE ESTRACE BUT.
THEY WE DON'T DO THAT ANYMORE
HER IN SO AS A RESULT REGARDLESS
SO BOMB. AND WHAT I SAY ESTRACE
KIDS GOING ON TIME BUT NOWADAYS
BECAUSE SOMEONE HAS ASKED FOR
ANYWHERE BUT.
.
BUT SO I'M WONDERING WHY WE
HAVEN'T MOVED OUR THINKING
TOWARD WILL BUT LINK LEARNING
MODEL. NOW THAT LINK LEARNS
CONFERENCE THE OTHER DAY IN
TERMS OF YOU KNOW YOU DEAL WITH
THE CAREER OPTIONS YOU DEAL WITH
A SOFT SKILL WHICH ALSO DEAL
WITH THE HAS STRONG ACADEMIC
FOUNDATION. SO THAT WHEN A
STUDENT GRADUATES THEY HAVE THEY
HAVE THEIR WE HAVE ALL THESE
CAREERS IN THE CREEK PATHWAYS
THAT THEY HAVE THIS WHOLE ARRAY
OF STUFF THAT'S AVAILABLE TO
THEM. AND AND I THINK AS LONG AS
WE KEEP THE TERMINOLOGY CAREER
TECH EDUCATION WE WE SOMETIMES
SHORT CHANGE OUR KNOWLEDGE.
SEE THAT LOOK WHAT HAPPENED
OKAY.
TO WHOM WE SHORT CHANGE OUR
KNOWLEDGE OF WHAT WE SHOULD BE
MOVING TO IN TERMS OF WHAT WHAT
IS OUT THERE BECAUSE. YOU I HAVE
A LOT OF KIDS WHO WANT ONE TO AN
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM AND WHO.
BUT THEY HAVE SUCH POOR MATH
SKILLS.
BUT THEY CAN'T QUALIFY FOR A. B.
A PROGRAM AND THAT'S SOUNDS UP
APTLY HORRIBLE BUT THE STANDARDS
ARE HIGH NOW. AND SHOW SO WE'RE
NOT IF WE KEEP THE OLD MODEL AND
WE KEEP MIDDLE CLASS IN A CLASS
RATHER THAN THE INTEGRATION OF
CURRICULUM THAT HAPPENS IN A. IN
A LINK LEARNING ENVIRONMENT.
.
I THINK WE SHOULD CHANGE OUR
KIDS AND I DON'T THINK WOULD DO
IN THIS WONDERFUL CAREER
PREPARATION STUFF THAT WE THINK
WE'RE MOVING INTO. BIKE BY
CONFLICT TALKING ABOUT IT IN
THIS WAY AS A COURSE IN OF
COURSE THERE RATHER THAN A WHOLE
WAY OF THINKING THAT EXIST ON
SCHOOLS WITH REGARDS TO
CURRICULUM AND. AND THE
INTEGRATION OF THAT CURRICULUM
INTO THE CAREERS IN THE PATHWAYS
AND THINGS LIKE THAT BUT ALSO
VERY STRONG FOUNDATIONS A WE GOT
AWAY FROM BOTH HIT BECAUSE IT
WAS A VERY LIMITING. AND OFTEN
IT WAS AS OUR CHAIR TALK ABOUT
TRACKING CERTAIN KIDS IT A
PATHWAY THAT THEY COULDN'T GET
OUT OF AND END UP AT THE END OF
THE LINE WITH VERY LIMITED
SKILLS THEY COULD WORK FOR THAT.
PERIOD OF TIME BECAUSE THEY WERE
MEETING THE NEEDS WITHIN ONE
THAT PROFESSION CHANGE THEIR
SHIFT IT. THEY DON'T HAVE THE
SKILLS TO SHIFT WITH THE.
SO I HOPE THAT OUR THINKING GETS
BIGGER THAN WHERE WE ARE THAT IT
REALLY STARTS IMPACTING THE FULL
CURRICULUM.
AND.
AND THAT WE REALLY START
TALKING ABOUT LINK LEARNING AND
AND HOW WE LINK UP THESE THINGS
ALL SCHOOLS THAT HAVE DONE LINK
LEARNING HAVE AMAZING RESULTS.
IN TERMS OF THE YOUNG PEOPLE AND
THEIR ACTIONS WHEN THEY LEAVE.
A AND AND WHAT THEY CAN DO AND
AND AND AND AND THE WORLD IS
CHANGING SO RAPIDLY. THAT THOSE
TWO SKILLS OF THIS COMPUTATIONAL
SKILLS. AND EURO OF LITERACY
SKILLS ARE TO THE TWO SKILLS
THAT WORK YOU THROUGH LIFE RIGHT
NOW. A AND GOT WILL AND AND MOST
OF OUR KIDS WILL CHANGE
PROFESSIONS A ZILLION TIMES I'M
A PROBABLY A DINOSAUR ANYONE
ABOUT A PROFESSION FOR FORTY
YEARS. UP THEIR PART WILL BE
MANY OF THOSE LEFT IN THE WORLD
UP BECAUSE OUR FOLKS OF THAT
YOUNG PEOPLE GOING TO CHANGE SO
OFTEN. AND THEY SHOULD HAVE THE
SKILLS TO ADAPT AND CHANGE AND
TO RECREATE THEMSELVES A BASED
ON THE INTEREST THAT THEY HAVE
BEEN BASED ON THE CHANGING
MARKETPLACE. SO I'M JUST HOPING
THAT AS WE TALK CT %
WHATEVER THAT WE REALLY MOVE TO
SOMETHING ELSE.
AND THAT WE DON'T SEE THIS AS
SUCH A LIMITED THING BUT THAT IT
IS REALLY INCORPORATED. IN ALL
OF THE COURSES AND THE WHOLE K.
TWELVE SYSTEM.
THAT HELPS YOUNG PEOPLE REALLY
DEFINE WHAT THEY WANTED TO IN
THEIR LIFE WITHOUT LIMITATIONS.
THANK YOU THOMAS BURKE.
AND SO I WOULD AGREE WITH DOCTOR
WEBER AND THAT MY MOM ALWAYS
TOLD ME WHATEVER I WOULD END UP
DOING I PROBABLY HAVEN'T HEARD
OF TODAY.
AND I AM PERSONALLY RIGHT NOW
SHE'S WRONG TO THEM EXACTLY
WHERE SHE STARTED.
YOU KNOW RYAN AND LET THEM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IS EXACTLY SHE
WAS WERE AND I WAS BORN SO.
THAT MAY NOT APPLY TO ME BUT. I
I AGREE WITH DOCTOR WEBER IN THE
FACT THAT THAT PROBABLY APPLIES
TO MOST YOUNG PEOPLE HOWEVER I
WILL SAY I DO THEY HAVE TO. KIND
OF GO THE OTHER DIRECTION ON ON
THE SHORT LIVED PART OF IT I
THINK.
I I COME FROM A COMMUNITY THAT
WOULD BE HAPPY TO BE HAVE A
CERTIFICATION THAT ALTHOUGH MAY
NOT BE PERMANENT AND MAY BE.
SLIGHTLY SHORT LIVED ENOUGH
THAT'S TEN YEARS OR FIFTEEN
YEARS WOULD. WOULD BE THANKFUL
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO START A
LIFE.
AND TO START A CAREER.
AND SO WHEN I LOOK AT THE FACT
THAT WE HAVE A HUNDRED THOUSAND
AND JOBS THAT ARE NOT FILLED
WITH CAREERS THAT WOULD BE A
CERTIFICATION WOULD WOULD PUT
THEM IN AND PUT PUT THE KIDS
INTO. CAREER OPPORTUNITIES WHERE
THEY CAN BUY A HOME WITH A START
AT SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
YEAR AND THOSE ARE IN MY
DISTRICT THOSE ARE IT THOSE ARE.
TECHNICAL JOBS IF THEY JUST NEED
A CERTIFICATION AND I DO SEE
THAT WE HAVE BUSINESSES THAT ARE
STARTING TO UNDERSTAND THAT AND
CERTIFY THEMSELVES. BUT I DON'T
THINK IT'S BUSINESSES SOLE
RESPONSIBILITY TO FILL THEIR OWN
JOBS I THINK THAT WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO THE CHILDREN
THAT WE HAD TO KATE TO CREATE
THOSE JOBS. OUGHT TO CREATE
THOSE OPPORTUNITIES FOR THEM.
YOU KNOW I LOOK AT MY WORKFORCE
INVESTMENT BOARD THEY'VE DONE A
FANTASTIC JOB CONNECTING AYE
EDUCATION WITH AEROSPACE OR
WITH.
OR OR WITH MEDICAL INDUSTRY AND
ALL THESE OTHER THINGS.
I WILL SAY THIS I SAY TO THANKS.
ONE I THINK THE STUDY SHOULD
OCCUR TECHNICAL EDUCATION HAVE
ENCOURAGE STUDENTS TO HAVE A
REASON TO GO TO SCHOOL. THEY
HAVE IT'S APPLICABLE THEY SEE
WHEN THEIR SKILLS AYE IT WE SAY
THAT'S IN MY DISTRICT I HAVE EA
SPORTS AND WE ALWAYS SAY MATH
LEADS TO MADDEN OF MORE MY KIDS
KNEW THAT GOING TO MATH CLASS
WOULD LEAD THEM TO BE ABLE TO
CREATE GAMES LIKE MADDEN. THEY'D
SHOW UP.
AND SO I DON'T SEE IT AS A
LIMITED OPPORTUNITY CREW
TECHNICAL EDUCATION I SEE IT AS
AN OPPORTUNITY INTO THEM. TO
KEEP KIDS ENGAGED TO KEEP YOUNG
PEOPLE ENGAGED IN TO WATCH THE
MOVE INTO THE NEXT PHASE OF
THEIR LIVES.
AND WHETHER THAT IS A CAREER OR
WHETHER THAT IS THE NEXT LEVEL
OF EDUCATION I THINK IT'S
VITALLY IMPORTANT TO US THAT
THE.
THAT ALL OF OUR STUDENTS GET THE
RPG DO THAT WHETHER WE ARE IN
DISADVANTAGED MEANS OUR
COMMUNITIES. IN WHICH THERE ARE
JUST JOB OPPORTUNITIES.
I'M I DO HAVE ONE QUESTION AND I
DO AT TWO QUESTIONS ACTUALLY ONE
I AM CONCERNED ABOUT.
WHAT? ASSEMBLY MEMBER O'DONNELL
MENTIONED ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT
IT'S VERY A REGIONAL APPROACH
BUT ALSO AND TRYING TO MAKE SURE
I UNDERSTAND I MIGHT HAVE MISSED
HEARD YOU. AND I WANNA MAKE SURE
I UNDERSTAND THE PROCESS BY
WHICH THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL IS
DIVIDING UP THIS MONEY SO ARE
YOU SAYING THAT THE MONEY WILL
BE DIVIDED EQUALLY OVER EACH
CONSORTIUM. OR HOW EXPLAIN TO ME
EXACTLY HOW YOU SEE THIS WORKING
BECAUSE THE AYE I HEARD GRANT
PROGRAM BUT THEN I HEARD YOU SAY
THAT WE WERE MOVING AWAY FROM
THE GRANT MODEL AND I JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE I UNDERSTAND A HUNDRED
PERCENT. BEFORE WE MOVE FORWARD
THINK YOU.
SO THIRTY AND THE FUNDING IS
ALLOCATED TO THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE WHO WILL THEN USE THE A
FORMULA TO DISTRIBUTE IT DOWN TO
THE CONSORTIA SO THE FORMULA IS.
BASED ON THE UNEMPLOYMENT RATE
IN THE REGION AND THE PROJECTED
JOB OPENINGS IN THE REGION AND
THE SEVEN THROUGH TWELVE ABA IN
THE REGION. SO EACH EACH
REGION'S CONSORTIUM CONSORTIUM
ALLOCATION WILL WILL VARY THAT
BASED ON THAT FORMULA SAID IT'S
NOT A SET.
YES.
THANK YOU ARE MR MURATSUCHI.
THANK YOU.
SO I SOME OF. MY COLLEAGUES KNOW
THAT I SAT ON THE. BOARD OF
TRUSTEES OF AGED BY JP A CURRENT
TECHNICAL EDUCATION.
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
REGIONAL OCCUPATIONAL CENTER A
LOCATED MY DISTRICT IN TORRANCE
AND DOWNED AYE I CAN ATTEST TO
WELL A LOT OF WHAT MY COLLEAGUES
HAVE ALREADY TALKED ABOUT THE.
THESE DID THAT THE VALUE OF.
NOT NOT ONLY THE CURRENT
TECHNICAL EDUCATION BUT THE LINK
LEARNING ASPECT OF IT OF OF OF
MAKING SURE THAT TO. THAT THERE
IS SAID YOU WERE TEACHING SOLID.
READING AND AND AND MATH SKILLS
AS PART OF THAT TEACHING OF
THESE THESE WORK SKILLS. SO I.
.
BASED ON MY EXPERIENCE I HAVE TO
CAN A CONCERNS ARE TWO QUESTIONS
ONE IS.
.
THE LA OWES.
WRITTEN ANALYSES TALK ABOUT
SCHOOL DISTRICTS APPLYING FOR. A
V..
.
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED.
GRANTS.
GRANTS THAT WOULD BE ISSUED
THROUGH THE.
.
THE CONSORTIA BUT.
WILL GPAS ALSO BE ABLE TO APPLY
FOR THESE THESE FUNDS AND SECOND
ARE THERE REGULATIONS.
THAT EXIST OR THAT WILL THAT
DID THAT ARE IN THE TRAILER
LANGUAGE OR ANYWHERE ELSE.
AS STE THAT THAT DEFINES HOW
THESE REGIONAL CONSORTIA ARE
GOVERNED.
I APOLOGIZE FOR HAVING MY AND MY
BACK TO YOU IN MY RESPONSE BUT
IT'S A LITTLE BIT OF AN AWKWARD
SET UP HERE SO I AM. JP EIGHT
ARE ELIGIBLE IT'S THAT'S THE
SAME.
ELIGIBILITY.
PULL AS UNDER CITY INCENTIVE
FRANCIS SCHOOL DISTRICTS COUNTY
OFFICES CHARTERS I'M ARE
APPEASING APA'S ARE ELIGIBLE.
JP'S DO HAVE A LOWER MATCH
UNDER OUR PROPOSAL SO IT'S A ONE
TO ONE.
RATHER THAN THE TWO TO ONE FOR
THE OTHER I'M AT THAT THE OTHER
APPLICANTS.
.
NAY POLITICALLY IF ABOUT YOUR IT
YOUR THAT THE SECOND QUESTION
ARE ARE ARE THERE ARE
REGULATIONS.
DATA DESCRIBE HOW THESE
REGIONAL CONSORTIA ARE TO BE
GOVERNED SO EACH OF BUT I'M EACH
OF THEM REGIONAL CONSORTIA I'M
HAVE TO DO A REGIONAL PLAN AND
AND NOT PLANNED THEY DESCRIBE
THEIR GOVERNANCE MODELS ABOUT IS
SOMETHING THAT'S DECIDED.
LOCALLY BY THE REGION AND BUT
IT IS DESCRIBED IN THEIR PLANTS
SO TO FOLLOW UP ON THAT. I MEAN
IF.
IF THE FUNDS ARE GOING TO BE.
AS AS YOU INDICATED PASSED
THROUGH THE CHANCES OFFICE TO
THE CONSORTIA.
YOU KNOW WHAT WOULD PREVENT.
BUT IF WILL NEVER WANT TO SOUND
LIKE DIFFERENT CONSORTIA WILL BE
GOVERNED ACCORDING TO THEIR OWN
RULES AND SO EACH CONSORTIA WILL
LOOK DIFFERENT. HAVE WHAT IS TO
PREVENT.
YOU KNOW GOOD CONSORTIA FROM
FROM HAVING YOU KNOW SOME BIAS
EITHER FOR.
PROGRAMS THAT ARE ADMINISTERED
BY THEIR LOCAL COMMUNICABLE AGE
AS OPPOSED TO THE LOCAL.
SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
DO WHAT WEATHERED I MEAN IT
JUST SEEMS LIKE. IF WE'RE GOING
TO BE CREATING. A NEW LEVEL OF
GOVERNANCE.
THROUGH THESE REGIONAL
CONSORTIA THEN IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT WE HAVE.
SOME UNIFORM RULES THAT WOULD
ALLOW OF FOR THOSE GRANTS TO BE
A.
DISTRIBUTED FAIRLY.
AND AND AND NOT. CONTROLLED ARE
BIASED TOWARD.
YOU KNOW THE THE LOCAL CAN
UNICOLOR CHEN THEIR PROGRAMS.
I I JUST WOULD LIKE.
MORE ASSURANCE THAT THAT THAT
THESE GRANTS TO PS A.
YOU KNOW.
ADMINISTERED FAIRLY AND AND AND
THAT.
.
OKAY THERE THAT THERE'D BE SOME
BASIC ROLES AS TO HOW THIS IS
GOING TO WORK.
IN A MISTER MISTER MURATSUCHI IF
I MAY OF USE PRE PREFLIGHT
RESPONDED THAT THAT'S A VERY
COMPLICATED ANSWER I THINK. AND
THAT'S WHAT I HAD ON EARLIER I
THINK IT'S REALLY WE'RE REALLY
OUGHT TO DIVE INTO THAT IN THE
IN BUDGET SUB TO FOR SURE
BECAUSE I DON'T UNDERSTAND. I
THINK EXPLAIN AGAIN AND I
UNDERSTAND I UNDERSTAND. A
THOMAS BURKE THEY'RE GONNA GIVE
THE MONEY TO CONSORTIUM MY
CHALLENGES HOUSING CONSORTIUM
GOING TO DELIVER SO I DON'T
WANNA GET FURTHER IT TOO FAR TOO
FAR INTO THAT RIGHT NOW IF YOU
COULD JUST GIVE A SHORT ANSWER
BECAUSE WE DO HAVE MISTER KILEY.
WHO ARE RUNNING SIGNIFICANTLY
BEHIND HER AS RIGHT NOW I'LL
JUST POINT OUT THAT I'M UNDER
THE EXISTING PROGRAM IN STATUTE
THERE ARE ARE REQUIREMENTS THAT
THE CONSORTIUM COLLABORATE WITH
VARIOUS DIFFERENT DO YOU SO? I'M
HIGH INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER
EDUCATION IN THEIR REGION
ELEAZAR.
CIVIC LEADERS THAT THERE'S A
WHOLE HOST SO IT'S NOT
NECESSARILY A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SUFFICIENT WITHIN THE CONSORTIUM
IT REALLY AS A BROAD SPECTRUM OF
STAKEHOLDERS AT THAT POINT.
THANK YOU MISTER KILEY WILL BE
OUR OUR LAST QUESTION ON FOR
THIS PANEL.
I THINK YOU HAVE A QUESTION FOR
MS.
COLLINS I SUED THE LA AS
RECOMMENDATION IS THAT WE TAKE
CARE OF THE LCF APPROACH TO AYE.
TO.
CT AND CAN YOU EXPLAIN A LITTLE
MORE WITHOUT DETAIL YOU
BASICALLY RECOMMENDING THAT WE
JUST.
AUGMENT.
THAT THE FUNDING TO WHATEVER
DEGREE.
AND THEN.
YOU KNOW I SEE HOW THEY DO BY
THE COLLAGEN ENCOURAGING THIS
INDICATOR.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION.
.
ESSENTIALLY WHAT WE RECOMMEND IS
TAKING THE LC FF APPROACH WHICH
PROVIDE SIXTEEN PERCENT MORE
FUNDING THAN THE MIDDLE SCHOOL
BASE RATE. I'M TO ACCOUNT FOR
THE HIGHER COSTS OF THINGS LIKE.
CREW TECHNICAL EDUCATION AND.
COLLEGE PREPAREDNESS THIS IS
THE ORIGINAL APPROACH THAT THE
STATE DETERMINED AT WHICH TO
TAKE FOR CT .
BACK IN A TWENTY TWELVE OR
TWENTY THIRTEEN FOURTEEN WE
ADOPTED THE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA THE THOUGHT
WOULD BE THAT FOR MANY OF THE
CATEGORICAL PROGRAMS GIFTED AND
TALENTED.
FOR EXAMPLE.
CT  THAT INSTEAD OF HAVING
DISTINCT EARMARKED FUNDING FOR
THOSE PROGRAMS THAT WOULD
REQUIRE DISTRICTS TO.
PERFORM A LOT OF COMPLEX
COMPLIANCE BASED ACTIVITIES THAT
CREATED.
INEQUITABLE FUNDING ACROSS
DISTRICT BASED ON HISTORICAL.
.
VARIABLES THAT BE LCF APPROACH
WOULD PROVIDE MORE FUNDING TO
STUDENTS BASED ON WHETHER THEY
WERE LOW INCOME ENGLISH LEARNERS
ARE FOSTER YOU.
AND THE THOUGHT WAS INSTEAD OF
DECIDING.
HERE IN SACRAMENTO WHAT LOCAL
PRIORITIES WOULD BE WE WOULD
WILL ALLOW THE LOCAL SET ASIDE
THROUGH. ON THE AL CAPP PROCESS
WHERE STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING
PARENTS AND TEACHERS AND OTHERS
WOULD COME TO THE TABLE AND
DETERMINE HOW THEY WOULD SERVE
STUDENTS.
TO BE NOT ONLY COLLEGE AND
CAREER READY BUT ALSO ENGAGED.
AT WE HAVE A WE HAVE EIGHT
STATE PRIORITIES THAT WE WE
WANTED SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
ADDRESS.
SO WHAT OUR RECOMMENDATION IS
FOR FOR MANY OF THE.
.
FOR MANY OF THE REASONS THAT
THAT US SOME OF THE MEMBERS
BROUGHT UP TODAY CONCERNS THAT
NOT EVERYBODY IS GOING TO APPLY
FOR A GRANT FOR EXAMPLE. WHAT
OUR RECOMMENDATION IS IS THROUGH
THE LC FF THE EXPECTATION IS
THAT EVERYONE PERFORMS COLLEGE
AND CAREER READINESS ACTIVITIES?
WE HOLD EVERYBODY ACCOUNTABLE
NOT JUST THOSE THAT ARE
RECEIVING FUNDS FOR IT AS WE DID
UNDER THE RCP DAYS BUT THE BUT
EVERY HIGH SCHOOL WAS HELD
ACCOUNTABLE THROUGH THE.
NEW ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM.
THE NEW ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM
HAS TAKEN AWHILE TO ROLL OUT
THERE SOME CONCERNS WITH THE
INDICATORS RIGHT WITHOUT A
TRANSITION PERIOD BECAUSE WE
DIDN'T HAVE FULL IMPLEMENTATION
OF ALL CFF THAT PROVIDE THAT
EXTRA FUNDING FOR HIGH SCHOOLS.
I OR ANYONE ACTUALLY ON THAT
WASN'T FULLY FUNDED FOR ANY I'M
GREAT SPAN.
SO OUR OUR RECOMMENDATION IS
CONTEST TO CONTINUE DOWN THAT
PATH OF REQUIRING EVERYONE TO
PROVIDE CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION AND HOLDING THEM
ACCOUNTABLE FOR IT. SO I GUESS I
THE ISSUE IS THAT THE WAY THE
INDICATORS CURRENTLY WRITTEN IS
IT DOESN'T NECESSARILY DO THAT
RIGHT THERE IS THAT YOU CAN
SATISFY THIS INDICATOR THROUGH A
VARIETY OF. MEANS THAT THAT
DON'T NECESSARILY INCLUDE ANY
VOCATIONAL OFFERING AT ALL IS
THAT IS THAT RIGHT.
YES WE AGREE THAT IF THE
LEGISLATURE HAS CONCERNS WITH
THAT THAT IT COULD MAKE
ADJUSTMENTS TO THE INDICATOR.
STATE BOARD IS PLANNING TO ADD
OVER THE NEXT THREE YEARS MORE
CAREER EDUCATION.
METRICS INTO THE INDICATOR
INCLUDING WORK BASED LEARNING.
AND.
CERTIFICATES BUT WE BELIEVE
THAT IF THE LEGISLATURE HAS ITS
CONCERNS IT CAN IT HAS THE POWER
TO. MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS TO
ADDRESS THAT VERY CONCERNED
BECAUSE THAT'S CONCERNED WE'VE
HEARD AS WELL BUT I WOULD NOTE
THAT WHILE THIS IS OUR
RECOMMENDATION WE WE RECOGNIZE
THAT THERE IS SIGNIFICANT
INTEREST IN CREATING. A
CATEGORICAL AND EARMARKED
PROGRAM AND THAT'S WHY IN OUR
ANALYSIS WE PROVIDED.
SOME RECOMMENDATIONS FOR HOW
YOU MIGHT STRUCTURE THAT WE
THINK THAT ACCOUNTABILITY EVEN
IF YOU TAKE A CATEGORICAL ROUTE
IS REALLY IMPORTANT IMPROVING
ACCOUNTABILITY AND IF YOU TAKE
THE L. CFF ROUTE. WE HAVE SOME
IDEAS FOR IMPROVEMENT AS WELL
INCLUDING.
LONGER TERM INDICATORS WE RIGHT
NOW DON'T KNOW AFTER A STUDENT
COMPLETES HIGH SCHOOL. IF SAY
GOING TO COMMITTEE COLLEGE INTO
A FOUR YEAR INTO AN
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM.
SO WE THINK AT THE VERY LEAST
THOSE TYPES OF IMPROVEMENTS
COULD BE MADE OF NO MATTER WHAT
APPROACH YOU DECIDE TO TAKE
RIGHT YEAH I GUESS THAT'S WHAT I
SEE IS.
THE TENSION HERE IS THAT.
.
I MEAN SEPARATE FROM THE
QUESTION OF ACCOUNTABILITY WE
DON'T REALLY SEEM TO HAVE ANY
VISION AS TO WHAT THE
APPROPRIATE.
YOU KNOW AND GOAL IS OUT WE
SEEM TO HAVE SOME AGREEMENT MORE
CT WOULD BE GOOD.
BY.
IT DOES NOT MEAN THAT EVERY
STUDENT SHOULD HAVE SOME
EXPOSURE TO IT DOES NOT MEAN
THAT EVERY STUDENT SHOULD HAVE
A.
VARIETY OF CAREER OFFERINGS
WITHIN THEIR DISTRICT WITHIN
THEIR REGION AND DIE THERE
DOESN'T SEEM TO BE ANY CONSENSUS
ON THAT AND YET WERE.
DEBATING SORT OF WHAT'S THE
BEST FUNDING MECHANISM TOWARDS
AN. UNDEFINED GOAL.
SO I DON'T KNOW IF THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE HAS AYE
UNANSWERED ABOUT THAT'S TO KIND
OF WHAT. WHAT OUR VISION IS HERE
BUT THE OTHER POINT ALL HAD IS
THAT I THINK THAT YOU KNOW
DOCTOR WEBER'S COMMENTS ARE
WORTH TAKING REALLY SERIOUSLY
AND PART OF THE REASON FOR THAT
IS TO BE A DIFFERENT
CONVERSATION OF WERE SITTING? IN
A STATE THAT HAS THE BEST K.
TWELVE EDUCATION IN THE COUNTRY.
AND WE DO HAVE MANY MANY
OUTSTANDING SCHOOLS IN THE STATE
BUT WE ACTUALLY HAVE ABOUT THE
WORST PERFORMANCE WHEN IT COMES
TO TRADITIONAL ECONOMIC
INDICATORS IN CASE THROUGH
TWELVE. AND WHEN YOU'RE
DISCUSSING CT  OF
OCCASIONAL EDUCATION IN THAT
CONTEXT THEN IT ALMOST SEEMS
LIKE SUMMER READY TO JUMP AT THE
IDEA THAT THIS IS SOMEHOW AN
ALTERNATIVE AND IT CAN'T I DON'T
THINK BE. CONCEIVED OF THAT WAY
THAT.
THAT THIS THAT THESE OFFERINGS
ARE VITAL TO HAVE AND I THINK
THAT EVERY GUY STUDENTS SHOULD
HAVE ACCESS TO VOCATIONAL
EDUCATION BUT I IT'S NOT A
SUBSTITUTE FOR BASIC. OTHER
BASIC EDUCATION THAT EVERY CHILD
IN CALIFORNIA I SHOULD BE
GUARANTEED A WERE FALLING FAR
FAR SHORT.
ON ON THIS MORE TRADITIONAL
METRICS I GUESS JUST DIED
ANOTHER THE CHAIR WANTS TO MOVE
ON BUT I'M. YOU YOU DID TALK
ABOUT SOME OF THE METRICS WE
HAVE.
FOR HOW CD PROGRAMS ARE DOING I
DO YOU TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT THOSE
ARE AND THEN WHETHER YOU'VE
NOTICED I'VE.
WHETHER THERE'S ANY CORRELATION
BETWEEN DISTRICTS THAT DO WELL
BY TRADITIONAL ACADEMIC HE
TWELVE METRICS AND THOSE THAT DO
WELL I WOULD CT  OR THOSE.
I'M NOT NECESSARILY CORRELATED
REAP BRIEFLY PLEASE BECAUSE TEAM
AND WE ACTUALLY DON'T HAVE
THE LONG TERM DATA ADDS THAT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S HAD HAD
MENTIONED. THAT WE'VE HAD
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS IN BOTH
STATUTES GOVERNING BOTH PROGRAMS
AND WE DO NOT HAVE THOSE
SPECIFIC OUTCOME MEASURES TO
POINT TO. AND THAT'S THE REASON
WHY WE'RE STRUCTURING OUR
PROPOSAL TO USE THE LAUNCH BOARD
BECAUSE THAT THAT HAS SHOWN
SUCCESS IN BEING ABLE TO TRACK
THROUGH. THE TRACK COMMITTEE
COLLEGE STUDENTS BACK THROUGH
HIGH SCHOOL AND INTO THE WORK
FORCE AND WE BELIEVE THAT BY
INCLUDING THIS DATA ON THE
LAUNCH PORTABLE UNIT POTENTIALLY
EXPAND THE AVAILABILITY OF
METRICS TO BUILD OUT THAT
INDICATOR.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION YOUR INFORMATION
AND.
ELEVEN MEMBERS OUT HERE TODAY
SO THANK YOU. THAT TO ME THIS
ISSUES ABOUT SKILL DEVELOPMENT
AND RICHMOND.
.
AND ULTIMATELY THIS ACADEMIC
SUCCESS AND JOB SUCCESS I THINK
IT'S PRETTY MUCH A NO BRAINER SO
WHY WE'RE HERE TODAY AND WE WERE
PUSHING THE SPORT. UNITY IN A
CLASSROOM YOU CAN MEMORIZE YOUR
YOUR YOUR FRACTIONS BUT IN THE
REAL WORLD YOU CAN APPLY THEM I
THINK THAT'S WHAT THIS IS REALLY
ABOUT SO THANK YOU.
WITH THAT WILL BRING UP OUR NEXT
PANEL PANEL NUMBER TWO
HIGHLIGHTING QUALITY CT
PROGRAMS.
METRO RED WILL COME UP.
ALYSSA LYNCH SUPERINTENDENT
GRAND HAYDEN STUDENT.
JIM KANNO IS A BOARD MEMBER IF
YOU COULD COME FORWARD PLEASE.
AND IF YOU COULD PLEASE BE AS
EFFICIENT AS POSSIBLE BECAUSE WE
ARE IN A SHORT TIME WHEN WE'RE
RUNNING LATE.
BECAUSE OF THE INTEREST IN THIS
TOPIC I MIGHT ADD WHICH IS A
VERY GOOD.
I DON'T THINK HE'S HERE TO MARK.
RAINY IS NOT.
GREAT THANK YOU.
I JUST GO AHEAD AND INTRODUCE
YOURSELF AND YOU MAY PROCEED
WHEN READY.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
SALICYLATE INCH TOM THINK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE
TODAY.
I'M GONNA JUST GONNA MOVE INTO
THIS AND SAY THANK YOU FOR
SAYING IT'S A NO BRAINER I FEEL
LIKE IT IS I WAS VERY PLEASED TO
HEAR A LOT OF MEMBERS. OF THE
PANEL TODAY AND ARE SHOULD SAY
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS AND SENATORS
I'M BORED WITH FUNDING THIS FOR
THE FUTURE TWO HUNDRED MILLION
OR BATH.
SHORTLY I WILL INTRODUCE MY TWO
GUESTS AS WELL SO.
I WANNA SAY THAT I'M THE
SUPERINTENDENT FOR METROPOLITAN
EDUCATION DISTRICT IN SAN JOSE.
WE OPERATE ONE OF THE LARGEST
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION
CENTERS IN CALIFORNIA.
WE SERVE SIX SCHOOL DISTRICTS
THIRTY FIVE HIGH SCHOOLS.
AND WE ARE AN EXTENSION OF OUR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THE PROGRAMS
THAT WE HAVE ARE JUST TOO COSTLY
TO OFFER ON THIRTY FIVE HIGH
SCHOOL CAMPUSES.
WE MAXIMIZE THE DOLLARS FOR OUR
DISTRICTS.
SO JOINING ME TO MY RIGHT TODAY
IS GRANT HATE AND A FORMER
STUDENT FROM CAMPBELL UNION HIGH
SCHOOL DISTRICT.
AND TO MY LEFT IS JIM CANOVA
SEVEN CLARA UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND METROID SCHOOL
BOARD MEMBER.
I'M HERE TODAY BECAUSE I'M
PASSIONATE ABOUT HER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION.
AND IT DESERVES THE FUNDING AND
AGAIN I'M GLAD YOU ALREADY
AGREE.
THIS SHOULDN'T EVEN BE A
QUESTION.
IF CTU SHOULD BE FUNDED OR NOT.
MATH ENGLISH AND SCIENCE
NO ONE EVER ASKS IF YOU'RE GONNA
FIND MOUTH.
OR SCIENCE OR ENGLISH OR SOCIAL
STUDIES.
CT PROVIDE STUDENTS.
THE SKILLS THAT ARE EMPLOYERS
ARE BEGGING FOR IN CALIFORNIA.
THE TIME WHEN FACEBOOK PROJECTS
TO HUNDRED THOUSAND JOBS OPEN.
OVER THERE THE NEXT FIVE YEARS.
IN CALIFORNIA COMPANIES ARE
STRUGGLING TO FIND.
WELL SKILLED.
EMPLOYEES WE CAN'T AFFORD NOT TO
FIND CURRENT TECHNICAL
EDUCATION.
I AM IN SUPPORT OF THE FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION BEING ALLOCATED
FOR AB SEVENTEEN FORTY THREE
OVER THE NEXT FIVE YEARS.
I'M SORRY THREE YEARS.
AND ALONG WITH THAT COMES THE
INCREASED ACCOUNTABILITY AND
WE'RE DEFINITELY INTERESTED IN
THAT.
AND ALIGNING IT WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL DASHBOARD.
HOWEVER I'M NOT IN FAVOR OF JUST
THREE YEARS OF FUNDING.
I'M IN FAVOR OF PERMANENT
FUNDING.
MY FIRST POINT TODAY IS IF ELSIE
FF IS BEING RESTORED TO THE TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHT LEVEL.
THEN SEE TO YOU SHOULD BE
RESTORED TO THE TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHT LEVEL.
TO THE FIVE HUNDRED MILLION THAT
WE HAD.
IN TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHT.
WHEN STUDENTS TAKE A MATH CLASS
IN HIGH SCHOOL THERE ARE FOUR
DIFFERENT TYPES OF MATH CLASSES
THAT WE ALL KNOW ABOUT.
ALGEBRA GEOMETRY CALCULUS.
TRIGONOMETRY.
THERE'S NO DEBATE ALL OF THE
CLASSES ARE FUNDED.
ONE STUDENTS TAKE A CTU CLASS
THERE ARE FOUR TYPES OF CLASSES
THERE'S A CD CLASS ON A HIGH
SCHOOL CAMPUS.
THERE'S A SEA TO YOU CLASS
COUPLED WITH CORE ACADEMIC
CLASSES WHICH I HIGHLY.
HIGHLY EMPHASIZE THEY ARE VERY.
VERY SUCCESSFUL.
THERE ARE TWO HOUR IN THREE HOUR
CLASSES ON CAMPUSES AND CENTERS
LIKE OURS IN SAN JOSE.
CENTERS ARE OFTEN FORGOTTEN
THERE ALWAYS FORGOTTEN AND LEFT
OUT.
AND THEN THERE ARE THE LINK
LEARNING CLASSES.
I BELIEVE THAT THOSE ARE
VALUABLE AS WELL.
LEGISLATORS NEED TO FIND ALL
CITY PROGRAMS.
WITHOUT BEING COMPETITIVE
WITHOUT HAVING TO MATCH DOLLARS
ARE SPENT THE LAST FIVE YEARS
WRITING GRANTS AND MATCHING
DOLLARS AND I REALLY DON'T HAVE.
IN IN THE FUTURE TAKING ALONE.
MY SECOND POINT.
STUDENTS PARTICIPATING SCHOOLS
AND REGIONAL SEE TO YOU CENTERS
TO PROVIDE HIGH QUALITY RIGOR
CITY PROGRAMS.
HAVE SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER
ACHIEVEMENT.
IN READING IN MATH AND SCIENCE.
THESE STUDENTS HAVE INTEGRATED
LEARNING APART APPROACH.
THEY'RE LEXILE LEVEL IS HIGHER.
THEY READ AT THE COLLEGE LEVEL.
WHEN THEY READ AN AUTOMOTIVE
MANUAL IT'S COLLEGE IN BUSINESS
LEVEL.
THE STUDENTS LEARN SCIENCE IN
DENTAL.
THEY LEARN THE MATH IN
CONSTRUCTION THEY LEARN SCIENCE
IN VETERINARIAN.
THEY LEARNED TO READ BETTER AN
AUTOMOTIVE.
NINETY THREE PERCENT OF THE CTU
STUDENTS GRADUATE.
COMPARED TO EIGHTY PERCENT OF
NON SAFETY STUDENTS.
I'M GONNA ALSO TELL YOU TO
PLEASE TAKE A LOOK AT OUR CENTER
DATA AND THE DATA FOR THE
CALIFORNIA TO ANSWER SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS THAT WERE ASKED
EARLIER.
CTT PROGRAMS REDUCE THE DROP OUT
RATE. THEY INCREASED THE
GRADUATION RATE.
SEE TO YOU STUDENTS ARE OUR
FIREFIGHTERS THEY SAVED NAPA.
SEAT TO SEE DO YOU STUDENTS
ARE YOUR DENTIST THAT TAKE CARE
OF YOUR TEETH.
SEE DO YOU STUDENTS ARE YOUR
MEDICAL ASSISTANCE THAT TAKE
CARE OF YOU.
SO YOU DO YOU STUDENTS HAVE BEEN
YOUR TEACHERS.
SAY TO YOU STUDENTS ARE YOUR
VETERINARIAN SET CARE FOR YOUR
PETS.
THEIR PHARMACIST PREPARING YOUR
MEDICATION.
AN AUTO MECHANICS THAT TAKE CARE
OF YOUR BREAKS THAT CAN TAKE
YOUR LIFE. IF.
NOT DONE CORRECTLY.
WITHOUT SUSTAIN DEDICATED CTE
FUNDING CT PROGRAMS AND
SUCCESSFUL CENTER BASED
PROGRAMS.
ARE AT RISK.
AS THE LOCAL COST PRESSURES ON
THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE
INCREASED IN THE PRIORITIES
THREATEN THE VIABILITY OF THESE
PROGRAMS WHICH IS WHY CD
OR I'M SORRY Y. CALIFORNIA IS
STRUGGLING TO FIND.
TALENT TO FILL THEIR JOBS.
IN CLOSING I WAS OCCURRED TECH
KIT.
IN COLLEGE.
AND I'VE BEEN IN PUBLIC
EDUCATION FOR TWENTY FIVE YEARS
AS A TEACHER.
MY FIRST YEAR I WAS ASKED WALK
TO THE FAX MACHINE.
TO FAX MY LETTER OF SUPPORT FOR
DEDICATED PERMANENT ONGOING
FUNDING FOR.
KURT TECHNICAL EDUCATION.
I WOULD LIKE THIS TO BE THE LAST
TIME THAT WE HAVE TO ADVOCATE
FOR PROTECT FUNDING.
PLEASE GIVE.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA BIG GIFT
OF AB SEVENTEEN.
FORTY THREE AND MAKE IT A
DEDICATED ONGOING FUNDING STREAM
FOR OUR STUDENTS AND OUR
ECONOMY.
CALIFORNIA IS FORTY FIRST AND
FUNDING FOR PUPILS
WE CAN DO BETTER AND WE MUST.
WE CANNOT AFFORD NOT TO DO THIS.
THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF DONALD FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
HER STUDENTS GO TO COLLEGE
BECAUSE OF CREW TECHNICAL
EDUCATION.
I NEED EVERYBODY TO STOP SAYING
IT'S FOR THOSE OTHER KIDS
IT'S OR SOMEBODY ELSE'S CHILD I
WAS.
ONE OF THOSE KIDS.
FINALLY.
I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE MICHELLE
AMERICAN AUDIENCE IN THE FIRST
ROW.
SHE WAS ONE A MY STUDENTS TWENTY
FIVE YEARS AGO.
IT'S BEEN A LONG JOURNEY.
AND I'M GOING TO SAY NUMBER
GRANTS NUMBER MATCHING I DON'T
HAVE THE STAFF AND I PLAY DON'T
HAVE THE WHEREWITHAL TO DO THIS
FOR MANY MORE YEARS. UNLESS YOU
GIVE US FUNDING AND INCLUDES
CENTERS.
CENTERS WERE IF THE STUDENTS
THAT NEED THE IN DEPTH LOOK AT A
CAREER THANK YOU GET TO WORK
RIGHT AWAY AND CONTINUE COLLEGE.
SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME I'M
GONNA TURN IT OVER TO GRANT.
OUR TESTIMONY OP.
BEFORE WE GO TO GRANT DO WE HAVE
ANY MEMBERS THAT WANT TO.
SPEAK TO OUR SUPERINTENDENT.
I JUST WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE YOUR
VERY.
SINCERE TESTIMONY I THINK
THERE'S MANY IN THE AUDIENCE I
MYSELF OF ANNA EDUCATOR FOR
THIRTY YEARS AND I THINK THAT
YOU STATE. WHAT MANY OF US FEEL
THERE'S ALWAYS I THINK? IN
EDUCATION THERE'S BEEN SOME
HIERARCHY ON AND I KNOW EVEN AT
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE SOMETIMES
THOSE THAT ARE TEACHING. AYE IN
THE C. T. E. THEY'RE NOT EVEN
INCLUDED UP WITH THE REGULAR
STAFF PROFESSORS AND SO FORTH
ARE CONSIDERED A SOMETIMES OF
THE OFFSITE DE THEY DON'T MANY
TIMES EVEN HAVE THEM ON IN THE
SAME CAMPUS THERE THERE THEY
HAVE AN OFFICE SOMEWHERE ELSE
SO.
AS I STATED I AM VERY AWARE OF
THE GRANT. AND WRITING AND HOW
INTENSIVE THAT CAN BE AND HOW
MANY NEED. OF GRANT WRITING. HOW
MUCH TIME IT TAKES
REALLY AWAY FROM THE STUDENTS
YOU'RE TRYING TO SERVE AND IT
REALLY IS A FULL TIME JOB SO
THANK YOU? OUT WILL GO AHEAD AND
WITH GRANT.
GOOD AFTERNOON
BLAMES GRADUATED I'M NINETEEN
YEARS OLD AND I TOOK TWO CLASSES
THAT.
S. B. C. T. OUR LOCAL SEATS YOU
CAP IS JUNIOR AND SENIOR HIGH
SCHOOL.
AND LET ME START OFF BY SAYING.
AND I'M.
WILL BE VERY VERY.
STRAIGHT FOR WITH YOU I WOULD
NOT BE IN COLLEGE IF I DID NOT
HAVE C. T. IN HIGH SCHOOL.
THOUGHT INTO WHAT I WANTED TO
DO BEFORE I STARTED GOING TO S.
B. C. T. I HAD.
NO PASSION FOR MATH OR ENGLISH.
OR TO SET A DESK I LIKE TO MOVE
AROUND WORK WITH PEOPLE. AND.
IT REALLY GAVE ME A PLATFORM TO
BUILD MYSELF AS A PERSON.
I DEFINITELY HAVE THE COURAGE TO
BE SITTING IN FRONT IN SITTING
IN FRONT OF ALL OF YOU ARE
TALKING RIGHT NOW.
IF IT WASN'T FOR CT BECAUSE IT
TAUGHT ME HOW TO HAVE BETTER
COMMUNICATION SKILLS AND HOW TO
WORK WITH PEOPLE. AND OF MY
COMMUNICATION SKILLS DEFINITELY
IMPROVED BECAUSE OF IT. AND MY
A.
IN MY.
JOB AND IN MY LIFE.
A CURLY WORKING AS IT.
MEDICAL ASSISTANT AN URGENT CARE
CLINIC.
AND ALSO I'M GOING TO COLLEGE
OUT TO BECOME AN EMT. WHICH
GIVES ME THE PLATFORM TO GO TO
SCHOOL TO BE A PARAMEDIC.
I WANNA HAVE THE TENACITY
TOWARDS EDUCATION AS COLLEGE
STUDENT. IF I.
GONNA HAVE A GOAL.
AND MY.
CAREER LIFE.
HE WOULD SAY.
MICHAEL IS TO BE A PART OF FIVE
FIVE PARAMEDIC AND ALSO I WOULD
LIKE TO BE A REGISTERED NURSE.
SO WITHOUT.
THE ABILITY TO HAVE THE HIGHER
LEVEL EDUCATION THAT CT GAVE ME
AND MAKE A HIGHER WAGE. OF I
WANT TO BE ABLE TO AFFORD TO PAY
FOR MY COLLEGE CLASSES.
AND I DIDN'T WANNA HAVE PROBABLY
WANTED TO GO TO COLLEGE TO BEGIN
WITH.
UNLESS I HAD A REASON TO AND I
FEEL I HAVE A PASSION AND A
REASON TO GO TO SCHOOL NOW.
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO ME TO
TRY TO SPEAK. NOT FOR MYSELF BUT
FOR THE STUDENTS OF THE STATE.
THOUGH INCOME.
LOWER CLASS MIDDLE CLASS HIGH
CLASS DOES IT REALLY MATTER
WHERE YOU'RE FROM. I'M A FROM A
SINGLE PARENT SINGLE INCOME
HOUSEHOLD SO.
I GUESS I SPEAK FOR MORE OF THE
MIDDLE CLASS BUT I THINK IT'S
IMPERATIVE TO EVERYBODY'S
EDUCATION JOB OPPORTUNITY TO.
TRY THINGS BECAUSE IF I DID HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TRY NEW
THINGS I WANT TO BE SITTING HERE
TALKING TO YOU TODAY.
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH GRANT.
CAN I ASK YOU A QUESTION THOUGH.
YOUR GREAT JOB WHAT WERE THE TWO
CLASSES THAT YOU TOOK AT THE
CENTER AND HOW DID YOU LEARN
ABOUT THE CENTER.
I LEARNED ABOUT THE CENTER
BECAUSE I DIDN'T KNOW THAT THERE
EVEN WAS I WOULD I GUESS YOU'D
SAY LOCATIONAL EDUCATION OUR.
TRUE TECHNOLOGY CATION UNTIL I
WAS IN HIGH SCHOOL.
I WAS NOT A STRAIGHT A STUDENT
I WAS MORE OF LIKE A. HIGH BE
ART LOW BE HIGH SEE STUDENTS SO
I WASN'T THAT KID WHO IS GONNA
GO STRAIGHT TO A FOUR YEAR. OR
GONNA GO STRAIGHT TO TO YOU OUR
NEW EXACTLY WHAT THEY WANTED TO
MAJOR IN.
ICE DON'T NECESSARILY HAVE A
DECLARED MAJOR I'M LEANING MORE
TOWARDS NURSING BUT I HEARD
ABOUT IT THROUGH.
WHAT OF MOUTH THROUGHOUT OLDER
STUDENTS?
I WAS.
.
VERY SOCIAL AROUND THE SCHOOL
AND I GOT TO KNOW A LOT OF THE
OLDER STUDENTS AND THEY WERE
TAKING WELDING THEY WERE TAKING.
MACHINE THEY'RE TAKING AN
AUTOMOTIVE THEY WERE TAKING HOLE
WRENCH CLASSES ACTUALLY NO
STUDENT WHO'S CURRENTLY
ATTENDING SEAT AS WE SEE T. HE
TOOK DIESEL MECHANICS AND NOW
HE'S BACK FOR WELDING. MOVED OUT
OF STATE CAME BACK YOU WANT CITY
WELDING AND OF SOMEONE WHO'S IN
A WELDING INDUSTRY BECAUSE HE
TOOK WELDING AT AS VCT. I KNOW
STUDENT FROM S. B. C. T. WHO IS
NOW IN THE ARMY AND HE'S GOING
TO JOIN NOT FORCE HIM WHEN HE
GETS OUT ANOTHER STUDENT WHO
TOOK FIRE SCIENCE AND IS NOW LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
SO.
I STARTED IN THE FIRE SCIENCE
COURSE BECAUSE I REALLY.
THOUGHT THAT I WANTED TO JOIN
THE FIRE DEPARTMENT BECAUSE I'M
VERY PASSIONATE ABOUT HELPING
AND SERVING PEOPLE. BUT ALSO.
.
REALLY LIKE THE HIGH STANDARDS
THAT THEY SET. AND
ONCE I WAS DONE WITH THAT I WAS
NOT ELIGIBLE TO TAKE EMT BECAUSE
YOU HAVE TO BE EIGHTEEN YEARS
OLD IN THE STATE CALIFORNIA TO
DO THAT. SO I ASKED MY STRUCTURE
OF WHAT SHOULD I DO NOW.
HE SAID YOU SHOULD GO ACROSS THE
HALL IT TAKE MEDICAL ASSISTING
AND OTHER EXPANDER KNOWLEDGE IN
THE MEDICAL WORLD. AND I CAN SAY
THAT.
IT STRONGLY HELP ME UNDERSTAND
MERGED IN MEDICINE BETTER BY
TAKING THAT SECOND COURSE.
IT HELPED ME LEARN A LOT AND I
KNOW THAT FOR A FACT IT'S GIVE
ME AN ADVANTAGE OVER OTHER
STUDENTS.
BECAUSE.
IF YOU LOOK IN MY RESUME HAVE
DONE SO MANY THINGS THAT I WOULD
HAVE NEVER DONE WITHOUT THIS
PROGRAM SO.
I TOOK FIRE SITE TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
AND I TOOK.
OUR MEDICAL SYSTEM TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN THOUSAND SIXTEEN.
WELL WE'RE VERY PROUD OF YOU AND
I KNOW THAT.
YOUR SUPERINTENDENT IS AND AND
I SAY I THINK YOUR TESTIMONY
REALLY.
EXPRESSES WHAT.
I MANY OF US.
.
FEEL THAT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE WITH PUBLIC
EDUCATION THAT.
NOT THAT WE TRACK STUDENTS
BUT THAT WE HAVE OF CHOICES FOR
STUDENTS
SO CONGRATULATIONS YOU'VE DONE A
GREAT JOB.
ANYBODY ELSE WANT TO SAY
ANYTHING TO GRANT.
OKAY SO THEY WILL GO THROUGH TO
THE NEXT SPEAKER AND I KNOW YOUR
TIME IS SHORT SO I'LL BE QUICK
BUT.
BUT THE PASSION THAT YOU JUST
HEARD FROM OUR SUPERINTENDENT
AND OUR STUDENTS AND. AND GRANT
IS SO IMPRESSIVE.
.
AT NOTICE HOW THEY'RE SPEAKING
FROM THE HEART.
AND I THINK THAT'S REALLY
SIGNIFICANT.
WE ARE A JP A.
WE HAVE SIX SCHOOL DISTRICTS
I'M SANTA CLARA UNIFIED TO
THAT'S DISTRICT THAT I REPRESENT
ON OUR METRIC CAMPUS. AND AWE I
HAD TREMENDOUS PASSION FOR ALL
WE TO YOUR I'VE BEEN A SCHOOL
BOARD MEMBER FOR MANY YEARS.
TIME AND THAT I YOU KNOW IN
EDUCATION AND K. THROUGH TWELVE
DISTRICT.
IT CAN TAKE YEARS TO SEE THE
FRUITS HERE LAYERS WHATEVER
MIGHT BE A BOND BUILDING NEW
SCHOOLS NEW PROGRAMS.
AND CT WHICH IS SYMMETRIC CAMPUS
WE HAVE STUDENTS MANY STUDENTS
JUST LIKE GRANT THAT EVERY ONE
OF OUR MEETINGS WHO COME OUT AND
SPEAK WITH PASSION.
AND WHEN YOU SEE HOW THEY FIND
THAT NICHE WHEN USED THEY FIND
THAT TRACK.
AND I WANTED TO SPEAK TO
SOMETHING THAT WAS SAID EARLIER
LIKE THERE'S THESE TWO TRACKS
COLLEGE AND CAREER NO THERE'S
NOT AYE I I HAVE TO SAY THIS
NINETEEN SEVENTIES EIGHTIES
THINKING. THAT'S NOT TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY THINKING WHERE IN
THE SILICON VALLEY WE SEE
STUDENTS LIKE GRANT WHO CUTS ARE
CAMPUS FINE IN H. FIND A
PASSION.
MAKE A FANTASTIC INCOME AND THEN
GO ON THE COLLEGE AND CONTINUE
AND FOR THOSE STUDENTS WHO ARE
FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO BE FROM
AFFLUENT FAMILY. WERE RESOURCES
ON AN ISSUE AND SILICON VALLEY
WE HAVE A LOT OF THOSE STUDENTS
AT HOME WITH MOM AND DAD WITH
SHANINA DEGREES ARE NOT GETTING
TRACTION BECAUSE IT'S VERY
EXPENSIVE TO LIVE IN SILICON
VALLEY.
OUR STUDENTS ARE VERY MOTIVATED
THEY COME AND THEY FIND THEIR
NICHE THEY THEY ARE SUCCESSFUL
THEY MAKE SIGNIFICANT INCOMES IN
SOME CASES A STAND ACCURATE
TRACK. AND SOME CASES AGO ON THE
COLLEGE INFO IN GOING TO NEW
CHAPTERS IN THEIR LIFE. SOME
START THEIR OWN BUSINESSES WE
HAVE A FORMER STUDENT WHO IS NOW
GETTING RECOGNITION IN THE FILM
INDUSTRY HE WHAT THROUGH OUR
CAMPUS AND HE STARTED AN
INCREDIBLY SUCCESSFUL COMPANY.
WE HAVE.
GOSH THERE'S JUST SO MANY
EXAMPLES WE COULD FILL THIS
CHAMBER WAS STUDENTS I FIGURE
ONCE YOU KNOW WE HAVE WHO. SHE
NOW WORKS AT TASKS LA AND IN
FREMONT IN THE SILICON VALLEY
AND SHE'S ON THE ASSEMBLY LINE
AND SHE'S VERY PROUD OF ALL THE
TECHNOLOGY INVOLVED IN
INSTALLING THE REAR HATCH ON
TESLA SO DANCE.
THIS IS A NEW TIME THIS IS A NEW
AGE THIS IS A TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY WE JUST CELEBRATED OUR
CENTENNIAL LAST YEAR.
SAN JOSE IS HAS HE T. E. SINCE
NINETEEN SEVENTEEN AND I'M
TELLING YOU RIGHT NOW FROM THE
HEART AS A GOVERNING BOARD
MEMBER OF THE K. THROUGH TWELVE
DISTRICT AND AS A REPRESENTATIVE
ON THIS JPA MATCHER AT BOARD.
IF WE DON'T RESTORED DIRECT
FUNDING WE WON'T BE AROUND
ANOTHER HUNDRED YEARS I PROMISE
YOU THAT WE NEED TO AND THAT'S
RIGHT THAT'S A MATTER ARE
RESTORATION
WE LOST A DIRECT FUNDING FOR
YEARS AGO. IT NEEDS TO BE
RESTORED LAST POINT WE SUE
SOMEBODY LIKE GRANT AND HIS
SUCCESS IN HIS LIFE.
WHATEVER DOLLARS GO INTO THIS I
ASSURE YOU MANY MANY MANY TIMES
TO THE THOSE DOLLARS COME BACK
AND THE IN THE INCOME THAT HE
MAKES IN THE TAXES THAT HE PAYS.
THE BUSINESSES HE MAY START THE
PEOPLE HE MAY HIGHER I DON'T
CARE IF SOMEONE MENTIONED
EARLIER TODAY I DON'T HE MAY BE
GONE NOW BUT HE TALKED ABOUT
THIS IS NOT A PARTISAN ISSUE
THIS IS NOT A PARTISAN ISSUE.
OUR LOYALTY HERE IS THE STUDENTS
OF CALIFORNIA R. LOYALTY IS TO
OUR STATE AND THE SUCCESS OF OUR
PEOPLE AND OUR KIDS.
I'M PASSIONATE.
EVERYONE HEARS PASSIONATE AND WE
NEED TO RESTORE DIRECT AND
ONGOING FUNDING NOTHING LESS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA.
THANK YOU CHAIR A I'D IS ONE OF
FOR SMALL.
GRANT THANK YOU SO MUCH I DO YOU
ARTICULATE THE IMPORTANCE OF CT
IN A WAY. THAT FEW CAN I'M INTO
AS A STUDENT HAS ACTUALLY
EXPERIENCED AND SO A YEAR
PHENOMENAL JOB AND I THINK ALL
THREE OF YOU FOR BEING HERE IN
PARTICULAR.
THAT OUR SUPERINTENDENT I THINK
THAT THAT A MOTION.
REALLY SPEAKS I BELIEVE
TWO OF THE PASSION THAT SO MANY
DO YOU HAVE FOR THE STUDENTS.
THAT ARE GOING TO OUR CITY
PROGRAMS THAT IS ONE OF. AYE
AYES WANNA MAKE COMMENTS TO. YOU
KNOW BACKING UP BOTH BUT THE
SUPERINTENDENT AS WELL AS OUR
BOARD MEMBER HERE MISTER CANOVA
INDICATED. BECAUSE.
I THINK THAT IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
CT IS AS RELEVANT TODAY AS
PROBABLY IT'S EVER BEEN.
BECAUSE OF THE CHANGING NATURE
OF OUR WORK FORCE IN OUR
ECONOMY.
AND I DON'T BELIEVE IT'S AN
EITHER OR BETWEEN CAREER IN
COLLEGE I THINK IT'S ACTUALLY
THE EXACT SAME THING.
OF AND WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT MATH
SCIENCE AND READING. THOSE THAT
ARE GOING TO SEE T. E. WHILE
THEY'RE IN HIGH SCHOOL WHEN
THEY.
ARE GRADUALLY MY HIGH SCHOOL THE
WAY THAT THEY'RE LEARNING THEIR
MATH SCIENCE AND READING THAT
THEY'RE MORE PREPARED AND THE
WORKFORCE THAN THOSE ARE. THAT
ARE FOCUS ONLY ON TRYING INTO
COLLEGE.
AND WE KNOW HOW VALUABLE THAT IS
BECAUSE AS WAS INDICATED. IT IS
SAN JOSE SOUNDS A MEASURE OF HIS
MOST EXPENSIVE PLACE IN THE
COUNTRY.
WHEN IT COMES TO RATS WHEN IT
COMES TO REAL ESTATE.
AND IT'S AN INCREDIBLY
COMPETITIVE WORK WORLD WORK
MARKER ECONOMIC I'M A JOB
MARKET.
AND SO IT'S I THINK.
IT'S REALLY NOT REALISTIC IN NOR
IS IT COMPASSIONATE OR SMART FOR
US.
CCTV IS IN SOME WAY COMPETING
WITH ANY KIND OF EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAM A PRANK POST COLLEGE
BECAUSE THE REALITY IS THAT.
PEOPLE NEED TO GO TO WORK.
PAIN TO BUILD A FOUR TO LIVE IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND THAT DOESN'T MEAN THAT
COLLEGE IS NOT IN THEIR FUTURE
AND YOU KNOW IN SOME CASES IT
WON'T BE BECAUSE THEY'RE GOING
TO HAVE A GREAT JOB STRAIGHT OUT
OF. HIGH SCHOOL THAT WILL BECOME
THEIR CAREER
BUT THEY HAVE AND AND AND I
APPRECIATE OF. DECEMBER QUIRK
SILVA SINGS CHOICES BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT IT'S ABOUT WE WANT
TO GIVE ALL OF US USE THE
CHOICES. THAT ATTRACT THEM
AND WE HEARD IT FROM A GRANT
THAT CT  IS WHAT LED HIM TO
HIS PASSION.
AND FOR SOMEONE ELSE MAYBE IT
WILL BE SOMETHING DOZEN AG FROM
COLLEGE TRACK THAT'S. FINE
BUT I THINK THAT WE NEED TO STOP
THINKING ABOUT.
CT AS A SUBSTITUTE BUT TO BASIC
EDUCATION. OTHER REALITY IS THAT
SEEKS YOU SHOULD NEVER BE
CONSIDERED A SUBSIDIARY. TYPE OF
EDUCATION IT YOU'RE REALLY A
NEEDS TO BE CONSIDERED AS AN
EQUAL OTHER TO TO GOING TO
COLLEGE.
BECAUSE AND MAY END UP ON THAT
PATH AND MAY NOT WITH THE KIND
OF QUALITY EDUCATE AND I'VE BEEN
IN THE METRO ED. BECAUSE WE TALK
ABOUT SORT BY CITY I WENT EASE I
UNION HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICT LOCAL
HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATE WHICH IS
PART OF THAT THE JPA.
AND NATURAL ED IS A FIVE MINUTE
DRIVE MY HOME I'VE BEEN THERE
MANY TIMES AND. I WOULD JUST
ENCOURAGE YOU KNOW MANY THE
MEMBERS ARE HERE NOW WE HAVE THE
OBVIOUS HAVE ALLOWED FOR
MEETINGS OF COMMITTEES TO GO TO.
BUT I WOULD ENCOURAGE THEM IF
THEY HAVEN'T VISITED.
A A CT ESPECIALLY ARE A RESULT
OF CENTER TO COME TO SETTLE THE
INCOME TO METRO EDITOR GO TO ONE
THAT'S NEAR THEM. IF THEY
HAVEN'T BEEN TO ONE THEY DON'T
THEY THEY WILL NOT UNDERSTAND
THE VALUE OF THE KIND OF
TRAINING THAT HAPPENS ON THESE
CAMPUSES I'VE SEEN IT ALL FROM
THE FIRE NURSES ASSISTANT STEP.
TO BUILDING TRADES TYPE WORK AYE
TO SOLAR PANEL INSTALLATION AND
ON AND ON AND ON AND THEY'RE
LEARNING THE BASIC SKILLS. THAT
OTHER STUDENTS ARE LEARNING IN A
HANDS ON MANNER UNLIKE ANYWHERE
ELSE SO.
I'M I'M FULLY SUPPORTIVE RCTS I
AND I AGREE THAT WE MUST DO
WHATEVER WE CAN TO GET TO A
PLACE OF PERMANENT FUNDING. AND
UP BECAUSE TO HAVE TO KEEP ON
FIGHTING I MEAN IT'S SO HARD AS
WE ALL KNOW DICK TO KEEP THE
ADMINISTRATION RUNNING WHEN YOU
DON'T KNOW WHAT YOUR NEXT YEAR'S
BUDGET GOING TO BE. OR EVEN YOUR
FIVE YEAR OUT. WHEN YOU'RE
TRYING TO PREPARE IN THIS CASE
IN UP FIFTEEN HUNDRED HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS GOING THROUGH
SILICON VALLEY ICICI .
THAT'S LARGER THAN MOST HIGH
SCHOOLS AND IN THE STATE AND SO.
BUT MUCH MORE COMPLICATED
BECAUSE YOU HAVE FOLKS COMING
FROM SO MANY DIFFERENT SCHOOLS
SO ANYWAY I'M A BIG FAN OF HIS
BLOOD TO SPECIFICALLY A METRO EN
THE SLOCUM AYE. CG PROGRAM BUT A
CITIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND
AND I'M VERY HAPPY WITH HAVING
THIS CONVERSATION BECAUSE WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE. THAT AS WE
LOOK AT WHETHER IT'S RETOOLING
THE PROCESS IN WHICH MONEY COMES
DOWN FOR THE AMOUNT OF FUNDING
THAT WERE DOING IT WITH OUR EYES
WIDE OPEN AND WE'RE DOING IT.
LISTENING TO THOSE ARE ACTUALLY
THE PRACTITIONERS THAT ARE
SERVING OUR STUDENTS EVERY
SINGLE DAY SO THAT WE'RE NOT
MAKING THINGS MORE COMPLICATED
UNNECESSARILY BUT WERE ACTUALLY
GETTING THE MONEY. A AND THE
RESOURCES AND THE. TO THOSE
GRANT
GREAT JOB AYE I WOULD DEFINITELY
SAY TO THOSE WHO ARE LISTENING
TO GO OUT AND VISIT SOME OF THE
C. T. E. PROGRAMS AS I STARTED
ARE MY COMMENTS WHEN WE WERE OUT
IN BUENA PARK.
AND OF COURSE THE STUDENTS AND
THE TEACHERS KNEW WERE COMING
SO.
BUT THEY WERE NOT PROMPTED TO
TELL US THE THINGS THAT THEY
WOULD JUST QUIETLY TALUS IN SO
MANY OF THEM TO.
TOLD US THEY WOULD NOT BE COMING
TO SCHOOL HAD THEY NOT BEEN AND
SOME OF THE PROGRAMS BUT ONE
PARTICULAR IS AND AGAIN.
WHAT A PARK WHICH SOME PEOPLE
WITH AND WHY DO YOU NEED AN
AGRICULTURE PROGRAM AND? WARRANT
NORTH ORANGE COUNTY BUT.
YOU KNOW MANY WAYS ISN'T THAT
OUTDATED BUT THEY TO THEY SHOWED
US AND TOLD US ABOUT NOT ONLY
WHAT THEY'RE GROWING BUT OF
COURSE GOING TO THE COUNTY FARM.
BUT THAT THEY'RE SELLING
LITERALLY RIGHT NOW YOU CAN GO
ON TO THEIR WEBSITE AND THEY ARE
SELLING ON NOT ONLY EGGS THAT
YOU CAN BUY A. EVERYDAY BUT
THEY'RE DOING FLORAL
ARRANGEMENTS THAT YOU CAN
PURCHASE FOR EVENTS ALL OF THESE
THINGS.
THAT ARE A PART OF OUR ECONOMY
AND WHAT BETTER WAY AS WE SAY TO
LEARN THAN THEM ACTUALLY
BECOMING THESE YOUNG
ENTREPRENEURS SO.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU.
WE CAN START WITH FROM THE REST.
ALRIGHT WE'RE GONNA BRING UP OUR
NEXT PANEL AND OUR NEXT PANEL IS
FROM.
FRESNO UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
AND WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME.
KIRSTEN BOROWSKI WHO'S THE
DIRECTOR OF.
CAREER READY NESS.
NICK FELONS AWAY LOVE WAS A
TEACHER AT SUNNYSIDE HIGH
SCHOOL.
AND HAZEL AYE CHA WHO IS A
STUDENT AS ROOM AT ROOSEVELT
HIGH SCHOOL. AND.
WE WILL GO HEAD START AS THEY
KNOW THAT WE ARE BEHIND ON TIME.
HELLO MY NAME IS CHRIS AMBER
ASKING I'M DIRECTOR OF CAREER
READINESS IN THE DIVISION AND
DEPARTMENT OF COLLEGE AND CAREER
READINESS AND FRESNO UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT.
WITH ME TODAY.
IS NICK VALENZUELA A HEALTH
PATHWAY TEACHER AT SUNNYSIDE
HIGH SCHOOL. AND HAZEL CHAU
WHICH IS ONE OF OUR HEALTH
STUDENTS ALSO A CNA STUDENTS.
AT ROOSEVELT HIGH SCHOOL AND
TOOK IN HIGH SCHOOL ALSO HONOR
TEAM IS ALSO BACK BEHIND US IS
DINA SCHEMBRI. WHO'S OUR PUBLIC
COORDINATOR AT ROOSEVELT HIGH
SCHOOL.
THANK YOU FOR GIVING US THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO TALK ABOUT THE
WORK OF CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION AND CAREER AND COLLEGE
READINESS.
IN OUR ORGANIZATION.
FRESNO UNIFIED SERVES MORE THAN
SEVENTY FOUR THOUSAND STUDENTS
FROM PRESCHOOL THROUGH GRADE
TWELVE.
IT IS PREPARING CAREER READY
GRADUATES THROUGH HIGH QUALITY
INSTRUCTION.
DISTRICT PROGRAMS AND SERVICES
AND RESOURCES.
WE SIXTY SIX ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS
FIFTEEN MIDDLE SCHOOLS NINE HIGH
SCHOOLS FOR ALTERED SCHOOLS
THREE SPECIAL EDUCATION SCHOOLS
AND CHARTER SCHOOLS.
WE ALSO HAVE AN ADULT SCHOOL THE
FIRST MORE THAN TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND ADULTS IN OUR
COMMUNITY.
WITH ACADEMIC AND CAREER
PREPARATION PROGRAMS.
OR BOARD DEVELOPED AN OVER
ARCHING MISSION.
AND THE LINE DISTRICT GOALS THAT
TO TEASE SICKLY GUIDE OUR WORK
THE MISSION IN OUR DISTRICT
GOALS CONDUCT EXTREMELY WELL TO
THE REAL WORLD.
OUR MISSION AS A DISTRICTS IS
PREPARING CAREER READY
GRADUATES.
THE GOAL THAT SUPPORT THE
MISSION.
ARE THAT ALL STUDENTS WILL EXCEL
IN READING WRITING AND MATH.
ALL STUDENTS WILL ENGAGE IN
ARTISTIC ACTIVITIES AT
ATHLETICS.
ALL STUDENTS WILL DEMONSTRATE
THE CHARACTER AND COMPETENCIES
FOR WORKPLACE EXPRESSED.
BUT ALL STUDENTS WILL STAY IN
SCHOOL ON TARGET TO GRADUATE.
THE REALLY IMPORTANT THING TO
KNOW. IS THAT IS NOT ENOUGH.
WE ARE NOT IMPACTING ENOUGH
KIDS.
WE KNOW WHAT THE RESEARCH
INDICATES THAT WE HAVE SEEN WHAT
IT SUGGESTS FIRST HAND IN OUR
OWN SCHOOLS.
KIDS WHO HAVE EXPOSURE TO
APPLIED LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES.
KIDS WHO UNDERSTAND THE
RELEVANCE OF WHAT THEY ARE
LEARNING.
THE KIDS TO LEARN ABOUT
POTENTIAL CAREER OPTIONS.
THOSE ARE THE KIDS WHO BECOME
TRULY ENGAGED IN SCHOOL.
THEY'RE THE ONES THAT STAY IN
SCHOOL AND GRADUATE.
AND THEY ARE THE ONES WHO WORK
SUCCESSFUL IN THE REAL WORLD.
THE LEADERSHIP OF FRESNO UNIFIED
OR BOARD IN OUR SUPERINTENDENT
UNDERSTAND TO A LARGE DEGREE.
THE PROSPERITY OF OUR COMMUNITY
REST IN THE ABILITY OF FRESNO
UNIFIED THE LARGEST SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY.
TO GRADUATE STUDENTS WITH A
CHARACTER AND COMPETENCY FOR
WORKPLACE SUCCESS.
OUR BOARD ADOPTED A CAREER READY
DEFINITION.
THAT ALL STUDENTS WILL HAVE
POSSIBLE OPTIONS AVAILABLE TO
THEM UPON GRADUATION FROM FRESNO
UNIFIED.
THIS STUDENT HOUSE A STRONG
ACADEMIC FOUNDATION. HAS
COMPLETED REQUIRED COURSES.
YEAH HOUSE ACQUIRED THE
WORKPLACE SKILLS AND
COMPETENCIES NECESSARY FOR
SUCCESS AFTER HIGH SCHOOL.
WE HAVE A GUIDING PRINCIPLE THAT
LEAVES OUR WORK.
SO HOW DO WE PREPARE COLLEGE AND
CAREER READY GRADUATES AND
FRESNO UNIFIED FOR THE WIDEST
ARRAY OF OPTIONS.
WE'VE ADOPTED A DIFFERENT
GRADUATE PROFILE FURTHER DETAIL
AND THE SKILLS AND COMPETENCIES
FOR WORKPLACE SUCCESS.
COLLABORATION TEAMWORK
COMMUNICATION
DIGITAL LITERACY.
WE HAVE A COLLEGE AND CAREER
CONTINUUM THE DETAILS GRADE
LEVEL WORK FOR ALL.
STUDENTS.
IN THE THIRD GRADE WE BRING
BUSINESSES TO EVERY THIRD GRADE
CLASSROOM.
EVERY CAMPUS TO EXPOSE STUDENTS
TO STEM CAREERS.
BY DOING HANDS ON ACTIVITIES
WITH THEM.
DURING OF ACTIVITY STUDENTS ASK
QUESTIONS ABOUT JOBS AND TOOLS.
AND SPEAKERS INTENTIONALLY TALK
ABOUT CAREER COMPETENCIES LIKE
TEAMWORK AND COLLABORATION.
IN THE FOURTH GRADE STUDENTS
LEAVE CAMPUS AND VISIT LOCAL
BUSINESSES TO SEE REAL PLACES OF
WORK.
WE WANT STUDENTS TO BEGIN TO SEE
THEMSELVES IN A WORK ENVIRONMENT
AND THINK ABOUT WHAT THEY LIKE.
HOW SCHOOLS CONDUCT TO WORKPLACE
EXPRESS?
AND SEE FIRST HAND SOME OF THE
SKILLS THEY WILL NEED TO BE
SUCCESSFUL AT WORK.
IN FIFTH GRADE WE HAVE PARTNERED
WITH FRESNO STATE AND DEVELOPED
A STEM BASED CURRICULUM A LINE
TO THE NEXT GENERATION FIVE
STANDARDS. THAT HIGHLIGHTS
CREATIVITY AND INNOVATION.
SENATE SIX GRADE STUDENTS VISIT
ONE OF OUR LOCAL COMMUNITY
COLLEGE.
SO THAT STUDENTS BETTER
UNDERSTAND THEIR OPTIONS AFTER
GRADUATION.
BUT THE MIDDLE SCHOOL LEVEL WE
FOCUS ON CAREER EXPLORATION AND
CONNECTING WITH COUNSELING.
WE WANT HELP STUDENTS THINK MORE
DELIBERATELY ABOUT CAREER
OPTIONS AND DEEPEN THEIR
KNOWLEDGE ABOUT CAREER CHOICES.
ADDITIONALLY WE PROVIDE COLLEGE
TOURS THAT INTENTIONALLY CONDUCT
THEIR CAREER INTERESTS.
WITH COLLEGE MAJORS.
IN TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN FIFTEEN
WE LOTS LIKE LEARNING PATHWAYS
ACROSS ALL OF OUR COMPREHENSIVE
HIGH SCHOOLS.
LINK LEARNING AS AN
INSTRUCTIONAL STRATEGY THAT A
COMPASSES FOR CORE PRINCIPLES.
COHORT SCHEDULING. RIGOROUS
ACADEMIC AND CT COURSEWORK.
AND STUDENT SUPPORT SO THAT BOTH
TEACHERS AND STUDENTS WITHIN THE
PATHWAY.
CREATE OPPORTUNITIES TO
COLLABORATE WITH IN A RIGOROUS
AND RELEVANT CAREER THEMES.
PATHWAYS INCORPORATE WORK BASED
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES TEACH
TECHNICAL AND TRANSFERABLE
SKILLS.
AND EMBEDDED INDUSTRY
CERTIFICATIONS
TO DATE WE HAVE TWENTY FIVE LIKE
LEARNING PATHWAYS. THAT ENGAGE
STUDENTS IN A WIDE VARIETY OF
CAREER THINGS FROM EGO
TECHNOLOGY.
TO EDUCATION TO ENGINEERING AND
CONSTRUCTION.
WE JUST BROKE GROUND ON A NEW
FACILITY.
ESTABLISHING A LARGE TRUCK
MAINTENANCE REPAIR TRAINING
FACILITY.
A FACILITY WE BELIEVE SUPPORTS
OUR LOCAL INDUSTRY.
AND THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
WE WORK WITH OUR INDUSTRY
PARTNERS INACTIVITY PREPARE
STUDENTS TO FILL HIGH DEMAND. OR
NEW AND EMERGING POSITIONS
WITHIN OUR LOCAL WORKFORCE.
WE CONTINUE TO PARTNER WITH OUR
LOCAL COMMUNITY COLLEGE IN
EXPAND TO A NON ROMAN OFFER TO
ME TO USE.
THIS SCHOOL YEAR WE HAVE OVER
FIVE HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE
STUDENTS EARNING COLLEGE CREDIT
WHILE THEY'RE IN HIGH SCHOOL.
DUAL ENROLLMENT ALLOW STUDENTS
TO EARN COLLEGE CREDITS WERE
GOING TO HIGH SCHOOL THEY ARE
TAKEN CLASSES ARE TAKEN RIGHT ON
THE STUDENTS HIGH SCHOOL CAMPUS.
WITH NO OUT OF POCKET EXPENSES.
FRESNO UNIFIED BELIEVE THAT
LEARNING IS A CONTINUING PROCESS
OF ENGAGING OUR STUDENTS.
PARENTS AND COMMUNITY MEMBERS
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR.
TO THIS END WE UTILIZE CAREER
INTEREST SOFTWARE IN OUR AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS.
AND ARE COMMITTED TO ENRICHMENT
OPPORTUNITIES IN THE SOME ALL
SUMMER.
FOR EXAMPLE OUR SPORTS SCIENCE
INSTITUTE IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
FRESNO STATE.
IS A WEEK LONG CAMP FOR HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS THAT FOCUSES ON
KINESIOLOGY AND SPORTS MEDICINE.
WE WROTE CAREER THEMES
CURRICULUM. AND OFFER A DAY IN
THE LIFE OF EXPERIENCES TO
TWENTY TWO OF OUR SUMMER SCHOOL
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL FOR.
FOCUSING ON HEALTH ENGINEERING
EDUCATION AND DESIGN THINKING.
OUR WORK IS FOCUSED ON PROVIDING
THE WIDEST ARRAY OF OPTIONS FOR
ALL STUDENTS.
OUR DATA DASHBOARD MONITORS
SPECIFIC WORKS SUCH AS THE
NUMBER OF CT A THROUGH G.
COURSES OFFERED IN THE DISTRICT.
EIGHTY FOUR PERCENT OF RCT
COURSES ARE A THROUGH G.
APPROVED.
AS CT OPPORTUNITIES HAVE
EXPANDED THE NUMBER OF STUDENTS
ON TRACK FOR A THIRD YEAR HE HAS
ALSO INCREASED.
AND IMPROVE DEEP A THROUGH G.
RATES RATES DIRECTLY CORRELATE
TO INCREASED
COLLEGE APPLICATIONS.
WE DILIGENTLY WORK TOGETHER.
TO CREATE COLLEGE AND CAREER
READY GRADUATES.
THE CHALLENGES PRESENTED IN THIS
WORK.
ARE MANY.
THEY INCLUDE FINDING HIGH
QUALITY CT TEACHERS.
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING TO UPGRADE
CURRENT TEACHER SKILLS AND
CONTINUING THEIR INDUSTRY
RELEVANCE.
FACILITIES AND ONGOING COST FOR
CT PROGRAMS AND FUNDING.
CATEGORICAL FUNDING THAT IS
OFTEN RESTRICTIVE TO ONLY MIDDLE
AND HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS.
WE HAVE BEEN RECIPIENTS OF
VARIOUS FUNDING.
FRESNO UNIFIED IS COMMITTED TO
DEVELOPING A STRONG CT PROGRAM
THAT PROVIDES THE WIDEST ARRAY
OF OPTIONS.
CT HE IS NOT JUST ABOUT HIGH
SCHOOL.
WE NEED TO PROVIDE CAREER CAREER
AWARENESS AND TECHNICAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR STUDENTS AT
EARLIER AGES.
WE KNOW THAT ALL STUDENTS NEED
EXPOSURE TO THE WORLD OF WORK.
WE NEED AGE APPROPRIATE CAREER
AWARENESS AND EXPLORATION FOR
ALL KIDS.
EVEN OUR ELEMENTARY STUDENTS.
WE KNOW THAT STUDENTS NEED TO
DEMONSTRATE WORKPLACE SKILLS AND
COMPETENCIES LIKE PROBLEM
SOLVING AND COMMUNICATION
SKILLS.
AND WE NEED TO DETERMINE THE
BEST WAY TO EMBED THAT SKILL
DEVELOPMENT WITHIN OUR
CURRICULUM.
WE NO THERE NEEDS TO BE A
COHERENT SYSTEM OF COURAGE
OCCASIONAL. ACROSS THE DISTRICT
SO THAT ALL STUDENTS AND PARENTS
UNDERSTAND ALL THEIR OPTIONS.
IT ARE SUPPORTED BY STAFF AS
THEY NAVIGATE THE SYSTEM.
WE KNOW THAT THE TWO U. COURSES.
AND PATHWAYS NEED TO BE
ACADEMICALLY RIGOROUS.
SO ALL OF OUR STUDENTS HAVE
OPPORTUNITIES TO GET GOOD JOBS
OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL.
AND GO TO COLLEGE.
TO HAVE THE CHOICE.
TO MAKE.
AND FINALLY MOST IMPORTANTLY WE
KNOW WE CAN'T DO THIS.
NOR SHOULD WE DO THIS ON OUR
OWN.
WE NEED TO REACH OUT TO
INDUSTRY.
TO LABOR.
TWO PARENTS.
TO THE FED EX LOST SECTOR TO
GOVERNMENT AND OUR HIGHER
EDUCATION PARTNERS.
WE NEED TO DEVELOP MEANINGFUL
PARTNERSHIPS.
WHERE WE ALL WORK TOGETHER?
TO HELP OUR KIDS.
STAY IN SCHOOL.
GET JOBS AND BE SUCCESS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF CT
PROGRAMS.
WELL GOOD AFTERNOON BUT WHAT
WHAT THE ONE ONE MOMENT THEN I'M
SMIS PRICE THAT ONE QUICK
QUESTIONS TO ASK.
.
BUT LED THE DISTRICT TO EXTEND
CITY PROGRAMS TO THE MID TO
MIDDLE SCHOOL. AND WE.
BECAUSE OF THAT WHAT WAS IMPACT
AT ALL ON THAT KIND OF THAT
INCREASE SORT. OF STUDENTS IN
HIGH SCHOOL GOING THROUGH GOING
TO THE CITY A PATHWAYS PROGRAM.
SO WE KNOW IN CALIFORNIA A THREE
G..
AROUND.
THE LEVEL OF COURSES THAT
STUDENTS NEED TO TAKE.
BECAUSE OF THAT RIGHT THERE ARE
MANY STUDENTS MANY STUDENTS IN
OUR DISTRICT TO IN MIDDLE SCHOOL
MAKE POOR CHOICES.
WE ARE TWELVE AND THIRTEEN YEAR
OLD STUDENTS.
WHO SOMETIMES DON'T MAKE THE
RIGHT CHOICE?
AND SO THAT IMPACTS.
THEIR OPTIONS IN HIGH SCHOOL.
AND SO TO UNDERSTAND. THAT
CHOICES THAT I MAKE IN UPPER
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL HOW WHY DO IN
MIDDLE SCHOOL REGARDLESS THERE
ARE NO CREDITS IN MIDDLE SCHOOL
KIDS MOVE FORWARD.
THAT IS NOT THE CASE ONCE I HIT
HIGH SCHOOL.
SO WAITED UNTIL THEY'RE IN HIGH
SCHOOL. IT'S TOO LATE.
BUT I THINK IT'S GREAT SO THAT
THAT THE IT'S A VERY GREAT
ASPECT BICU PROGRAM.
SO THANK YOU AND A MISTER
ABOUNDS WELL.
GOOD AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS NICK
VALENZUELA CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATOR. IN THE HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES PATHWAY AT
SUNNYSIDE HIGH SCHOOL FRESNO
CALIFORNIA.
BUT THANK YOU FOR PRIDE IT
PROVIDING ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK WITH YOU.
IN AUGUST OF TWO THOUSAND I
BEGAN WORKING IN EDUCATION AS AN
ATHLETIC TRAINER A BILL THAT
HIGH SCHOOL IN FRESNO.
DURING THE SEVEN YEARS AS I THAT
I WORK AS AN ATHLETIC TRAINER I
TAUGHT IN OUR O. P. SPORTS
MEDICINE PROGRAM. COURSE.
IT WAS THIS TEACHING EXPERIENCE
THAT PROMPTED ME TO PURSUE A
SINGLE SUBJECT TEACHER
CREDENTIAL IN PHYSICAL
EDUCATION.
MY MISSION WAS TO IMPART MY
KNOWLEDGE OF PHYSICAL EDUCATION
AND EDUCATION THROUGH THE FISCAL
TWO MY TO EACH MY STUDENTS.
IN THE SPRING OF TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN.
MY PRINCIPAL MISTER TEN MILES.
PROPOSED AT NEW OPPORTUNITIES
FOR ME IN THE AREA OF CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION.
I WAS VERY RELUCTANT FOR NUMBER
OF REASONS.
BUT THROUGH HIS BEST CELLS
EFFORTS.
I AGREE TO ACCEPT THIS NEW
TEACHING VENTURE.
I RECALL TELLING HIM THAT FIRST
OPPORTUNITY.
I WANT TO BE CONSIDERED FOR
PHYSICAL EDUCATION.
POSITION IN THE MEDIA FUTURE.
FAST FORWARD TO OCTOBER OF TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN ONLY SIX
MONTHS AFTER MY INITIAL
CONVERSATIONS WITH MISTER
LYLE'S.
I MADE AN UNANNOUNCED VISIT TO
HIS OFFICE PEEK MY HEAD IN THE
DOOR WHEN I TOLD HIM.
DISREGARD MY MY PREVIOUS REQUEST
FOR FUTURE FISCAL EDUCATION.
POSITION I WAS ENJOYING MY NEW
ROLE AS KRYCEK LATCH CATER.
AS A CAREER TECHNOLOGICAL LEADER
OF THE GREAT OPPORTUNITY.
TO WORK WITH STUDENTS TO HAVE AN
INTEREST IN THE HEALTHCARE
PROFESSION.
EACH OF US GETS TO EXPLORE MANY
CAREERS WITHIN THE INDUSTRY
SECTOR.
ONE OF THE PROJECT BASED
LEARNING EXPERIENCES THAT WE DO
IN THE FALL SEMESTER IS TO
CREATE A POST SECONDARY ROAD MAP
THAT LEADS TO A PROFESSIONAL
CAREER IN HEALTH CARE.
THROUGH THIS EXPERIENCE STUDENTS
GET EXPOSED TO THE MANY CAREER
OPPORTUNITIES THAT ARE AVAILABLE
AND THE WORK THAT IT WILL TAKE
TO GET THEM THERE.
THEY LEARN ABOUT AVAILABLE
DEGREE PROGRAMS.
COMPARE DEGREE TYPES.
COMPARE COLLEGE VERSES
UNIVERSITY INSTITUTIONS.
AND RESEARCH THE OUTLOOK OF
THEIR PROFESSION.
I GET TO TEACH STUDENTS SOFT
SKILLS SO THAT SO THAT THEY CAN
INCORPORATE THEM INTO THEIR
DAILY LIFE.
INCORPORATING TWENTY FIRST GETS
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY SKILLS AND
TO MY C. TO YOU COURSE HAS
HELPED THE STUDENTS UNDERSTAND
SOME OF THE SKILL REQUIREMENTS
AND TRAITS.
THAT EMPLOYERS ARE LOOKING FOR.
STUDENTS LEARN AND PRACTICE THE
SKILLS TO PROJECT BASED
LEARNING.
HOSTING GUEST SPEAKERS
ATTENDING FIELD TRIPS
AND HOSTING A HEALTH FAIR IN THE
SPRING.
WHICH BY THE WAY AYE FLYERS LEE
FOR YOU TO IT THAT MAKE A TRIP
TO FRESNO COME JOIN US.
THEY INDUSTRY EXPOSURE THAT CT
STUDENTS
RECEIVES IS UNPARALLELED.
IT'S VERY HEART WARMING WHEN
INDUSTRY PROFESSIONALS TAKE TIME
FROM THEIR EVERYDAY NORMAL WORK
TO REDIRECT AND REFOCUS.
TO WORK WITH STUDENTS.
INDUSTRY PROFESSIONALS ARE
UNDERSTANDING THE IMPORTANCE OF
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION.
AND HOW IT RELATES TO THEIR
INDUSTRY GROWTH.
LASTLY AS A CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATOR.
I TRY TO CREATE A CULTURE WITHIN
OUR LINK ONE PATHWAY THAT RAISES
THE AWARENESS.
A POSTSECONDARY OPPORTUNITIES.
AND RAISE THE BAR FOR STUDENTS
TO ASPIRE TOWARD WHEN THEY
CONSIDER THEIR FUTURE
PROFESSIONAL CAREER.
THANK YOU FOR PROVIDING ME THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE MY ROLE AND
EXPERIENCE AS A CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION.
THANK YOU MISTER BROWN'S WILLING
AND GIVEN THE FACT THAT YOU ARE
HESITANT.
AT FIRST I HEARD ABOUT OFFER THE
OPPORTUNITY AT ALL IT WHAT DO
YOU SEE ARE THE MAIN CHALLENGES
IN RECRUITING. CTE TEACHERS.
WELL.
FOR ME I WAS IN THE INDUSTRY AS
AN ATHLETIC TRAINER.
I HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO TEACH IN
ROP SPORTS MEDICINE PAPA COURSE.
SO I WAS KIND OR READY.
ON CAMPUS.
PULLING PEOPLE MAYBE FROM
INDUSTRY.
TO COME INTO AN AREA THAT.
THEY MADE AT NIGHT NOT EVEN EVER
CONSIDER.
WHEN THEY HEAR OF THE.
THE CHALLENGES AND OBSTACLES TO
BECOME.
CERTIFICATE A TEACHER.
.
AND THEN YOU LOOK AT THE
POTENTIAL SALARY DECREASE.
THOSE ARE.
THOSE ARE CERTAINLY BECAUSE
BECAUSE OF CONCERN OR OR AREAS
TO.
TO BE FOCUSED ON.
AND HOW CAN WE ENCOURAGE THEM
TO.
YEAH.
.
WELL WHAT WHAT WHAT WAS WITH YOU
LIKE FOR EXAMINERS BY WAVE
EXAMPLE THAT THAT'S A YOU KNOW
WHAT I'M GONNA STICK.
TO ITT  RATHER THAN GOING
TO BECOME.
P. TEACHER.
WELL SO I'M.
I THINK.
.
WORKING WITH A DIRECTOR OF WET
WITH TRISTAN AND AND AND
EVERYONE ELSE THAT'S IN OUR.
COLLEGE CAREER READINESS OF
DEPARTMENT OF FRED'S UNIFIED WE
ALL REALLY WORK TOGETHER TO
SUPPORT ONE ANOTHER.
WE UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE OF
THIS YA DOCTOR UGH DOCTOR WEBER
WHO IS HERE.
A GREAT GREAT TESTAMENT ABOUT
LINK LEARNING PROGRAMS.
WHICH WHICH WE IMPLEMENT FRESNO
UNIFIED SO.
.
THE JUICES BUT DRAKE AND THAT.
AS OUR STUDENTS ENJOY.
RIGHT WELL THANK YOU AND THEN.
HAZEL.
HI MY NAME IS HAZEL VIOLET CHAR
AND I AM A STUDENT AT ROOSEVELT
AND DUCK IN HIGH SCHOOL.
AND I JOIN DEL ROSA HOPE ACADEMY
WHEN I WAS A SOPHOMORE.
AND HOW I WAS INTRODUCED I
ACTUALLY THEY JUST BECAUSE YOU
KNOW THEY JUST UNROLL YOU AND.
RADOVAN CLASSES THAT YOU NEED
FOR OUR SOPHOMORE YEAR AND THEY
OWN RULED ME IN ONE OF THE HOPE
ACADEMY CLASSES. AND I RECENTLY
JUST CAME BACK BECAUSE.
FRESHMAN YEAR I LEFT I DROPPED
OUT AND I WAS PREGNANT WITH MY
DAUGHTER.
SO THEN I LASTED NO SOFTWARE YA
CAME BACK AND SHE WAS THE ONE
WHO MOTIVATED ME TO BECOME A.
NURSE
SO THAT'S WHY ONCE I FOUND OUT
ABOUT THIS HOPE ACADEMY PROGRAM
I.
WAS MOTIVATED TO STAY IN.
AND NOW I'M IN MY SENIOR YEAR
AND I HAVE THIS OPPORTUNITY
SUGATA.
STUCK IN HIGH SCHOOL AND BE IN
THE CA NAY PROGRAM AGAINST BE A
LOT OF. OPPORTUNITIES THAT.
IT'S GONNA PROVIDE ME JOBS
WHEN I GRADUATE HIGH SCHOOL AND
PASSED MY.
SEE AN AIDS TEST.
SO THE BENEFITS OF SO THIS.
CT  CLASSES AS THAT.
THEY.
PROVIDE ME COURSES THAT I OUR
LIGHTS OF MY FUTURE CAREER
GOALS.
AND THIS.
THEY ALSO PROVIDE COLLEGE
CREDITS JUST LIKE MISS BRONSKI
HON STATED. THAT.
WE DO THE DUAL ENROLLMENT WITH
FRESNO CITY COLLEGE AND THE ONE
OF THE CLUB THE TWO CLASSES
THAT.
THEY PROVIDE I RULES OF ALL IS
LOVE PHARMACOLOGY CLASS OF THE
MEDICAL TERMINOLOGY.
AND THE ONE THAT I WAS IN WAS
THE PHARMACOLOGY CLASS.
S. SO I FULLY THE PHARMACOLOGY
CLASS HAS GAVE ME ON.
HIGHER STEP IN MY EDUCATION
LEVEL AND MY KNOWLEDGE BECAUSE
WHEN YOU'RE A NURSE YOU HAVE TO.
DO CALCULATIONS FOR MEDICATIONS
AND THAT'S.
HOW I SAW PHARMACOLOGY IT REALLY
HELPS ME AND LEARNING HOW TO
CALCULATE MEDICINE BECAUSE I
KNOW LIKE?
IT COLLEGE IS KIND OF A HARD
WHOM. GONNA BE.
YEAH SO WHAT ARE MY GOALS IN
LIFE IS TO BECOME A REGISTERED
NURSE WHO.
SPECIALIZES AT NEO DATES.
AND THE COLLEGES I'M PLANNING TO
GO TO IS SPECIAL CITY COLLEGE
AND I PLAYED FOR THEIR FUTURE
NURSES PROGRAM THAT.
AND ALSO FEDERAL STATE THERE
EACH COP PROGRAM TO HELP ME.
BOOST UP AND OUT.
MAKING.
WELL LADIES JUST BECAUSE THOSE
PROGRAMS ARE THEY'RE PROVIDED
FOR ME SO THAT I COULD. GET IT
SO THEY ARE AND PROGRAM AND JUST
TAKE UP MY* WHAT REPRESENTS
I NEED.
AND THE IMPORTANCE OF SEATS
EVOKE OUT AS LIKE.
IT'S SO LET'S BECAUSE I
EXPERIENCE SO MUCH I GOT SO.
VOLUNTEER AS YOU KNOW COMMUNITY
ORIGINAL MEDICAL SENSOR AND
THAT'S NOT WHAT YOU GET TO DO
WHEN YOU'RE A JUNIOR IN HIGH
SCHOOL.
AS.
I LEARNED SO MUCH
AND YOU KNOW YOU REALLY GETS
UNDERSTAND THAT PORTS SINCE OF
HIP BUT AS WELL. BECAUSE HIP
BUZZER REALLY.
IT'S SERIOUS BECAUSE I THOUGHT.
IT'S VERY SERIOUS SLOW AT.
AND YOU KNOW THAT NOMINEES.
KIDS AT MY AGE WHO UNDERSTAND
THE PORT SINCE OF HIP BUT AND.
THAT'S WHAT I FEEL LIKE.
IS REALLY IMPORTANT TO ME ADDS.
C. N. A LIGHT.
BECAUSE I GOT SO GOLDEN LIVING.
TILL ARE DO JOB SITES SO I CAN
GET MY HUNDRED HOURS TO BE ABLE
TO TAKE MY CNA TEST.
IT REALLY HAS TAUGHT ME A LOT OF
HANDS ON EXPERIENCE TO WHEN.
I'VE BECOME A ARE AND I DO I
WOULD DO WHAT CMA'S DO.
L. BUT.
CNA HAS TAUGHT ME TO BE A HUMANE
PERSON ANSWER REALLY.
BE PASSIONATE ABOUT WHAT I WANT
TO BE WHEN I GROW UP AND. THAT'S
JUST.
I KNOW A LOT OF STUDENTS THEY
DON'T WANT TO BE IN THIS CLASS
AT THIS AGE BECAUSE THEY.
THEY SEE IT AS A NEGATIVE WAY
BUT REALLY CNA PROGRAM HOW I SEE
IT.
YOU'RE ABLE TO TAKE CARE YOUR
PARENTS WHEN YOU THE GOLDEN
YEARS.
YEAH. SO I'M SURE PARENTS ARE
ENCOURAGING YOU TO.
I MEAN LIKE.
YOUR ABLE TO YOU KNOW TAKE
PARENTS WHEN A GOAL OR TAKE CARE
OTHER PATIENTS WHO. YOU KNOW
DON'T HAVE ANY RELATIONS TO YOU
BECAUSE USUALLY FAMILY IS MORE
IMPORTANT SO YOU WOULD BE. YOU
HAVE A BIG HEART AND TAKING CARE
OF THEM BUT.
AT THIS AGE SEEING THAT.
HOW IT IS IMPORTANT TO SEA THE
VALUE OF LIFE ESPECIALLY YOU
KNOW PATIENTS WHO ELDERLY
PATIENTS?
IT REALLY JUST OPENS UP MY EYES
THAT.
WE NEED MORE PEOPLE THAT ARE
PASSIONATE ABOUT WHO THEY WANT
TO BE AND.
A PASSION ABOUT TAKING CARE OF
PEOPLE WITHOUT HAVING NEGATIVE
THOUGHTS.
WELL THANK YOU ZEL YEAH VERY
WELL DONE IS PHENOMENAL VERY
WELL DONE.
.
ANY ANY QUESTION I JUST WANNA
SAY HE'S A THANK YOU SO MUCH
MEAN THAT BETWEEN YOU AND GRANT
FROM THE FORMER PANEL THE TWO OF
YOU GO ON THE ROAD. I THINK
EVERYONE WILL SUPPORT CITY OF
FROM EUREKA DOWN THE SAN DIEGO
BUT I JUST WANT TO COMMEND YOU
BECAUSE WHEN. I WAS YOUR AGE I
HAD NO IDEA WHAT I WANTED TO DO
AND THE FACT THAT YOU WERE ABLE.
UP TO FIND IT AND FIND IT
THROUGH A CT PROGRAM IS
PHENOMENAL AND.
I'D I JUST AND AND ONE OTHER
THING AND WE HAVE OUR SHARE OF
THE SHOW DOLLARS BACK YOUR
HOMAGE KALRA REPRESENT SAN
JOSE'S MANAGEMENT FOR A MATCH.
WAS AND NUMBER MEMBERS COMING
OUT BUT I AS WELL THAT YOU KNOW
THAT I'M A LOT OF OUR. OTHER
MEMBERS AS WELL STASHED ALL
WATCHING THE HEARING AND WE HAVE
STAFF MEMBERS ARE COMMITTEE SO
EVERYTHING YOU'RE SAYING IS
REALLY GOING TO BE IMPORTANT
PART OF HOW WE MOVE FORWARD I
WANNA. THANK OUR CHAIR O'DONNELL
FOR MAKING THIS A PRIORITY
BECAUSE WE WOULDN'T BE HERE IF
IT WASN'T FOR HIM SAYING OF THIS
SOMETHING IMPORTANT THAT WE
REALLY NEED TO PAY MORE
ATTENTION TO IT AND SO. HAZEL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH I'M GONNA
HAND BACK OVER TO OUR CHAIR.
BUT.
WANT TO THANK ALL OF YOU FOR
PRESENTING IN FOR THAT GIVES
OPPORTUNITY YEAH ABSOLUTELY
THANK YOU VERY WELL DONE AND
WE'LL. HAVE THE FIRST ONE.
IS.
.
THAT MOST KIDS ARE NOT ALL KIDS
ARE GOING TO PURSUE A FOUR YEAR
DEGREE.
WE KNOW THAT.
SO MANY CAREER CAREER EDUCATION
HIGH SCHOOL THAT IS BOTH
ENGAGING.
AND THAT WILL INSPIRE FURTHER
EDUCATIONAL ATTAINMENT.
BUT ALSO TRAINING OF POST HIGH
SCHOOL.
IT'S NOT EITHER OR COLLEGE OR
CAREER A CHOICE IT'S RATHER
ABOUT A MAKING OF MAXIMIZING
CHOICES FOR ALL STUDENTS.
.
SECOND THE MIDDLE SKILL JOBS
MAKE UP THE LARGEST SEGMENT OF
CALIFORNIA'S LABOR MARKET
ROUGHLY ROUGHLY HALF OF
CALIFORNIA'S LABOR MARKET.
MIDDLE SKILL IS DEFINED AS
REQUIRING.
EDUCATION TRAINING BEYOND HIGH
SCHOOL.
BUT ON A FOUR YEAR COLLEGE
DEGREE.
BUT ANTHONY CARNAVAL THE FROM
GEORGETOWN ESTIMATES THAT NEARLY
HALF OF THE FOLKS
WHO ARE CURRENTLY IN GOOD JOBS
IN CALIFORNIA MEANING A MEDIAN.
ANNUAL INCOME OF FIFTY NINE
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR ARE
MIDDLE SKILL. THE EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT PROJECTS
THAT NEARLY ONE MILLION JOB
OPENINGS OVER THE NEXT TEN YEARS
ARE MIDDLE SKILL.
IN THE POINT THAT I'M TRYING
MAKE IS NOT ONLY WILL NOT ALL
HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATES GO TO
COLLEGE IMMEDIATELY GO TO
COLLEGE AFTER HIGH SCHOOL.
WILL NOT. PURSUE A FOUR YEAR
DEGREE NOT ALL JOBS
REQUIRE A FOUR YEAR DEGREE BUT
ALL GOOD JOBS DO REQUIRE
EDUCATION OR TRAINING AFTER HIGH
SCHOOL.
.
FINALLY.
CAREER EDUCATION IN HIGH SCHOOL.
SHOULD LINE UP.
VERY DIRECTLY WITH WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN IN REGIONAL LABOR
MARKETS.
WORK FOR SPORTS COMMITTEE
COLLEGES
AROUND SHE TO WORKING TOGETHER
REGIONAL PLANS.
THAT IDENTIFY INDUSTRY SECTORS
THAT ARE DRIVING REGIONAL
EMPLOYMENT IN OCCUPATIONS. IN
THOSE SECTORS WITH MOST
PROJECTED OPENINGS.
THERE ARE LINING CREW DUCATION
IN TRAINING WITH COMPANIES IN
THOSE SECTORS. OF THEIR COKE
DESIGNING CURRICULUM WITH
EMPLOYERS.
.
SO HIGH SCHOOL CAREER EDUCATION
SHOULD LINE. UP AS WELL SO THAT
STUDENTS CAN EXPLORE CAREER
PATHWAYS TAKE ADVANTAGE OF WORK
BASED LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES
THAT ARE POPPING UP ALL OVER THE
STATE.
AND TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
ACCESSIBLE AFFORDABLE A
EDUCATION TRAINING POST HIGH
SCHOOL.
.
THIS IS GOOD WORKFORCE POLICY IS
GOOD EDUCATION POLICY BUT IT'S
ALSO GOOD ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
POLICY. AYE IF FOR SUPPORTING A
COMPANIES IN INDUSTRY SECTORS
ARE DRIVING REGIONAL PLAMEN
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
BY CREATING A GOOD QUALITY.
LOVE LABOR POOLS AROUND THE
STATE WE'RE GONNA HELP THOSE
SECTORS GROVER GONNA HELP.
THEM CREATE MORE JOBS IN THIS
CAN BE A GREAT BENEFIT FOR THAT
THE ENTIRE STATE.
I'LL LEAVE IT AT THAT BECAUSE I
KNOW THERE'S A GREAT PANEL
COMING UP NEXT RICK NICOLE
WRITES IN JEREMY SMITH THEY'RE.
BOTH ON THE EXECUTIVE COMMITTEE
OF THE STATE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT PORTS I'M HOPING
THAT THEY ARE NOT THE BALL OUT
OF THE PARK.
GREAT THANK YOU WILL LISTEN
THANK YOU FOR WHAT YOU DO
EVERYDAY AND YOU WERE GREAT
PANELS WELL SO THANK YOU.
I WOULD THAT WILL MOVE TO OUR
NEXT PANEL.
WAYNE DAVIES.
IT'S COMING FORWARD.
AND MARLENE GARCIA.
SEE JERRY ME SMITH I BELIEVE.
IS THERE TOO I THINK THAT'S IT
FOR THE LAST PANEL I BELIEVE.
SOME MAY HAVE HAD.
SOME MAY HAVE LEVERAGE.
WITH IT O FIRST WE'LL HEAR
FROM PLAIN DAVIES HIS FROM THE
CALIFORNIA SHEET METAL AND AIR
CONDITIONING CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION.
I SEEN NICOLE OUR.
BRYCE COMING FORWARD NOW.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE
BECAUSE I KNOW YOU OFFER
COMMITMENTS.
SO GRAY DAVIS.
THANK YOU FOR BEING PATIENT IT
WAS FIRST GO THIS LONG BUT YOU
KNOW WHAT THAT'S A GOOD THING.
OF NO ONE ASKED A QUESTION WE
WILL THEN DONE TWO HOURS AGO BUT
WE MIGHT NOT HAVE THIS BIG OF.
YOU KNOW WE MIGHT NOT HAVE MUCH
THEM THAT MUCH SUPPORT FOR THIS
ISSUE OF THAT WERE THE CASE SO
THANK YOU AND WE'RE LIMITED TO
THREE MINUTES OFTEN VARY UP GOES
WHERE I WAS TOLD THAT PICKED. SO
MY NAME IS GOING TO HAVE YOU
SIGN EXECUTIVE VICE PRESIDENT
FOR NATIONAL AYE BROWN'S
COMPANY.
ON THE STATE TREASURER ALSO FOR
CALIFORNIA SHE MIDDLE
CONTRACTORS ASSOCIATION.
I WANNA THANK YOU EACH OF YOU
FOR TAKING THE TIME TO BE HERE
TODAY. AND LET ME SET ARE BY
SAYING THAT VOCATIONAL EDUCATION
HAD EARLY IN PROFOUND IMPACT. ON
ME.
MY DOES EXCESS MY LIGHT NAM
OPPORTUNITIES.
THIS IS TRUE FOR ME AND ALL MY
PEERS IN CALIFORNIA'S
ENGINEERING CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRIES.
I'M LITERALLY HERE TODAY AS A
PRODUCT THE PUBLIC INVESTMENT IN
VOCATIONAL EDUCATION IN THE
NINETEEN SIXTIES AND NINETEEN
SEVENTIES.
I IT IN SCHOOL I WAS NOT
INTERESTED IN TRADITIONAL
CLASSES AND DID JUST WHAT WAS
NECESSARY TO PASS THEM.
I WAS HOWEVER EXCITED TO ATTEND
SHOP CLASS AND BUILD SOMETHING
AND SEE THE POSITIVE RESULTS.
WELL IN HIGH SCHOOL I WAS
EXPOSED TO WORK EXPERIENCE
OPPORTUNITY.
DURING THIS SESSION I WAS
REQUIRED TO READ VARIOUS
ARTICLES ON CAREER TECHNICAL JOB
OPPORTUNITIES AND WRITE A BRIEF
REPORT.
ONE CAREER OPPORTUNITY H. PAC
HAD ME VERY INTRIGUED.
THE CREW REQUIRED ELECTRICAL
WELDING SHEET METAL AND OTHER
SKILLS.
IT ALSO PAID EXTREMELY WELL I
BELIEVE.
IN LOOKING AT A PATH TO ENTER
THE TRADE I FOUND I COULD ATTEND
LANEY COLLEGE IN OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA.
LAINEY OFFERED A TWO YEAR
CERTIFICATION PROGRAM ORNISH
SOCIAL SCIENCE DEGREE.
I TOOK THE CERTIFICATION PATH
EXECUTIVE BOARD CLASSIFIED SO
WANTED TO SKIP IN HIGH SCHOOL.
AFTER TWO YEARS AT LANEY.
COLLEGE I WAS ABLE SECURE AN
APPRENTICESHIP WITH A SHEET
METAL WORKERS UNION.
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY SEVEN I
BEGAN MY CAREER AT NATIONAL OR
BALLOTS COMPANY.
AND ONLY EIGHT SHORT YEARS LATER
I BECAME A PARTNER IN THE FIRM.
AFTER SPENDING TEN YEARS IN THE
FIELD I BEGIN HAVE MORE
INVOLVEMENT IN THE BUSINESS SIDE
OF THINGS.
IT WAS THEN THAT I WENT BACK TO
SCHOOL TO TAKE CONTINUING
EDUCATION CLASS WORK NECESSARY.
TO DEVELOP A CLEAR UNDERSTANDING
OF HOW THE FINANCIAL SID THE
BUSINESS WAS OPERATED.
WITH MY VOCATIONAL INTERESTS AND
LIFE EXPERIENCE THAT LED ME TO
DEVELOP THE DESIRE TO RETURN AN
ACTUAL LEARNED IN THE TYPICAL
ACADEMIC CLASSROOM SETTING.
THIS UNFORTUNATE IN MY OPINION
HE'S IMPORTANT VOCATIONAL
PATHWAYS TO BOTH LIFE AND POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION ARE NO
LONGER ENCOURAGED IN THE CALL
COLLEGE ONLY PATHWAYS.
OF TODAY'S HIGH SCHOOLS.
IN FACT SEE TI E. AS IMPORTANT
TO TO PAY TWELVE STUDENTS IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AS THE
ADVANCED PLACEMENT PLACEMENT
CLASSES ARE TO STUDENTS WERE
GOING TO TAKE WAS CONSIDERED THE
TRADITIONAL. YOU SEE CSU COLLEGE
ADMISSION ROUTE AFTER HIGH
SCHOOL.
IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN I WAS
FORTUNATE TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SERVE ON A PANEL
THAT WAS INTERVIEWING POTENTIAL
CANDIDATES FOR THE UNION SHEET
METAL PRISON PROGRAM. IN THE BAY
AREA.
THERE WERE MULTIPLE CANDIDATES
WHO ARE ACTUALLY GRADUATES FROM
TRADITIONAL FOUR YEAR COLLEGES.
I WAS INTERESTED TO LISTEN TO
THEIR REASONS FOR WANTING TO
HAVE A CAREER PATH IN THE
CONSTRUCTION TRADE AFTER
SPENDING NEARLY ALL THEIR LIVES
ON ACADEMIC ONLY PATHWAY.
THE REASONS THEY CITED RANGE
FROM PAY AND BENEFITS TO THE
WORK HOURS AND THE QUALITY OF
LIFE.
OUR FIRM NOW CO HIRED FOR THE
YOUNG MAN AND I AM HAPPY TO SAY
THERE ARE DOING WELL.
ALTHOUGH THEY NOW MUST COMPLETE
A FIVE YEAR PARTNERSHIP.
PROGRAM AND PAY BACK YOUR UC AND
CSU LOANS.
HAVE YOU BEEN EXPOSED TO CREEK
TECHNICAL EDUCATION K. TWELVE
THEY MAY HAVE BEEN YEARS AHEAD
AND FREE TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS IN STUDENT LOANS.
IT SADDENS ME AND MY PEERS THAT
THE CURRENT CULTURE AND OUR
STATE DOES NOT PUT THE SAME
EMPHASIS AND FUNDING TOWARDS
VOCATIONAL EDUCATION AS THEY DO
FOR COLLEGE PREP COURSE WORK IN
MIDDLE SCHOOLS AND HIGH SCHOOLS.
THIS ISN'T EMBLEMATIC OF A
DANGEROUS CLASS CASTE SYSTEM
THAT PERPETUATES THE FALSE
NOTIONS THAT PEOPLE WHO PURSUE
ONLY ACADEMIC GOALS. ARE SMARTER
THAN.
MORE SUCCESSFUL THEN.
AND MORE IMPORTANT.
THEN THOSE WHO CHOOSE TO WORK
WITH THEIR HANDS.
IN FACT THIS
DAHLE TELLS THE MAJORITY OF OUR
CHILDREN THE LESS THEY PURSUE
ADMISSIONS TO OUR UC AND CSU
SYSTEMS.
THAT THEY ARE NOT A PRIORITY.
THIS IS WRONG.
WOULD LIKE TO THANK CHAIRMAN
O'DONNELL AND EVERYONE SERVING
ON THESE COMMITTEES FOR TAKING
THE ISSUE SERIOUSLY REALIZING
THE EQUITY OF CREEK THEM
OFFERING STARRCADE TOLL SYSTEM.
YOUR COURAGE AND COMMITMENT TO
PROVIDING THE NECESSARY FUNDS TO
VOCATIONAL PROGRAMS THAT WILL
HELP RESTORE COMMITMENT OF
PRODUCT EVERY CHILD IN THE K.
TWELVE SYSTEM.
AND I KNOW I ONLY HAVE THREE
MINUTES I'VE EXCEEDED EGGMAN
EVERYBODY'S PROBABLY TIRED. BUT
I WANT ALSO TELL YOU AS AN
EMPLOYER. CURRENTLY TODAY I
TURNED DOWN AN OPPORTUNITY TO GO
WORK AT THE TEST LOW BATTERY
FACTORY BECAUSE I DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH EMPLOYEES WITH THE SKILL
SETS REQUIRED TO DO THE WORK WE
DO.
I GOT A CALL TODAY FROM NORTH
CAROLINA THEY WANT US TO COME UP
AND
HELP BUILD A PHARMACEUTICAL
COMPANY.
FACILITY A TWO BILLION DOLLAR
FACILITY.
I HAD TO TURN HIM DOWN BECAUSE I
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH SKILLS
EMPLOYEES.
THIS.
A TRAGEDY.
IT'S A MIDDLE CLASS JOB.
IT'S SOMETHING THAT.
I COULD DO.
ANYBODY.
AND I MAY HAVE A STUDENT TOWN
TODAY BUT I CAN FROM A VERY POOR
ENVIRONMENT AND I'VE BEEN A WORK
MY WAY FOR BECAUSE OF CONTINUING
EDUCATION.
HER CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION
SOMETHING THAT'S GOT TO BE
FUNDED.
FUNDED FULLY FUNDED
CONSISTENTLY.
AND AND FUNDED AT SOMETHING THAT
IS IS.
ASSIGNED TO THAT.
THAT ISSUE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OKAY THANK YOU MISTER DAVIES
VERY AUTHENTIC.
A VERY AUTHENTIC.
AND THINK YOUR YOUR EARS YET.
ADDRESS WAS CLAPPING YOU CAN FOR
HIM HE DID A GREAT JOB.
IN ONE THE MORE AUTHENTIC
SPEAKERS TODAY HONESTLY.
BECAUSE YOU GET THE REAL LIFE
STORY OF WHAT HAPPENS WHEN WE DO
HAVE CLEAR TECHNOLOGY ASIAN. AND
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN WE DON'T.
AND THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE FACED
WITH TODAY.
AND YOU KNOW AS MY FATHER IN LAW
WAS A SHEET METAL WORKER FOR
PROBABLY WHAT THIRTY EIGHT
YEARS.
SINO Y. LE YOU KNOW.
WHAT EQUALITY FEEL THAT IS TO
ENTER AND HOW IT PROVIDES FOR
FAMILY?
YOU KNOW FED MY WIFE. ON HONOR
I'D HEARD.
YOUNG YEARS SELF THANK YOU.
WITH THAT.
WILL TURN TO.
.
MARLENE GARCIA FROM COMPTON.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME GOOD
AFTERNOON OF MY NAME IS MARLENE
GARCIA I'M WITH APPLE EDUCATION
I SPEAK TODAY AS A MEMBER
COMPANY OF COMP HERE A NONPROFIT
TRADE ASSOCIATION. SERVING AS A
LEADING VOICE OF THE INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY INDUSTRY IN THE
COUNTRY.
.
I'M HERE TODAY BECAUSE AB OUT
THOUGH WE REALLY BELIEVE IN.
PARTYING TWENTY FIRST CENTURY
CT.
SKILLS WITH STUDENTS
BOB I WANT TO FOCUS MY COMMENTS
BRIEFLY ON THE CHANGING NATURE
OF THE WORKPLACE THE NEED FOR
ALL STUDENTS TO HAVE EXPOSURE TO
CODEINE AS ONE OF THOSE BASIC
SKILLS. AND THEN ALSO THE NEED
FOR US TO FUND TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY CITY PROGRAMS.
SO AT APPLE WE BELIEVE STRONGLY
IN THE INVESTMENT OF CT
SKILLS TWENTY FIRST CENTURY
SKILLS BECAUSE TECHNOLOGY
TOUCHES ALL FACETS OF OUR LIVES.
THERE'S AN EXPLOSION OF JOBS
REQUIRING COMPUTER SCIENCE
ENCODING FOR NUMEROUS.
ENTRY LEVEL POSITIONS THAT
DON'T EVEN REQUIRE OF ADVANCED
DEGREES.
IN THE U. ALONE APPLE SUPPORTS
TWO MILLION JOBS
THROUGH AT FOR THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTRY IN ALL FIFTY STATES.
INCLUDING ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
APP ECONOMY JOBS AND FOR HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND JOBS
ATTRIBUTABLE TO COMPANIES THAT.
APPLE WORKS WITH AS SUPPLIERS.
NEW MOST NOTABLY CALIFORNIA OF
COURSE HAS THE HIGHEST
CONCENTRATION OF AB SUPPLY OF.
OF.
U. S. BASED SUPPLIER COMPANIES
AS WELL AS THE APP ECONOMY
CHOPS.
ACCORDING TO A RECENT REPORT BY
CANTIERE THE CYBER STATES REPORT
THERE'S BEEN A HUGE GROWTH IN
TECHNOLOGY JOBS WHICH WE ALL
KNOW BUT IN CALIFORNIA. THERE
HAS BEEN THAT WE'VE ADDED FORTY
EIGHT THOUSAND NEW TECHNOLOGY
FALL INTO TWO CATEGORIES ONE IS
YOUR TRADITIONAL TEXT THEM JOBS
IN THERE ABOUT ONE POINT TWO
MILLION. JOBS O. AVAILABLE TODAY
AND THESE ARE THE JOBS FILLED BY
TRADITIONAL TECH COMPANIES LIKE
APPLE GOOGLE AS WELL AS START
UPS. BUT INTERESTINGLY THERE'S A
SECOND CATEGORY OF JOBS AND
THESE ARE TECHNOLOGY OCCUPATIONS
AND THESE ARE JOBS THAT DON'T
NECESSARILY REQUIRE YOU TO BE AN
EXPERT. PROGRAMMER BUT RATHER
MODEST MIDDLE SKILL JOBS THAT
COMPANIES ARE SEARCHING FOR
PEOPLE TO FILL THESE KINDS OF
JOBS WITHIN RETAIL HOSPITALITY.
PRIVATE SECTOR AS WELL AS.
GOVERNMENT IN EDUCATION.
AND THESE ARE JOBS THAT WE THINK
FALL SQUARELY IN THE IN IN IN
THE CATEGORY OF QUALITY CAREER
TECHNICAL ED JOBS.
BUT WE ALSO KNOW THAT THE JOB
MARKETS BECOMING INCREASINGLY.
AUTOMATED AND THERE'S A LOT OF
FEAR ABOUT THIS BUT WE KNOW THAT
THESE JOBS A SIX GREATER TODAY
FOR EXAMPLE BY THE TIME THEY HIT
THEIR THEIR PEAK JOB YEARS IN
TWENTY THIRTY.
ABOUT HALF OF TODAY'S JAWS WILL
BE REPLACED WITH OTHER JOBS.
LOT OF TIMES THESE JOBS ARE
REFERRED TO AS NEW COLLAR JOBS.
SO WE CAN'T PREDICT WHAT THOSE
JOBS ARE GOING TO BE IN THE
FUTURE BUT WE KNOW THAT THE
KINDS OF SKILLS THAT STUDENTS
ARE GIVEN NEED TO SUCCEED IN
THESE EMERGING NEW JOBS THAT WE
DON'T EVEN KNOW ABOUT TODAY.
THAT THEIR SKILLS SUCH AS
COMPUTATIONAL THINKING WORKING
COLLABORATIVELY PROBLEM SOLVING
SKILLS AND DIGITAL LITERACY
SKILLS.
AND WE'VE FOCUSED A LOT ON THE
DIGITAL LITERACY SKILLS SO WE
BELIEVE ALL STUDENTS SHOULD HAVE
ACCESS TO CODING.
AND WE CONSIDER COATING THE NEW
BASIC SKILLS ARE BASIC LITERACY
SKILL FOR THE TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY.
WE THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR ALL
STUDENTS BE EXPOSED A COATING AT
AN EARLY AGE INCLUDING C.
STUDENTS. THIS MIGHT TURN ON THE
LIGHT BULB AND HELP THEM
DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT THE TWO
CAN GO INTO A HIGH DEMAND STEM
FIELD WHICH WERE SORELY LACKING
IN. GIRLS AND STUDENTS FROM
DISADVANTAGED BACKGROUNDS.
BUT EVEN IF THE STUDENT IS NOT A
STEM ORIENTED STUDENT THE STONY
THAT'S THAT EXPOSURE BECAUSE.
TECHNOLOGY IS EMBEDDED IN
VIRTUALLY ALL BUSINESSES NOW AND
THEY'LL BE PART OF CREATING
THESE NEW SYSTEMS AND THEY HAVE
TO HAVE THAT BASIC EXPOSURE TO
UNDERSTAND. THE TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY BUSINESS.
AND LASTLY ABOUT CODING WE
REALLY THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
ARMOR STUDENTS WITH THE SKILLS
THAT ALLOWED THEM TO CREATE
TECHNOLOGY AND NOT JUST CONSUME
TECHNOLOGY.
SO LASTLY.
AS EVERYONE HAS SAID TODAY WE
NEED WE BELIEVE THAT WE NEED A
CONTINUED INVESTMENT IN SQUALID
ECT  PROGRAMS WE KNOW ABOUT
THIRTY PERCENT OF THE STUDENTS
IN CALIFORNIA GO WANT YOUR
TRADITIONAL. HIGHER ED.
INSTITUTIONS BUT WHAT ABOUT THE
REMAINING SEVENTY PERCENT WE
BELIEVE IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO
EXPOSE THEM TO THESE PALM
DIGITAL SKILLS TO CLOSE THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE AND PREPARE THEM
FOR THOSE EMERGING JOBS. THAT
ARE OPEN AND AVAILABLE IN OUR
STATE AND OUR COUNTRY.
AND.
WE KNOW THAT FOR THE STUDENTS
THEY CAN GET ONE OF THESE SIR
SHORT TERM CERTIFICATE PROGRAMS
AND NOT NECESSARILY HAVE TO PAY.
THE HIGH COST OF A COLLEGE FOUR
YEAR EDUCATION SO WE THINK FACT
CAREER TECHNICAL ED PROGRAMS
OFFER GREAT PROMISE TO STUDENTS.
AND THEY GIVE THEM STUDENTS THE
TRAINING THEY NEED THAT'S
ESSENTIAL FOR PREPARING THEM FOR
THE WORK OF THE FUTURE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISS GARCIA
THANK YOU FOR.
IT'S GOOD TO HEAR APPLES VOICE
IN THIS CAPITAL HONESTLY BECAUSE
I CAN'T DO THIS ALONE I NEED TO
HEAR FROM OUR INDUSTRY PARTNERS.
AND OTHER ASSEMBLY MEMBERS NEED
TO HEAR FROM INDUSTRY PARTNERS
IF WE'RE GOING TO MAKE THE
CHANGE WE NEED TO MAKE SO THANK
YOU.
I WOULD THAT.
WILL HEAR FROM.
JERRY. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AND
ALL THAT OTHER CHAIRS OF THE.
OTHER RELEVANT COMMITTEES THAT
WERE HERE EARLIER IN HERE DAY WE
THINK YOU AND YOUR STAFF FOR THE
TIME.
TODAY TO DO THE SECOND HEARING
A LOT OF WHAT I SAID.
IN BUENA PARK
I WOULD'VE SAID AGAIN TODAY
TIME.
.
BUT THERE WAS TIME BUT I WANNA
MAKE IS THE FEW NEW POINTS.
WE BELIEVE.
AS AT THE PREVIOUS SPEAKER A
SAID THAT YOU NEED TO ATTRACT
THESE KIDS TO THESE CAREERS THAT
DON'T REQUIRE A UNIVERSITY
EDUCATION.
AND THAT CONSTRUCTION TRADES
THAT'S.
A.
BECAUSE YOU CAN START WORKING
RIGHT OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL AN
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM.
AND THE APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM
IS THE COLLEGE IN THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY THAT'S THE
THREE TO FIVE YEAR DEGREE
DEPENDING ON THE CRAFT THAT YOU
GO THROUGH THAT. WOULD.
TAKE THE PLACE OF A TRADITIONAL
FOR YOUR COLLEGE EDUCATION AND
THE GOOD THING ABOUT A
PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM OF THIS EARN
WHILE YOU LEARN LEARN.
EARLY LEARN YES.
.
YOU ARE EARNING A LIVING WAGE
WITH BENEFITS AND A PENSION AND
HEALTH CARE. OF VACATION TIME
ALL THOSE THINGS WHILE YOU'RE
LEARNING THE CRAFT.
NOW WE ARE IN OF A CONSTRUCTION
BOOM RIGHT NOW IN PART OF THAT
IS BECAUSE OF WHAT THIS
LEGISLATURE IS DONE.
WHETHER IT'S PASSING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING LEGISLATION.
THERE'S A GREAT NEED THEIR.
SP ONE THAT JUST PASSED LAST
YEAR AS WELL.
TO FILL SOME OF THAT SEVENTY
BILLION UNFUNDED LIABILITY AND
ROAD MAINTENANCE AND
CONSTRUCTION.
THE WORK IS THERE TO FOR THE
KIDS TO GO TO QUOTE UNQUOTE
COLLEGE WHEN THEY'RE NOT
PRESSURE PROGRAM ONLY THANK YOU
OFFER THAT.
SO THERE'S A GREAT CAREER OUT
THERE WAITING FOR THESE KIDS I
JOIN A PRESSURE PROGRAMS AND
YOU'VE ALSO INCENTIVIZE THE USE
OF A SKILLED AND TRAINED
WORKFORCE ON DIFFERENT TYPES OF
PROJECTS WHICH MEANS. GRADUATES
OF STATE APPROVED THE
PARTNERSHIP PROGRAMS.
AND EVEN SEND A BY THE
INCENTIVIZE THESE A PROJECT
LABOR AGREEMENTS WHICH ALSO PUT.
ABOUT GRADUATE THE STATE
APPROVED THE PRESSURE PROGRAMS
TO WORK.
SO WE ARE VERY PLEASED THAT THE
GOVERNOR HAS SEEN FIT TO EXTEND
THE PROGRAM WE.
AGREE WITH YOUR BILL MORE ABOUT
HOW IT SHOULD BE EXTENDED BOTH
IN TERMS OF MONEY AND IN TERMS
OF OVERSIGHT. SO ABRASIVE PORT
OF OF YOUR EFFORT.
.
I WANTED JUST LEVY WITH TWO DOTS
FIRST.
IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER THERE'S
ONLY FOUR FUNDING STREAMS FOR CT
IN THE STATE THE ANSWER NOT
GRANT.
PERKINS.
.
THE FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
THAT WOULD THAT HAVE BEEN IN THE
LAST TWO SCHOOL BONDS FOR CT
FACILITY CONSTRUCTION AND
THE ARROGANCE AND GRANT.
WE CANNOT AFFORD TO LOSE THE C.
IG IT'S A CRITICAL PART OF
FUNDING.
A THIS PROGRAM IS THE FIRST DAY
SO MANY DISTRICTS WANT MORE
MONEY THAN THEY'RE GETTING NOW.
AND FINALLY I WANT TO SAY THAT.
WE PAY FOR THE STATE'S JOINT
LABOR MANAGEMENT PRESSURE
PROGRAMS.
WE NEED THE STATE TO STEP IN AND
PAY FOR THE CT  PROGRAMS IN
THE HIGH SCHOOLS SO THAT THOSE
KIDS CAN.
MATRICULATED OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL
INTO THE STATE A PUT A PRESSURE
PROGRAMS THAT WE PROVIDE WITH.
WITH OUR MONEY TO TRAIN THEM
FOR THE CONSTRUCTION JOBS OF THE
FUTURE THANK.
THANK YOU A THIS RICE YOU'VE
BEEN VERY PATIENT.
THE LAST MERRILEES.
THINKING OF HER THE WHOLE.
AGAIN TO CALL RISE.
I'M THE. LEVER AND POLICY.
LABOR AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
POLICY DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION AND I
JUST WANT TO START OUT BY SAYING
THANK YOU TO YOU CHAIRED ON ALL
ALL THE OTHER CHAIRS AND MEMBERS
WHO ARE HERE. FROM THE
RESPECTIVE COMMITTEES ABOUT YOUR
COLLECTIVE LEADERSHIP AND
PERSISTENCE
TO ENSURING AND PRIORITIZING
CRITIC EDUCATION ON IN THIS
LEGISLATIVE SESSION.
.
WHEN I WAS BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE.
BEFORE AND WHEN ó PARK I
SHARE THAT WE HAD EIGHT SHORT
MONTHS
BEFORE THE C. TAG FUNDING WAS
ENDING IN TODAY WERE
APPROXIMATELY AT FOUR MONTHS.
BEFORE THIS IMPORTANT POLICY
DRIVER THAT'S MAINTAINING ALL OF
THESE PROGRAMS.
EXPIRES.
WHILE MANUFACTURERS ARE AND
REMAIN ENCOURAGED BY THE
ATTENTION AND DEDICATION THAT'S
BEING PAID TO MAINTAINING
FUNDING FOR THESE CRITICAL
PROGRAMS. WE WANT A REALLY
REMIND YOU ALL TODAY THAT THE
FRAMEWORK FOR DELIVERY IS JUST
AS IMPORTANT AS THE FUNDING.
WHICH IS WHY CMT A CONTINUES TO
SUPPORT A C. T. E. DELIVER
DELIVERY MODEL THAT EMBODIES.
KEY THESE THREE KEY ELEMENTS
THE PERMANENT DEDICATING FUNDING
BECAUSE THAT WILL ENSURE THAT
YOU HAVE SUSTAINABLE PROGRAMS.
ALIGNMENT TO INDUSTRY NEEDS THAT
ARE INFORMED BY REGIONAL LABOR
MARKET DATA BECAUSE THAT WILL
ENSURE THAT WHAT WE'RE TRAINING
STUDENTS TO. THEIR ACTUALLY JOBS
AVAILABLE AND IN THERE YOU KNOW
COMMUNITIES FOR THEM TO COMPETE
FOR AND THEN REGIONALLY
DELIVERED STATE LEADERSHIP THAT
ENCOMPASSES STRONG
ACCOUNTABILITY BECAUSE THAT WILL
ENSURE THATYOU'RE GETTING YOUR
RETURN ON YOUR INVESTMENT.
AND ALSO ALL THREE OF THESE WILL
ALSO ENSURE THAT THERE ARE HIGH
QUALITY PROGRAMS DELIVERED FOR
KRETEK EDUCATION WHICH IS I I
THINK THAT WE ALL.
IS OUR GOAL FOR EVERYONE TO
ENSURE THAT
STUDENTS CAN ACTUALLY.
GET JOBS ON HAVE SOLID ON
ECONOMIC FUTURES AND CAREER
MOBILITY.
A CALIFORNIA STUDENTS CANNOT
COMPETE FOR TWENTY FIRST CENTURY
JOBS WITH NINETEENTH CENTURY
SKILLS AND TRAINING APPROACHES.
AND MANUFACTURERS IN CALIFORNIA
CANNOT CONTINUE TO INNOVATE WE
CAN'T CONTINUE TO EXPAND WITHOUT
A HIGH TRAINED WORKFORCE BECAUSE
THE INNOVATION AND TECHNOLOGY AS
MY PANEL MAY JUST SAT WILL NOT
WAIT.
THE INDUSTRIAL WORKFORCE
PIPELINE IS DRY. AND THE SILVER
TSUNAMI THAT WE ALL HEAR ABOUT
WILL SOON OVERTAKE MANUFACTURING
BECAUSE THE GENERATION THAT'S
RESPONSIBLE FOR BUILDING THE
WORLD THAT WE LIVE. CONTINUES TO
RETIRE AND ACCELERATED RATE.
EVERY TIME THAT WE CANNOT FIND
ACCOUNT OF QUALIFIED CANDIDATES
TO BACK FILL THOSE OPENINGS
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS LOSE
THEIR COMPETITIVE EDGE.
AND WITHOUT A PROPERLY TRAINED
WORK FORCE WE CANNOT INCREASE
PRODUCTION TO MEET INCREASING
DEMAND WE CANNOT IMPLEMENT NEW
TECHNOLOGIES TO INCREASE
EFFICIENCIES AND ACHIEVE
PRODUCTION TARGETS.
WE CANNOT ENERGIES NEW PRODUCTS
DIVERT AND DEVELOP THEM OR
INNOVATE.
WE CAN EVEN PROVIDE BETTER
CUSTOMER SERVICE BECAUSE ALL OF
THAT IS NOW WELL CONNECTED WITH
THE INTERNET OF THINGS.
AND ULTIMATELY WE CANNOT
STRENGTH THE STATE'S MIDDLE
CLASS ECONOMY.
AND I WON'T GO INTO ALL THE
STATISTICS THAT WE TALKED ABOUT
WHERE TO PARK ABOUT WHAT WE'RE
HEARING FROM OUR HR
PROFESSIONALS RELATED TO
MANUFACTURING AND. LOGISTIC
FEELS ABOUT THE CANDIDATES THAT
WERE SEEN YOU KNOW THE AND
EXPERIENCE WITH HANDS ON TASKS
IN THE. MECHANICAL APTITUDE AND
AND THE DIFFICULTY THEY'RE
HAVING ONCE THEY'RE INTEGRATING
INTO THE WILL THE EXISTING
WORKFORCE. BUT WHAT I WILL ENDED
SAYING THAT AS THE GLOBAL
MARKETPLACE DEMANDS GREATER
INNOVATION.
AND TECHNOLOGY APTITUDE
MANUFACTURERS NEED A RELIABLE
PIPELINE OF HIGHLY TRAINED
INDIVIDUALS TO MEET BOTH OUR
CURRENT AND OUR FUTURE JOB
NEEDS.
SEEM TABLE EXPORT TO CONTINUALLY
WORKING WITH YOU TO ADDRESS
THIS.
OF SKILLS GAP ISSUE THIS
CRITICAL SKILLS GAP ISSUE AND TO
DIVERT.
DEVELOP A SUSTAINABLE DELIVERY
SYSTEM SO THINK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME THANK YOU WELL DONE ALL OF
YOU.
THANK YOU.
THAT AS OUR LAST PANEL SO THANK
YOU. WILL NOT TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT.
YOU MAKE HIM A COME UP.
STATE YOUR NAME AFFILIATION AND
IF YOU HAVE IN THIS SHARE PLEASE
KEEP IT TO ABOUT THIRTY SECONDS
IF YOU COULD JUST BECAUSE.
BEEN A LONG.
DRIVER THIRTY.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
VALERIE THE SITCH I'M WITH THE
FRESNO COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF
SCHOOLS OFFICE I'M THE
ADMINISTRATOR FOR CRITIC AT ROP
WE ARE STILL FUNCTIONING ROP IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY. I'M I AM ONE
OF THOSE SEVEN TECHNICAL SYSTEMS
PROVIDERS THAT MISS WHITE SPOKE
ABOUT EARLIER AND IRONICALLY THE
REGION I SERVE WOULD BE THE SAME
GEOGRAPHICAL AREA THAT. THE WORK
FORCE THE GREATER WORKFORCE AND
PEACE DOES I THINK IT'S
INTERESTING THERE'S A COUPLE OF
THINGS HAVE BEEN SAID TODAY THAT
SORT OF PRESUME THAT K. TWELVE
CT  IS NOT AS.
INTEGRATED WITH OUR BUSINESS
PARTNERS AS AS WE SHOULD BE AND
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT ALL OF OUR PROGRAMS ARE
ALIGNED WITH OUR REGIONAL
WORKFORCE INITIATIVES. IN OUR
STATEWIDE LABOR BECAUSE IT'S NOT
MY JOB TO KEEP SOMEBODY IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY IT'S MY JOB TO
MAKE SURE THEY KNOW WHAT THEIR.
SKILLS ARE AND WHERE THEY NEED
TO GO TO PURSUE THOSE SKILLS.
I ALSO THINK IT'S REALLY
CRITICAL THAT OF THE SIX
THOUSAND HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
THAT I SERVING FRESNO ROP YOU
HEARD FROM MY BIGGEST PARTNER
FRESNO. BUT A SERVICE SMALLEST
PARTNER WHICH IS LATENT WHICH
HAS LESS THAN TWO HUNDRED
STUDENTS.
THE CAPACITY FOR THOSE SMALL
RURAL DISTRICTS TO BE ABLE TO
COMPETE AGAINST THEIR LARGER
PARTNERS EVEN IN A TIERED SYSTEM
IS GOING TO BE. VERY A TOUGH FOR
THEM WHAT WE'VE LEARNED THROUGH
OUR TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE WE
PROVIDE PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
A ONE ON ONE CONSULTATION. ON
THE CHURN OF ADMINISTRATORS WHO
HAVE NO CT EXPERIENCE THROUGH
OUR SCHOOLS IS GREAT. AND THE
STATE'S STABILITY THAT WE CAN
PROVIDE IS A RADIO THANKS A
FRESNO GOT THE MOST TIME TODAY.
.
BUT THANK YOU KNOW I APPRECIATE
THIS COMES.
MARK EPSTEIN DIRECTOR CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL TECHNOLOGY
EDUCATION NETWORK OVER THE PAST
THAT DECADE WE'VE BEEN
ADVOCATING FOR ON A NUMBER OF
CHANGES HOW STRUCTURALLY.
DEALING WITH CTA CT  FOR
THAT I WILL HIGHLIGHT VERY
QUICKLY NUMBER ONE AND PROBABLY
THE MOST IMPORTANT IS WE NEED TO
HAVE. A SET COLLEGE PREPARE TORY
SEQUENCE FOR THE CT
PATHWAYS. AS AN ALTERNATIVE TO
THE A THREE G. SEQUENCE THAT HAS
THE SAME RESPECT.
AND ACCEPTANCE.
TO.
WE NEED REFORM OF THE
ARTICULATION AGREEMENT PROCESS
BETWEEN THE HIGH SCHOOLS IN THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES SPECIFICALLY
ALLOWING HIGH SCHOOLS. TO MAKE
AN ARTICULATION AGREEMENT WITH
ANY COMMUNITY COLLEGE IN THE
STATE AND NUMBER TWO IS
ELIMINATING THE TWELVE HOUR
RESIDENCY REQUIREMENT THAT HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS TO HAVE THOSE.
CREDITS.
GRANTED.
NUMBER THREE AN* SUMMER
YOUTH EMPLOYMENT PROGRAM WHICH
IS IMPLEMENTED BY LAW HIPS.
THAT WE NEED TO HAVE A VERY
STRONG CONNECTION BETWEEN THE
WORKING WITH THE LOCAL WHERE
IT'S A VAT PROGRAM. AND THE
SELECTING OF STUDENTS TO BE TIED
TO THEIR LOCAL HIGH SCHOOLS
CAREER PATHWAY IN ACADEMY
PROGRAMS.
NUMBER FOUR.
IS THAT WITH THE REPEATEDLY OF
TECHNOLOGICAL CHANGE IN THE
BREAKING DOWN OF OUR
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT PROCESS
WE NEED TO ALLOW THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS.
TO ALLOW TECHNOLOGY
PROFESSIONALS
O BE TEACHERS OF RECORD FOR
AUGMENTIN INSTRUCTION IN A
PARTNERSHIP.
WITH ON CREDENTIALED TEACHERS
AND LAST WE HEARD A LOT ABOUT
THE STATISTICS ON THE BENEFITS A
CT. ONE THING THAT WAS NOT
MENTIONED AT ALL IS THAT THOSE
STUDIES.
THAT GIVE DIFFERENTIATE BY
GENDER.
FIND THAT THE BENEFIT IS
SUBSTANTIALLY HIGHER FOR MALES
AND AS SUCH FOR THE FOLKS OUT
HERE. I THINK THERE MAY BE A
CASE FOR THE LACK OF SUPPORT TO
CT  COULD BE LABELLED AS
DISCRIMINATION AGAINST MALE
STUDENTS.
THANK YOU.
ARE KEEP IT ONE MINUTE PLEASE I
WILL CUT YOU OFF AFTER ONE
MINUTE.
HELLO.
I'M MARIAH HER FOR WEARING
CURRENTLY A SENIOR AT HIM AT
HIGH SCHOOL SO. SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND I JUST WANTED TO
TAKE MORE OF A. PERSONAL RATTLE
IN THE AFFECT THAT CTE PROGRAMS
HAS PAT ON MYSELF AND THE
PERSONAL FACT THAT IT HAS NOT
NECESSARILY. THE STATISTICS THAT
WE'VE HEARD A LOT OF TODAY BUT
PERSONALLY I GREW UP IN A FAMILY
THAT IS NOT RELATED TO
AGRICULTURE WHATSOEVER AND HAD
SOME TROUBLING TIMES. CLOSE
BECAUSE OF AGRICULTURE EDUCATION
AND THE FFA WHICH STANDS FOR
FUTURE FARMERS OF AMERICA.
THAT I HAVE FOUND WHAT I WANT
TO DO WITH MY LIFE AND THAT I
HAVE FOUND A ROUTE IT WHETHER
IT'S ON NOT NECESSARILY A
TECHNICAL EDUCATION AFTER I DO
WANT TO ATTEND A FOUR YEAR
COLLEGE. BUT NOW BEING AND
AGRICULTURE COURSES UP FOR THE
REST OF MY LIFE I CAN BE AN
INFORMED CONSUMER AND AN
ADVOCATE FOR AGRICULTURE AND I
JUST REALLY WANTED TO EMPHASIZE.
THAT THERE IS A LOT OF ADULT
SUPPORT WHICH IS SO IMPORTANT
FOR STUDENTS BECAUSE WE NEED
THAT REPRESENTATION THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY VERY WELL DONE BY
THE WAY. OR WHETHER.
HELLO MY NAME IS HAILEY BALDWIN
I AM A SENIOR ESCONDIDO HIGH
SCHOOL IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY I AM
ALSO HERE WITH MARIAH WE ARE AT
A LEADERSHIP CONFERENCE RIGHT
NOW WITH THE FAA PROGRAM. THAT'S
CALLED SACRAMENTO LEADERSHIP
EXPERIENCE AND I'VE TAKEN THESE
OF CREE TECHNICAL COURSES SINCE
MY FRESHMAN YEAR AND THROUGH
THIS I HAVE LEARNED THE
IMPORTANCE AND THE EXTENT OF THE
AGRICULTURE INDUSTRY. AND IT'S
REALLY SHOW ME A PATHWAY FROM
FOR MY LIFE.
MY FAMILY WAS ALSO NOT INVOLVED
IN THE AG INDUSTRY BUT I'VE SEEN
THAT THERE'S MANY DIFFERENT
ASPECTS THAT WE NEED TO CONSIDER
AND WITH A GROWING POPULATION BY
YOUR TWENTY FIFTY THAT WOULD BE
AT LEAST NINE BILLION PEOPLE. WE
NEED TO PUT MORE IMPORTANCE IN
THIS INDUSTRY AND THESE PROGRAMS
HAVE TAUGHT ME THAT AND HAVE
GIVEN ME CONFIDENCE IN MY LIFE
AND A DIRECTION. THANK THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON OF CHARLEY
HOFFMAN AND SUPERINTENDENT FOR
SHASTA ATTORNEY ROP WHO HAVE
NORTH AND READING. OF THANK YOU
FOR THE HEARING THANK YOU FOR
YOUR INTEREST
CLEAR THAT THE PANEL REALLY GETS
OUR ISSUES AND AND THANK YOU FOR
THAT ICE PUSHED ESPECIALLY.
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEES.
QUESTIONING.
FOR THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO
ROUTE FUND ON GO ON GOING
FUNDING FOR CT AT THE HIGH
SCHOOL LEVEL WHICH IS A GREAT
THING. AROUND IN NOW THROUGH THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM AND
WHEN QUESTIONED ONE OF YOUR
PANELISTS.
OF THE LARGEST ANSWER THEY GAVE
WITH THAT WAS THAT.
THE STRONG WORKFORCE INITIATIVE
IS AN EXISTING REGIONAL
STRUCTURE.
AND I.
SOMETHING THAT NO YOU'RE MUCH OF
YOUR PANEL.
MEMBERS SEEM TO IMPLY BUT NOBODY
SAID WE HAVE A STRONG EXISTING
REGIONAL STRUCTURE ALREADY IN
PLACE
FOR HIGH SCHOOL CTA AND IT'S
CALLED ROP.
AND IT WAS NEVER DE FUNDED
BECAUSE IT DIDN'T WORK IT WAS
THE FUNDED TO SUPPORT LCF AB
WHICH HAS BEEN A GREAT THANK.
BUT ROP WAS NOT A CATEGORICAL AT
ON IT'S A REGIONAL CT DELIVERY
SYSTEM FOR AN ESSENTIAL PART OF
EDUCATION THANK YOU.
Q. FROSTING US
LYNDA GRACIOUS TRUSTEE OF THE
CITY CENTER METROID SILICON
VALLEY AND ALSO OF THE CAMPBELL
UNION HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICT.
WE HAVE MANY MANY STUDENTS WERE
OFFERED JOBS DURING THEIR
INSURANCE INTERNSHIPS AND OUR
LOCAL BUSINESSES ARE HIRING OUR
STUDENTS AS FAST AS WE CAN TRAIN
THEM THEY ARE HUNGRY FOR DEVELOP
TALENT.
MY DISTRICT CONTRIBUTES NINE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
ANNUALLY TO THE METRO AT CENTER.
AND WE ARE FACING DIFFICULT
CUTBACKS.
WE KNOW THAT WE MUST ENDEAVOR TO
MAINTAIN THIS CONTRIBUTION
WE HAVE TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY
SEVEN STUDENTS THERE SOME WITH
DISABILITIES MUST TAKING A
THROUGH G. APPROVED COURSES. AND
THEY'RE RECEIVING INSTRUCTION
AND THE DEPTH OF EXPERIENCE THAT
WE CANNOT PROVIDE WE HAVE NO
SPACE AT OUR SITES FOR
FACILITIES VISCO.
AND WE CANNOT PURCHASE THE STATE
OF THE ART EQUIPMENT NEEDED FOR
THE TWENTY FOUR PROGRAMS BEING
OFFERED.
WE JUST CELEBRATED OUR ONE
HUNDRED YEAR ANNIVERSARY BUT OUR
FUTURE IS IN JEOPARDY AND LESS
THE STATE RECOGNIZES THE VALUE
OF C.  CENTERS.
WE NEED DIRECT SUSTAINED
RELIABLE FUNDING FOR THE
EXCELLENT CENTERS THAT ARE
ALREADY SERVING HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS. WE OPERATE GRANT TO
GRANT ON A WING AND A PRAYER THE
CONSTANT EFFORT TO STAY SOLVENT
FAVORITES TIME AND ENERGY FROM
OUR CORPORATION THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS OUR
DOCTOR CHRIS POINT NINE WITH
ALAMEDA COUNTY OFFICE OF PAN AND
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
PATHWAYS TO COLLEGE AND CAREER.
WE CAME HERE TO SUPPORT.
THOUGH LEGISLATORS RESPONSE TO
THE GOVERNOR'S.
TRAILER BILL I THINKING THAT THE
NEW CITY E. IG FINDING WOULD
BEST SERVE OUR DISTRICTS.
FROM THE DISTRICTS WERE HEARING
THAT THEY REALLY ARE FEELING THE
ACCOUNTABILITY OF THE NEW
COLLEGE AND CAREER READINESS
INDICATORS. AND THEY NEED TO
BUMP UP THERE.
CTP PATHWAYS AND INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT WILL HELP SUPPORT THAT AS
THEY MOVE FORWARD TO REALLY
SERVE ALL STUDENTS.
WE HAVE A VARIETY OF
OPPORTUNITIES TO ENSURE EQUITY
AS WE PROGRESS SO THANK YOU FOR
THIS AND.
WE APPRECIATE YOUR. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU FOR
THIS I'M HEARING IT'S GREAT MY
NAME'S JULIE DUNCAN ON THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF TRI VALLEY R.
O. P. I SERVE DUBLIN PLEASANTON
LIVERMORE SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
WE'RE PREACHING TO THE CHOIR YOU
SUPPORT CD  BUT I THINK THE
QUESTION IS HOW DO YOU SUPPORT
CD.
AND I BELIEVE AB SEVENTEEN FORTY
THREE IS A START I LOVE IT FOR
FREE ONGOING DEDICATED FUNNY BUT
IF IT STARTS SOME I THINK THAT'S
IT. WE DON'T NEED TO REINVENT
THE SYSTEM.
WITH ITS C. TEGAS BEEN
PHENOMENAL THE CD HAS DONE A
GREAT JOB WE HAVE THE TECHNICAL
SYSTEM PROVIDERS THAT ARE FROM
I'VE WORKED MEDICAID HER FIFTEEN
YEARS I CAME FROM INDUSTRY I
LEARNED WHAT BUREAUCRACY MET
WHEN I CAME EDUCATION.
AND THE INCENTIVE GRANT HAS
PROVIDED STRUCTURES THAT ARE THE
BEST I'VE EVER SEEN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA DO I HAVE TO BE
HONEST WITH A QUESTION WE GOT
OUR TECHNICAL ASSISTANT PROVIDER
THAT GOES THE STATE OR NOT
CALLING FIFTEEN DIFFERENT PEOPLE
THEY OFFER PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT.
WE ARE WORKING WITH INDUSTRY
RIGHT NOW THESE ELEVEN ELEMENTS
THAT ARE IN THAT INCENTIVE
GRANT.
REQUIRE US TO WORK WITH BUSINESS
VERY HAVE BUT REQUIRE REQUIRE
THAT OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS WHO
HAD CT TEACHERS THAT MAYBE WORK
CREDENTIALED NOW THEY HAVE TO BE
IF THEY WANT THAT MONEY. WHERE
INCENTIVIZING FOLKS ACTUALLY DO
WHAT THEY SHOULD BE DOING SO
THANK YOU THANK YOU?
HI THANK YOU AND THANKS HER
HEARING US OUT MY NAME'S AMY
MILLER I'M NOT BOARD PRESIDENT
FOR THE DUBLIN UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND A FORMER CHAIR OF
THE TRIBALLI ROP. AND HE JUST
HEARD FROM THEIR SUPERINTENDENT
AND I JUST WANTED SHARE JUST A
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE EIGHTY
FIVE TO EIGHTY SEVEN PERCENT OF
OUR BUDGET GOES TO SALARIES
PENSION BENEFITS AND THAT DOES
NOT LEAVE A LOT OF MONEY FOR
COMPETING PRIORITIES. OF WHICH
NOW CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION
IS ONE OF THEM.
WE DO OUR BEST TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF OUR STUDENTS AND TO
HELP THEM FIND BALANCE AND
WITHOUT THE SEATED PROGRAM. A
DOUBLING COULD NOT HAVE
PARTICIPATED AND OFFER THE
CLASSES THAT WE'VE OFFERED OUR
STUDENTS. COME OVER HALF OF OUR
STUDENTS PROVIDE A ARE IN THESE
PROGRAMS SUCH AS BY A MINUTE
SPORTS MEDICINE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
MEDICAL OCCUPATIONS TO NAME A
FEW. THERE ARE OVER FIVE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY STUDENTS IN OUR REGION
THAT ARE OUT IN THE FIELD
WATCHING SURGERIES ON THE
FOOTBALL FIELD WITH YOU KNOW
THAT LEARNING USING THEIR SPORTS
MEDICINE.
AND WE ALSO SUPPORT THE MIDDLE
COLLEGE WHERE YOU HAVE HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS GRADUATING WITH
TWO YEARS OF COLLEGE ALREADY AND
IN DUBLIN NINETY EIGHT PERCENT
OF OUR STUDENTS DO GO ON TO
COLLEGE. AND THESE CLASSES MEET
THE EIGHT THIRTY REQUIREMENTS
BUT SOME OF THEM LEARN ABOUT
CAREERS THAT THEY'VE NEVER BEEN
EXPOSED TO LIKE MY SON WHO IS
NOW MAJORING APPLIED BUSINESS
DATA ANALYTICS. WHICH YOU'D
NEVER HEARD OF SO THANK YOU WE
NEED A PERMANENT FUNDING SOURCE
YEAR CT THANK YOU.
HELLO I'M TOM HANSEN THE
SUPERINTENDENT MISSION VALLEY
ROP IN SOUTHERN ALAMEDA COUNTY
AND SERVE.
FREMONT NEWARK AND UNION CITY I
JUST LIKE TO MAKE TWO POINTS I'M
I THINK THE THE FUNNELING OF A
TWO HUNDRED MILLION IN THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. IS A LITTLE
BIT OF A MISFIT IT'S NOT THAT
THAT WERE NEGATIVE ABOUT CTA
FUNDING OF COURSE BUT.
MY CENTER SERVES.
THIRTY FIVE HUNDRED STUDENTS.
.
ACROSS NINE SECTORS WE WILL NOT
FIND A RE A SINGLE OR JUST A
COLLECTION OF COMMUNITY COLLEGES
IN MY REGION. THAT SUPPORT NINE
SECTORS OF CT SO THERE IS THAT
THERE WILL BE BIASES IN CHOICES
MADE THAT DON'T DON'T SUPPORT
THE SECTORS. AT CENTERS AND LA
LOCAL DISTRICTS HAVE SUPPORTED
THEM. ARE THE SECOND THING I
WOULD SAY IT'S JUST AYE
YESTERDAY I MET WITH.
REPRESENTATIVES FROM
ASSOCIATION TRAINING CENTERS UP
PIPE FITTERS SPRINKLER FITTERS.
CONSTRUCTION TRADES AND.
.
CARPENTERS UNION
THEY YOU THEY WILL TELL YOU WE
WILL TAKE EVERY SINGLE HIGH
SCHOOL GRADUATE THAT YOU CAN
PRODUCE THAT'S QUALIFIED.
I'M SO THIS BE NO IN ONE RESPECT
DOESN'T HAVE A LOT TO DO WITH
UNITY COLLEGES TICKET EVERY
SINGLE STUDENT THAT'S PROHIBITS
I THANK YOU READY. THANK YOU BUT
I AM WHAT I WILL SHARE WITH YOU
AND OTHERS THANK YOU ARENA POINT
OF IF YOU DON'T LIKE. THE
GOVERNANCE MODEL THE CONSORTIUM
MODEL THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSING
PLEASE SHARE IT. WITH YOU ARE
SIMPLY MEMBER OR LOCAL SENATOR.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS LINDA
GRANGER I'M SUPERINTENDENT FOR
E. NARY A REGIONAL OCCUPATIONAL
PROGRAM SERVING THE STUDENTS
FROM CASTRO VALLEY HAY WORD SAN
LEANDRO IN SAN LORENZO UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICTS. AND I JUST
WANTED TO SAY THANK YOU FOR THAT
INVESTMENT IN CRITICAL EDUCATION
THROUGH THE CT INCENTIVE GRANT
THAT HAS ENABLED US AND PART TO
BRING BACK. UP PATHWAYS THAT
WERE ELIMINATED SUCH AS OUR
PUBLIC SERVICE PATHWAY WE'VE
EXPANDED THROUGH THAT GRANT AND
OFFERING ENGINEERING PATHWAYS
AND ENTREPRENEURSHIP PATHWAY SO
WE ARE NOW OFFERING.
OPPORTUNITIES FOR STUDENTS AND
ELEVEN INDUSTRY SECTORS IN OUR
DISTRICTS IN WHILE MY DISTRICTS
ARE COMMITTED TO PROVIDING THE
SERVICES TO OUR STUDENTS THROUGH
TWENTY TWENTY TWO BEYOND THAT IT
BECOMES A QUESTION AND WE WILL
BE FIGHTING FOR DOLLARS.
TO MAINTAIN PROGRAMS THAT WE
WORK SO HARD TO RESTORE. AND I
JUST WANTED TO REMIND YOU AND
REMAIN FOCUSED ON THE BENEFITS
THAT ARE PROGRAMS PROVIDE TO
STUDENTS AND I THINK THE MOST
RECENT EMAIL FROM ONE OF OUR
PARENTS ILLUSTRATES THIS.
I GOT A LETTER SAYING I WANTED
TO TAKE A MINUTE TO SAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR OFFERING MY
DAUGHTER THE OPPORTUNITY TO
VOLUNTEER AT THE GIVE KIDS A
SMILE EVENT. THAT WAS HELD
SATURDAY AT THE UNION CITY
DENTAL CARE CENTER SHE'S AN
ORIGINAL ASSISTING PROGRAM IT
WAS A GREAT OPPORTUNITY FOR HER
AS SHE IS THE DESIRE TO BECOME.
A DENTIST AND WILL BE GOING TO
THE UNIVERSITY OF PACIFIC IN THE
FALL. AFTER VOLUNTEERING HANNAH
TOLD HER FATHER AND I THAT IF
SHE WASN'T SURE BEFORE SHE NOW
KNOWS ONE HUNDRED PERCENT THAT
THIS IS THE CHOICE FOR HER.
BEING THERE WITH THE DENTIST AND
ASSISTANCE GAVE HER THE
CONFIDENCE TO BE ABLE TO ASSIST
THE PATIENT
SO I THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON A CHAIRMAN
O'CONNELL O'DONNELL SKIS ME.
AND.
DISTINGUISHED MEMBERS I'M
MATTHEW ROBERTS I'M WITH THEIR
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE I REPRESENT
VON TON QUAN LIVE ON AND THE
WORK FORCE AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT DIVISION. WANTED
JUSTICE TAKE A COUPLE OF MINUTES
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONTINUED
SUPPORT ON THE DISCUSSION OF
CAREER EDUCATION WE BELIEVE THAT
WE'RE TALKING THE SAME LANGUAGE
IN TERMS OF STUDENT OUTCOMES. IT
WAS STRONG WORKFORCE WERE VERY
VERY FLATTERED AND VERY VERY.
BEHIND THE THE INITIATIVE
THAT'S.
THAT'S PROVING OUTCOMES FOR
STUDENTS WHETHER IT WOULD BE.
FOR.
EMPLOYMENT EARNINGS OR WAGE
GAINS OR JUST COMPLETION AND ON
TO COLLEGE AND AND CAREER.
WE'RE VERY THRILLED ABOUT THE
THE WORK THAT WE'RE DOING TO.
TO CREATE SOCIAL MOBILITY FOR
STUDENTS.
AND TO FILL THESE MIDDLE SKILL
JOBS THAT ARE AVAILABLE AND WE
STAND READY TO WORK WITH OUR K.
TWELVE PARTNERS TO SORT OF
CONNECT THE METRICS AND CONNECT
THE OUTCOMES GOING FORWARD.
WE'D NEVER LIKE TO SEE
REDUCTIONS IN FUNDING IN ANY
WORSE OUR CAREER EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAMS BUT AGAIN WE STAND
READY TO TAKE WHATEVER PROPOSAL
IS IS PRESENTED THANK YOU THANK
YOU YOU CAN SHARE THE CHANCELLOR
THAT I THINK HE'S A GREAT GUY I
KNOW FROM LONG BEACH BUT I'M
NOT.
IN LOVE WITH GOVERNOR'S PLAN.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
MICHELLE SUDDEN I'M FROM SILICON
VALLEY VALLEY CAREER TECH AND IN
SAN JOSE I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF.
DEDICATED IMPERMANENT FUNDING
FOR CT PROGRAM'S HIGH QUALITY CT
PROGRAMS OFFER STUDENTS CLEAR
PATHWAYS AND INDUSTRY
CERTIFICATIONS AND POST
SECONDARY CERTIFICATION AND
DEGREES.
C. T. GIVES OUR STUDENTS CORE
ACADEMICS EMPLOYABILITY JOB
RELATED TECHNICAL SKILLS AND
THEY ARE JOB READY.
I WITHOUT SUSTAINED ON DEDICATED
C. T. FUNDING SUCCESSFUL
REGIONAL CENTERS BASED.
CT PROGRAMS ARE AT RISK AS
LOCAL PRESSURES AND PRIORITIES
THREATEN THESE PROGRAMS TO BE
OFFERED OR EXPANDED. OVER THE
LAST TWENTY TWO YEARS I'VE HAD
TAUGHT AT THE US WILL COME DALY
CAREER TECH ED.
TWELVE HUNDRED STUDENTS.
HUNDREDS OF STUDENTS ARE NOW
DENTAL ASSISTING DEL ASSISTANCE.
DENTAL HYGIENISTS AND DENTISTS.
.
LASTLY I WOULD LIKE TO INVITE
ALL OF YOU TO COME OUT TO OUR
OUR CENTER AND SEE OUR HIGH
QUALITY PROGRAMS AND STUDENTS IN
ACTION.
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME MY NAME IS RACE I
DIDN'T I'M ELECT GO INSTRUCTOR
FROM SILICON VALLEY CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION.
AND WE NEED DEDICATED A
PERMANENT FUNDING AND THE REASON
I COME ACROSS IT THIS WAYS. I
CAME FROM THE INDUSTRY LEXICAL.
TOOK A BIG PAY CUT TO COME AND
TEACH THIS TO YOU THOUGHT WHAT
THEY NEED TO DO TO GET THE
FILLED.
I DID THAT BECAUSE I YOU LOVE
COACHING AND GO LOVE THE YOUTH
AROUND ME.
FOR ME TO BE.
ABLE TO BE IN FRONT OF THEM AND
TEACHING THEM WHAT THEY NEED TO
KNOW I NEED TO KNOW THAT I'M
GONNA HAVE A JOB NEXT YEAR. AND
THE YEAR AFTER THAT AND THE YEAR
AFTER THAT.
I PLODDED TIME INVESTMENT INTO
THESE KIDS LOVE TO SEE THEM
SUCCEED.
BUT I HAD TO SUCCEED AS WELL I
NEED TO SUSTAIN.
A LIKELY HIT AS WELL. I TOOK A
PAY CUT TO COME BACK AND HELP
THE KIDS BUT I NEED TO KNOW THAT
MY JOBS CAN BE DOWN THERE TWO
THREE YEARS DOWN THE ROAD. AND
THE YEAR TO YEAR AND YEAR TO
YEAR HAS NOT.
BENEFICIAL HEALTHY IS ME AS A
TEACHER.
ON A YEAR TO YEAR BY WINDOW AND
NOT FIVE FORECAST FIVE YEARS OR
TEN YEARS DOWN THE ROAD WHERE I
MIGHT BE.
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO DO.
THINK FOR A TOPIC YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M ON THE OTHER
SIDE THE FENCE IN A WAY BECAUSE
I REPRESENT THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEFENSE WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AS A REGIONAL MANAGER
IN THE REGIONAL STATES AND
CALIFORNIA BEING MY MAIN FOCUS
AREA. FOR CURRENT DUCATION I AM
HERE TODAY TO BE AND HAVE A GOOD
FOR SCHOOLS BECAUSE OUR MISSION
IS NATIONWIDE IS EVERY STUDENT
MATTERS AND UNDERSTANDING THIS
AND EVERY STUDENT SHOULD HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY. TO EXPLORE
CAREERS THAT BEST FIT THEM TO
HAVE A SUCCESSFUL LIFE TO BE IN
OUR SOCIETY TO BE. WORKING AND
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO THAT WAY
OF ALL CHERISH AND EVERY STATE
ACROSS THE NATION. THE SONG IS
SUNG. GIVE OUR CHANGE OUR
STUDENTS A CHANCE AND EDUCATION
TO EXPLORE HER EXPLORATION AS
WHAT I DO. AND I DO THE ASSET
CREW EXPLORATION PROGRAM
ASSOCIATE. WAS SCHOOLS
NATIONWIDE WE FOUND OUT OUR BEST
OPPORTUNITY ARE FOR SCHOOLS.
THAT OFFER CT  PROGRAMS AND
I CAN SAY THE STATE MY GREAT SAY
THE CALIFORNIA DOESN'T EXCELLENT
JOB THEY CAN DO BETTER HOWEVER.
BUT I THINK WATER BEST BANG FOR
THE BUCK WHAT WE FOUND OUT
THROUGH ASSESSMENTS AS FAR
CENTERS HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
AND I'M ASSOCIATED WITH SILICON
VALLEY MY OFFICE IS OUT OF NASA
AT NASA AMES AND I'LL JUST SAY
QUICKLY. THAT WE HAVE A GREAT
CAREER CENTER INTACT AND I
BELIEVE THAT CAREER FUNDING
NEEDS TO BE HERE AND OUR STATE
AND OUR CENTERS AS WELL THANK
YOU HIGH SCHOOLS THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME I'M DANIEL BOTH BAY
I'M UP PRESIDENT OF MILPITAS
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT BOARD OF
A.
A SCHOOL BOARD I ALSO SERVE AT
METRO ED IN SAN JOSE.
FOR LAST EIGHT YEARS.
MILPITAS IS YOU KNOW IS TWELVE
SQUARE MILES WE HAVE A GREAT
DIRECTORS AND A GREAT AND A
RELATIONSHIP WITH OUR OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT WHERE
THE FIRST ONE IN THE STATE TO GO
INTO A PARTNERSHIP WITH THEM AND
TELL THEM KNOWLEDGE.
CAMPUS RIGHT ACROSS THE STREET
FROM THE HIGH SCHOOL.
SO WE HAVE THIRTY TWO HUNDRED
STUDENTS THERE ARE A LOT OF
WHICH GO TO OTHER METRO ED. AND
OUR SUPERINTENDENT DOWN THERE
HAS TO HAVE BAKE FOR HER FUNDS
FROM SIX SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT
PARTICIPATE IN THE JPA.
WE NEED SOME BETTER FUNDING FOR
THAT.
.
THE PROPOSAL TO GIVE THE FUNDING
TO THE CHANCELLOR OF THE
CHANCELLOR'S A NICE PERSON BUT
OF I DON'T EVER THE FUNDING IS
THERE.
AT ANYWAY THAT OF WE NEED TO
MOVE ALONG WITH THE. WITH OUR
FUNDING MODEL AND KEEP OUR
CENTERS ALIVE IN OPEN.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON KIM STONE OF
STONE ADVOCACY HERE ON BEHALF OF
ASSOCIATED BUILDERS AND
CONTRACTORS OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WHERE TRADE
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING MERIT
SHOP BUILDERS WHO SUPPORTS
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION TO
PROVIDE I'M OUR FUTURE
WORKFORCE.
AS YOU KNOW WE'VE GOT.
SKILLED WORKER SHORTAGES IN THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY MADE
PARTICULARLY WORST BUYS THE
RECENT FIRES IN THE NEED FOR
REBUILDING SO WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THESE EFFORTS AND THINK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRS AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ON MY NAME
SAMANTHA BIG ON A HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATE.
I JOIN CT IN MY JUNIOR YEAR OF
HIGH SCHOOL UP UNTIL THEN I'D
ONLY EVER HEARD OF ENGINEERING
AND IT REALLY KNOW WHAT IT WAS.
MIKE BREEN STARTED WITH AN
ENGINEERING PHYSICS CLASS WHICH
IS VERY HANDS ON IT WAS NEW TO
ME AND THAT I WAS LEARNING
THROUGH EXPERIENCE.
I JOIN THE AND COMPETED WITH
THE ROBOTICS AND SOLAR BOATS
TEAMS THERE AND I NOW ATTEND CAL
POLY POMONA WERE AND CONTINUE MY
EDUCATION ENGINEERING. I'VE
JOINED EXECUTIVE BOARDS OF
ENGINEERING CLUBS ON CAMPUS AND
INTERNET.
COMPANIES INCLUDING NASA JPL
AND. NOT THE BERMAN CORPORATION
NEEDLESS TO SAY THE CTE PROGRAM
DRAMATICALLY AFFECTED MY LIFE
FOR EVER AND CHANGE WHERE I'M
GOING. AND MANY OF THOSE WHO
WERE INVOLVED IN IT AS WELL. I
STARTED DURING SCHOOL MORE AND I
FELT LIKE THERE WAS A DIRECTION
AND PURPOSE TO MY EDUCATION. I
FELT LIKE MY LEARNING WAS MORE
MEANINGFUL AND APPLICABLE TO
EVERYDAY LIFE.
IT PREPARED ME FOR THE REAL
WORKING WORLD AND NOT JUST THE
THEORETICAL TEXTBOOK WORLD THAT
I'D BEEN USED TO BEFORE AND FOR
THESE REASONS I BELIEVE THE
GOVERNOR. GOVERNOR AND
LEGISLATURE.
BUT YOU SHOULD CONTINUE TO FUND
CD PROGRAMS IN THE STATE INJURY
TO.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MARRY CENTERS
WITH LOS ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE
OF EDUCATION JUVENILE COURT
SCHOOL. OUR POPULATION IS
COMPRISED OF STUDENTS HAVE MANY
EMOTIONAL DISORDERS AND MENTAL
DISABILITIES HAVE SPENT TIME IN
AND OUT OF DETENTION FACILITIES
AND COME FROM EXTREMELY UNSTABLE
HOME ENVIRONMENTS.
THEY COME TO US WITH A NEGATIVE
ATTITUDE TOWARDS SCHOOL WITH A
MAJORITY OF THEM HAVING SEVERE
GAP SOME BASIC MATH READING AND
LANGUAGE. THEY COME TO US WITH A
LACK OF BELIEF THAT THEY HAVE
ANY TYPE OF FUTURE.
OFFERING CITY COURSES HAS
ALLOWED OUR STUDENTS BECOME MORE
ENGAGE THEIR LESSONS WHILE
OFFERING PRACTICAL APPLICATIONS
OF KNOWLEDGE THAT HELPS THEM SEE
THE RELEVANCY OF INSTRUCTION AND
EVEN MORE IMPORTANTLY. A VIABLE
OPTION FOR A PRODUCTIVE FUTURE.
MATH LANGUAGE ARTS AND JOB SKILL
TRAINING ARE INTEGRATED INTO THE
PROGRAMMING STUDENTS SEE THE
DIRECT CORRELATION RELEVANCE OF
LEARNING AND THEY LEARN HOW TO
APPLY SKILLS IN A REAL WORLD
SETTING. OUR STUDENTS CAN FULLY
GRASP THE CONTENT AND UPON ABLE
TO UNDERSTAND AND ANSWER THE
QUESTION. WHY DOES LEARNING
MATTER? THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
FIRST OF ALL I LIKE TO
SINCERELY THANK YOU FOR GIVING
ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF AT CTE STUDENTS. MY
NAME IS MISSUS DROPPING OUR I'M
A MEDICAL ASSISTANT INSTRUCTOR.
AT SILICON VALLEY VALLEY CT
FOR FOURTEEN AND A HALF
YEARS AFFECTING TEACHING OUT OF
THE SAME ROOM I WAS TAUGHT AND
SO THAT'S LIFE HASN'T CIRCLES
THERE. I HAVE WITNESSED THE
TRANSFORMATION OF YOUNG PEOPLE'S
CHARACTER AND MINE.
SOME STUDENTS COME AND
STRUGGLING DISCOURAGE READY TO
DROP OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
AND ONCE THEY ENTER SEC T. AND
EXPERIENCE AS HE T. EDUCATION.
MANY LEAVE AS CONFIDENT
PROFESSIONALS TAX PAYING
INDIVIDUALS PURSUING COLLEGE
EDUCATION JUST LAST YEAR TWENTY
FOUR IN MAY STUDENTS ARE NOW
WORKING AFTER THEIR INTERNSHIP
AND THAT'S JUST ONE PROGRAM THAT
WE HAVE
C. T. E..
CT IS A KNOW IT A SAYS THAT
NOURISHES IT ENCOURAGE IT
CHALLENGES IT BUILDS CHARACTER.
IT INSTILLS MORALS IN TWO DAYS
YOU.
THE INNER CHARACTER I'M A PERSON
IS THE TRUE MEASURE OF LASTING
GREATNESS PARA GREAT BILLY
GRAHAM THINKING.
AND.
HELLO THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME
TO SPEAK.
CUDDLING IN THIS WHOLE KEY TRY
TO BE AS ARTICULATE FLOWING AS I
CAN.
MY NAME IS REACH YOU I'M A
CERTIFIED SURGICAL TECHNOLOGIST
FIRST ASSISTANT AND CERTIFY
ROBOTICS FIRST ASSISTANT.
I AM ALSO A TEACHER AT METRO ED
SILICON VALLEY.
TELECOMMUNICATION WAS STRONGER
WAS MY TEACHER. FOR THE SURGICAL
TECHNOLOGY PROGRAM AND I JUST
WANNA SAY THAT.
CT IS GIVING ME THE KNOWLEDGE
SKILLS CONFIDENCE ABILITY TO DO
MY JOB WITH A PROFICIENCY AND
ACCURACY.
MOON MY BACKGROUND WHERE AFTER
GRADUATING.
FROM MEASURE ED I WORK BECAUSE
OF SANTA CLARA FOR.
ROTH ABOUT FIFTEEN YEARS
O'CONNOR HOSPITALS WELL I HAVE
ALSO HELPED SEVERAL POSITIONS
OPEN UP TO HAVE A PRACTICE OF
THE LEAD SURGICAL TECHNOLOGIST.
I BECAME CHIEF PRECIP CHIEF
PRECEPTOR FOR EDUCATING OUR ALL
THE NEW NURSING SEVERAL TAX AND
MEDICAL STUDENTS COMING INTO THE
HOSPITAL WAS ALSO THE ONLY NON
MEDICAL AS THE ONLY NON MD.
EDUCATOR IN THE VIEW WHEN
RESIDENTS YOU RESIDENCY TRAINING
PROGRAM.
.
DOING ALL THESE THINGS OF THE
HOUSE WILL BE A VERY ACTIVE IN
THE MEASURE OF COMMITTEES AND
BEING PART EDUCATION AND
PERFORMING SURGERY WITH SO THE
TOP SURGEONS IN THE AREA. I
GAINED ALL THIS FROM A CD. AND
THEY'VE STRUCTURES HERE THE
SCHOOL IS THANK YOU THINK ABOUT.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON I'M JENNIFER
LOUIS LAMBERT THAT LINK LEARNING
ALLIANCE I THINK YOU SUMMED IT
SO MUCH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
O'DONNELL HOW MUCH THIS QUICK
WHEN HIT MY THREE MAIN POINTS
ON.
FOR.
FOR LINK LEARNING ALLIANCE I'M
FIRST LINK WINNING ALLIANCE
COMPARED TO THEIR PEERS.
OR.
OUR STUDENTS FROM AUSTIN GROUPS
DROPOUT LESS COMPARED AND DROP
OUT LESS COMPUTER THEIR PEERS.
AND THE COMPLETE MORE ATG
COURSES AND IT'S HIM MORE SKILLS
WHICH PROVIDES FOR BETTER
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES. AND
MORE IMPORTANTLY AT THESE
IMPROVE OUTCOMES ARE
PARTICULARLY SIGNIFICANT FOR
STUDENTS WHO ARE NOT EXPECTED TO
SUCCEED IN HIGH SCHOOL. AND THEN
THE SECOND POINT WHICH IS THAT
LINK CORNY WORKS WITH
ORGANIZATIONS SUCH AS TELL
CHAMBER. A JP MORGAN CHASE
KAISER PERMANENTE IN SORT OF
HEALTH BECAUSE WE ALL RECOGNIZE
THE NECESSITY IN DEVELOPING A
WORKFORCE.
FOR IT WITH TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY SKILLS AND COMPLETE A
POST SECONDARY CREDENTIALS AND
WE BELIEVE THAT WORKING WITH THE
ALLIANCE WILL HELP STRENGTH THEN
AND THE CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE.
AND OUR THIRD AND MAIN POINT
ALSO AS WELL AND WENT LEARNING
HAS CONCERNS WITH THEIR CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION INCENTIVE
GRANT DIE.
BECAUSE IT DOESN'T ENSURE AT
LENGTH LEARNING I'M WERE
CONCERNED AT THAT I IT DOESN'T
EXPLICITLY CONNECT WITH PROGRAMS
THAT PROVIDE POST SECONDARY AND
I THINK YOU. THINK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME GLENN
YAMASAKI NH BEEN TEACHING FOR
TWENTY SEVEN YEARS IN THE DOWNEY
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT. ALAS
TEN AS AN ENGINEERING PATH WE
TEACHER.
I'M WITH THE FULL SUPPORT OF MY
DISTRICT ON THE LOS ANGELES
OFFICE OF EDUCATION I'VE SEEN
THE TRANSFORMATION IN THESE KIDS
LEARNINGS.
KIDS USED TO LEAVE AT THREE
O'CLOCK AFTER SCHOOL TO GO HOME
TO PLAY VIDEO GAMES ARE HANGING
OUT MY ROOM TILL SIX O'CLOCK
DOING ROBOTICS WELDING ALL KINDS
OF THINGS. THEY'RE TAKING A
PERSONAL INTEREST IN THEIR
LEARNING NOW. ON THIS IDEA THAT
I'VE THAT I'VE HEARD THAT THE
ACADEMICS AND THE CT PALS ARE
MUTUALLY EXCLUSIVE. I DON'T BUY
INTO THAT BECAUSE OF THESE
TENURE AS MY OWN PERSONAL
STATISTICS I FOLLOWED.
IS OF MY SENIORS THAT HAVE
APPLIED TO CONTINUE ON. A WITH
ENGINEERING DEGREES A HUNDRED
PERCENT OF THEM HAVE BEEN
ACCEPTED INTO UNIVERSITIES.
SO THE CITY PROGRAM WORKS I HOPE
WE CONTINUE TO FIND EXPAND THE
PROGRAMS THANK YOU.
HELLO THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING US
TO BE HERE TODAY MY NAME IS
TIFFANY MORRIS I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF CAREER EDUCATION FOR
THE VENTURA COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION. WE SERVE TWENTY
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN OUR REGION
I'M HERE TODAY TO ASK YOU TO
PLEASE ALLOW US TO CONTINUE THE
WORK THAT WE'VE BEEN DOING OVER
THE LAST FIVE YEARS.
PLEASE VALUE THE MILLIONS AND
MILLIONS HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS THAT HAVE BEEN SPENT
THROUGH CCP T. AND CT INCENTIVE
GRANT. OUR SYSTEM ISN'T BROKEN
AS YOU CAN HEAR TODAY IT WORKS
PLEASE DON'T SUPPORT THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF A SYSTEM.
A NEW SYSTEM THAT SEEMS TO BE
IMPLIED IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
THAT SIZE THAT OUR SYSTEM ISN'T
WORKING IT WORKS GREAT. WE
SUPPORT AB SEVENTEEN FORTY THREE
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR WHEN HE
WAS DRESSED IN BROWN OF
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS. ARE WE LIKE THE
GOVERNOR'S FUNDING FOR CD WE
LOVE YOUR FUNDING FOR CD AND ALL
THE ISSUES WITH.
MOVING THE PROGRAM THROUGH
COMMUNITY COLLEGES DITTO OR NOT
IN SUPPORT OF THAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU MY NAME
IS JANET HAMMOND DIRECTORS. NCT
FOR THE COUNTRY COSTA
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION WE
SERVE ITEM ELEVEN THOUSAND
STUDENTS ANNUALLY IN THIRTY FOUR
HIGH SCHOOLS. IN CONTRA COSTA
AND ALAMEDA COUNTIES. OUR FEAR
IS THAT WHEN THE IF THE CITY
INCENTIVE GRANT IS ALLOWED TO
I'M SUNSET THAT MOST IF NOT ALL
OF THESE FABULOUS PROGRAMS ARE
GOING TO DISAPPEAR. BECAUSE
DISTRICTS SIMPLY CANNOT AFFORD
THE COST OF STATE SUSTAINING
THEM. SO JUST A REMINDER WERE ON
THE EDGE OF A CLIFF THAT
THREATENS TO SWALLOW UP CT
IS WE KNOW IT.
AND I'D LIKE YOU TO FOCUS FOR A
MOMENT ON THOSE ELEVEN THOUSAND
STUDENTS THAT MY PROGRAM SERVES
IF THOSE PROGRAMS ON AREN'T
THERE. ARE THEY GONNA BE PLACED
IN STUDY HALL INSTEAD OF
LEARNING HOW TO IN TURN IS A
ATHLETIC TRAINERS.
WILL THEY BE ASSIGNED AS
TEACHERS ASSISTANCE INSTEAD OF
LEARNING HOW TO TESTING ANALYZE
DNA. WILL THEY SIMPLY HAVE
SHORTER SCHOOL DAYS INSTEAD OF
LEARNING HOW TO DESIGN AND
PROGRAM ROBOTS.
WELL THEY NEVER HAVE THE CHANCE
TO LEARN COMPUTER CODING AND
APPLY IT IN A REAL WORLD
PROBLEM.
I'M HERE TO IMPLORE YOU.
TO SUPPORT PASS AND ADOPTED
SEVENTEEN FORTY THREE ON A
PERMANENT BASIS.
THANK YOU
I CONCUR.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU FOR
HAVING US JENNIFER HORTON I AM A
TEACHER ON SPECIAL ASSIGNMENT.
SUPPORTING STEM AND CT
FOR WESTERN PLASTER UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT OUT IN LINCOLN.
AND.
THE ELEVEN ELEMENTS HAVE BEEN
VERY HELPFUL THEY HAVE HELPED
KEEP US ON TRACK THAT HELP KEEP
US HONEST IN SPENDING OUR MONEY
ONLY ON CD STUDENTS.
THEY HAVE HELPED US REFLECT ON
OUR PROGRAMS AND IS ALSO HELPED
US TO DOCUMENT THE GROWTH OF OUR
PROGRAMS.
WITHOUT CT  AND FUNDING FOR
CD PROGRAM'S HIGH SCHOOL REALLY
BECOMES APPARENT SCHEME.
WHERE YOU HAVE EDUCATORS THAT
ONLY KNOW TRADITIONAL EDUCATION
MOST OF THEM TEACHING STUDENTS
TO BECOME PROFESSIONAL STUDENTS?
WE'RE CT  REALLY HELPS TO
BROADEN.
SO THAT THEY CAN SEE WHAT IS
REALLY OUT THERE FOR CAREER
OPPORTUNITIES THANK YOU.
YOU.
HI I'M GEORGE READ SOME THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR THE
CALIFORNIA AUTOMOTIVE TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION YOU JUST GOT A
HANDOUT THAT I GAVE YOU A WON'T
READER TO YOU. BUT ARE THE
BIGGEST CHALLENGES FOR
CALIFORNIA AUTOMOTIVE.
EDUCATION IS FINDING. A CAREER
READY TEACHERS.
I MEAN THAT THAT'S A HUGE
PROBLEM WE NEED TO ADDRESS THAT
IMMEDIATELY.
THE OTHER THING THAT THAT.
ISN'T A CHALLENGE FOR US IS
THAT THE PARENTS
THE PRINCIPALS. AND THE
COUNSELORS DON'T SEEM TO THINK
THAT AN AUTOMOTIVE.
REPAIR INDUSTRY JOB. IS A
RELIABLE CAREER.
IT'S NOT IT IS A VERY RELIABLE
CAREER THERE'S LOTS OF JOBS LOTS
OPPORTUNITIES.
LOTS OF MONEY TO BE MADE SO.
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION
FUNDING ESPECIALLY AUTOMOTIVE
FUNDING IS VERY IMPORTANT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH CALIFORNIA
AUTOMOTIVE BUSINESS
A COALITION IN THE AUTOMOTIVE
SERVICE COUNCILS OF CALIFORNIA.
WE WE THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
THEIR SUPPORT FOR CT EP OUT OF
OUR SHOP PROGRAMS PROVIDE HANDS
ON LEARNING THEY PROVIDE PROBLEM
SOLVING AND EMPLOYABILITY SKILLS
THAT LEAD TO GOOD PAYING JOBS.
BUT THERE ARE CHALLENGES YOU
JUST HEARD GEORGE SAID TALK
ABOUT AUTOMOTIVE INSTRUCTORS
THAT ARE RETIRING. AND.
AND THEY'RE NOT BEING REPLACED
AND SOME OF THOSE PRO WAS A I'VE
HAD BASICALLY CLOSING DOWN AND
SO WE WE NEED FUNDING NOT ONLY
FOR TEACHERS BUT WE NEED HIM FOR
TO UPDATE EQUIPMENT AND TOOLS.
AND WE REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MARIE
DELA CRUZ I'M THE CBO FOR METRO
ED. AND SILICON VALLEY CT I'VE
BEEN.
IN SCHOOL FINANCE MANAGING
SCHOOL BUDGETS FOR OVER THIRTEEN
YEARS NOW AND WE'VE SEEN OUR.
FUNDING MODEL CHANGE YEAR AFTER
YEAR AND IN THIS CURRENT MODEL
IT'S REALLY HUMBLING FOR US TO.
ASK OUR SIX MEMBERS DISTRICTS TO
SHARE THEIR FUNDING AND I'M HERE
TO HOPEFULLY.
SEE.
THE DAY THAT.
ROP IN EXISTING PROGRAMS LIKE
ROP CENTERS AND CITY CENTERS GET
DEDICATED PERMANENT. ONGOING
SEPARATE FUNDING THANK YOU.
MONA KLEIN I REPRESENT FAMILY
AND CONSUMER SCIENCE TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WE'RE
VERY INTERESTED IN DEVELOPING A
FOUR YEAR. DEGREE CREDENTIAL
PROGRAM FOR ALL C. T. TEACHERS
IN THE IT RELATED INDUSTRY
SECTORS.
GOT ANY IDEA ABOUT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WHO MIGHT HELP WITH THAT.
THANK YOU.
JERRY SHELTON ON BEHALF OF CARE
OP THE.
ASSOCIATION OF CAREER AND
COLLEGE READINESS ORGANIZATIONS
AND.
MAINLY WE JUST LIKE TO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR AND
THE OTHER CHAIRS THAT WERE
INVOLVED IN MEMBERS. AND THE
SHOW OF SUPPORT FOR CONTINUED.
STABLE AND ONGOING FUNDING FOR
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION.
ANYTHING THAT THE ASSOCIATION OR
I CAN DO TO SUPPORT THAT OF.
WE'RE READY TO HELP.
THANK YOU AND I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PARTICIPATION TODAY.
OBVIOUSLY THERE'S MORE WORK TO
DO AGAIN I ENCOURAGE YOU TO
CONTACT YOUR ASSEMBLYMEMBERS
YOUR SENATORS.
TO LET THEM KNOW HOW IMPORTANT
THIS ISSUE IS AND.
AND IN IN LEAN ON THEM. TO MAKE
SURE NOT ONLY THAT WE FUNDED.
BUT WE FUNDED.
IN THE RIGHT WAY SO THAT IS NOT
A REAL COPY CLICK COMP COULD A
COMPLICATED WAY FOR A LOCAL.
THE LOCAL ELEAZAR GET TO GET
THE FUNDING I'M VERY AGAIN YOU
HEARD ME TODAY'S I'M VERY
CONCERNED WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL HAPPY WITH THE ONGOING
FUNDING I LIKE TO BE MORE THAN
TWO HUNDRED MILLION. BUT AGAIN
THE STRUCTURE.
OR THE METHODOLOGY BY WHICH HE
GETS A LOCAL SEEMS TO BE TO BE A
LITTLE BIT CONFUSING AND A BIG
HURDLE COMING FORWARD SO THAT
THANK YOU.
ITS MAIN IS A JOURNEY